hey this is andrew brown your cloud
instructor and exam pro bringing you
another complete study course and this
time it's the google cloud digital
leader made available to you here on
free code camp so this course is
designed to help you
pass and achieve google issued
certification
and the way we're going to do that is by
going through lots of lecture content
follow alongs and using my cheat sheets
on the day of the exam
so you pass and you can take that
certification and put it on your resume
or linkedin
so you can get that cloud job or
promotion you've been looking for
just a bit about me i was previously the
cto of multiple ed tech companies with
15 years industry experience five years
specializing in the cloud
i'm an aws community hero i publish many
free cloud certification courses just
like this one
and i love star trek and coconut water
i just want to take a moment here to
thank viewers like you because you make
these free courses possible
if you're looking for more ways of
supporting more free courses just like
this one
the best ways to buy the extra study
material at exam pro dot co
and in particular for this certification
it's gcp
hyphen cdl there you can get study notes
flash cards quizlets
downloadable lectures which are the
slides to all the lecture videos
downloadable cheat sheets which by the
way are free if you just go sign
up practice exams you can also ask
questions and get
learning support if you want to keep up
to date
with new courses i'm working on the best
ways to follow me on twitter
at andrew brown and you i'd love to hear
if you passed your exam
or what you'd like to see next so there
you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are at the start of our journey
asking the most important question first
which is what is the google cloud
digital leader so the digital leader is
a fundamental or
a foundational cloud certification that
introduces you to the core concepts of
cloud
and google cloud in particular so this
certification will demonstrate a person
can define and understand
digital transformation cloud concepts
core services such as compute storage
databases and networking
security and cost management for
fundamental certifications they like to
always put a bit of emphasis on security
and cost management
and for the digital leader there's a lot
of talk about digital transformation
which is a
industry term but google uses it quite
frequently
not in the exam questions themselves but
something we'll have to understand
the certification has no known course
code so i'll be calling it the gcp
cdl this is the first certification you
should obtain
in your learning journey and i'll show
you in the next slide
why that is this is an easy course to
pass however
it is more challenging than other
fundamental certifications so
we'll spend quite a bit of time just
describing it compared to other
uh fundamental certifications so here is
the gcp roadmap
as you can see there aren't a lot of
certifications for gcp which is
a good thing because it's very focused
however it's a bit laid out differently
in the
in the fact that they have professional
certifications and these
are not necessarily difficult
so uh when you see a professional
certification for aws you know it's
really hard
but uh some of these or most of these
are like the difficulty of an aws
associate which is a bit odd uh then
they have an associate tier where they
only have a single certification and
then we have
the new uh foundational certification
the one we're looking at today
uh the cloud digital leader i've also
divided this here
we have the professional and i these are
also professional certifications here
but i kind of treat these as specialties
and that's what this line
indicates okay so uh in terms of your
learning path you should start with the
cloud digital leader
uh and especially for um gcp just
because of the way they write the
questions it's so different from the
other providers
i strongly recommend that you get
comfortable with the cloud digital
leader
very common to go for the cloud engineer
and after that the cloud architect the
cloud architect is like the solutions
architect associate
of gcp uh i mean it's harder than the
uh the solution architect associate but
it's not hard overall
and it's not as code heavy or
technology heavy it's more concept heavy
from there you can move on to the cloud
developer or the devops just depends on
your specialty
and then in the specialties it's up to
you what you want to do
collaboration engineer is a very
unusually named certification
this one in particular uh is
um it's like administration so like it's
uh you know setting up your organization
and networking it's a very odd name for
a certification
but they have it there if it was me if
it was me going into the specialties i'd
either go for the cloud security
engineer data engineer or machine
learning engineer
cloud networking i don't know how useful
that is neither is the collaborator okay
so how long should i study to pass the
gcp cdl so if you're new to
gcp you're looking at 25 hours of study
this is longer than what i generally
recommend for study times for
fundamentals but because the exams are
more difficult we'll talk about in a
moment that's why it's higher if you've
already passed the
certified aws certified cloud
practitioner or the azure fundamentals
you're looking at a 15 hour study time
um you know there is a lot of
transferable information but again it's
the fact that their exam questions are
uh more difficult
if you've passed either the solutions
architect associate or the
azure administrator
you're looking at a very short study
time you'll be uh
able to knock this out in a few days
okay so my recommended
study time is one to two hours for 14
days uh
generally with the az 900 or the
certified cloud partitioner i would say
just book it by the end of the week
for this one you need a little bit of
extra time so if you want to
book the exam to have confidence and
make sure you're going to commit to your
studies
i'd say book it 10 days 11 days or even
14 days in advance
okay so how does it compare against the
database
cloud practitioner and the az900
so the uh we'll use the cloud
practitioner as the
baseline for our fundamental
certifications because it was one of the
earliest ones
it's also one of the like the best
written ones
okay uh then we have our azure
fundamentals the az900 and then the
google digital leader so
baseline is going to be one right and so
the clf c01 is the easiest fundamental
certification still is today
has straightforward services it has
straightforward questions
well wooden questions and that's what
makes it so easy to pass
and to grasp uh cloud fundamental
knowledge
for the azure fundamentals uh this is
the az-900
it's a bit harder than the certified
cloud practitioner
just because azure's services are a
little bit more muddled
azure likes to or microsoft likes to uh
meet everyone's demands and so they
really tack on a lot of stuff
but that adds to a lot of confusion
whereas aws is very
isolated services the questions are
slightly more difficult just the way
they word them
and so it's 1.5 times harder when we're
looking at the google cloud
or the cloud digital leader it's three
times harder
than the cloud practitioner and i
believe that this was actually by design
because
i think that a lot of people think that
well because
the cloud practitioner is very easy um
that it
doesn't hold a lot of value so gcp
decided to just make this harder
i don't really agree with that approach
but that's what they did
now the services in gcp are probably the
easiest to learn out of all the
providers they're very very
straightforward
but the questions are presented in a
business-like scenario so it's a lot
like the solutions architect
associate exam and that makes it a lot
harder
to um to study for because you'll have
to spend more time with practice exams
okay
and there are some services where you'd
expect additional knowledge so one
example would be
um cloud storage where you have to
actually know the the the tiers
of cloud storage that's something that
you wouldn't see like aws with s3 you
wouldn't have to know that
and so there's those kind of stuff
another thing is they just have a lot of
tricky questions or poorly worded
questions i'd say out of the three they
have the worst written
exam questions uh now to say that
doesn't mean you shouldn't go get the
cloud digital leader i have this course
here for a reason i believe there's a
lot of value here
but you just have to understand that you
know there's trade-offs depending on
what you do with all these things okay
so uh where are you gonna take this exam
well uh you can take it in person
or in an online uh from the convenience
of your own home uh with other providers
you usually use psi
and pearson vue but google uses
criterion and actually the exam
experience was really good i liked it
out of
uh every single um online proctor system
i've ever used criterion
is great i don't know if they're
switching over to proctoru
they were using it for the g suite
certification um prior
and so i don't know if they're going to
switch providers it's i'm not really
i've read it at one place they said they
were but now they're not i so i don't
know but anyway if you are going to use
criterion it's pretty easy to use
if you've never heard the term proctored
it just means that there's somebody or
there's a supervisor monitoring you
right so even if you take it online
what they'll do is they'll ask you to
like uh at the start of the call and say
okay show us under your desk all four
walls
make sure you're not cheating right so
they're there to monitor you okay
and a proctor is technically also in
person but a lot of times we say proctor
exams we're referring to the online
exams
so what does it take to pass example you
got to watch the lecture videos memorize
key information
you're going to need to do hands-on labs
and follow along within your own gcp
account
now this is the thing um if you read the
if you read the requirements for gcp
they say you don't have to do any follow
alongs and that is a hundred percent
total lie so
uh it's just like there's no way there's
no way you'd pass without doing follow
along so i put in some follow alongs to
help you
cement that knowledge in this course
okay uh do
paid online practice exams normally for
um fundamental certifications you can
get away with not doing them so like the
az 900 or the certified club petitioner
it's that easy but in this case you
absolutely 100 percent
need practice exam questions because
just the way they word them they're so
hard
and i'm going to tell you right now i'm
the only provider that i know of that
actually have these questions because
you know i took the exam the day it came
out and i was the first to make sure i
had
a lot of questions okay so this
again this is harder this is very hard
to pass without practice exam questions
so
um you know go on the platform sign up
and
help support more free courses um but if
you do pass without using uh practice
exams i'd love to hear
uh like uh you and like how much extra
time you had to study okay
for the content outline uh there's
another oddity that they don't do is
they don't break down
each of the domains uh usually you'll
have a percentage here saying like okay
you're going to 20
of questions of this so we know where to
focus our time but google doesn't do
that
so we'll just read through the domains
here so setting up a cloud solution
environment
planning and configuring a cloud
solution deploying and implementing a
cloud solution ensuring successful
operation of a cloud solution
configuring access and security and the
distribution of these domains are not
known we do not know what they are
however on the marketing website they
said the following they said well
general knowledge
general uh uh google cloud knowledge and
google cloud product services this is
what the breakdown is this is not very
helpful because
i mean we need to know what these are
right because this is what they're
testing us on there's a huge breakdown
for this
but i mean like i guess you kind of get
the idea so um
do i think this is reflective yeah sure
i guess so
in terms of grading you just have to get
a 70 percent to pass it is
scaled like most other courses mean that
it's not always
exactly 70 to pass but generally that's
what it's going to be
in terms of the type of questions you'll
get 60 of them so you can afford to get
18 wrong
there's no penalty for wrong questions
the format of the questions are multiple
choice and multiple answer
i think i only saw one multiple answer
like out of the whole course so it's
mostly multiple choice
um which is great but again the
questions are the the
actual body of the questions is the hard
part okay for the duration you get 1.5
hours you get additional time a lot of
other providers give you only an hour so
i really appreciate they gave me extra
time i cleared it within 30 minutes but
i imagine that if you know
if this is your first time you'll need
that full time make sure you utilize
all of the time when you're taking that
when you're taking the exam
you can get 1.5 minutes per questions
other providers that only give you one
minute per question
so the exam time is 90 minutes the seat
time is 120 minutes
see time refers the amount of time that
you should allocate for the exam so that
includes
time to review instructions show online
proctor your workspace
read and accept the nda complete the
exam provide feedback at the end exam
uh and so you do want if you're taking
it online you have to show up early okay
and be
ready make sure your laptop is plugged
in this is actually valid for
three years which is great um aws used
to have them for two years i think they
extended the ccp to three years
azure is they're just good forever but i
like this thing where it's just three
years but there you go so that
is um the introduction here and what
we'll do is we'll go take a look at the
actual exam guide so i can just kind of
talk through
some of the things there like what i
thought actually
showed up on the exam as opposed to uh
didn't okay
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
we are taking a look at the official
exam guide on the google cloud website
now it's a bit different than other
providers which will give you a
downloadable pdf
but that's not what google does they
just make it inline html but before we
do that we're just going to look at the
exam overview
so here you can see where i grab those
general percentages
it's a hundred dollar registration fee
90 minutes this is going to vary based
on your region probably but
i mean i assume it's always showed up in
usd dollars they do have some
recommended resources
um which you can click through like
these here and they are terrible
and they are not relevant to the exam
and i actually went through every single
one of these
because i thought that um i might be
missing out on some information i'm
going to tell you
waste the time don't do it um i mean
like if you wanted to kind of get like
indoctrinated into the way google thinks
about their products sure
but i did not like them whatsoever
they're all available like
via quick labs there's probably coursera
courses but
the reason i make this course is because
i don't want you have to pay for
something to get access to that and
that's the whole reason here
um now there actually are there are
really good resources by uh google cloud
or developer advocates and that's stuff
that i do recommend but this stuff
absolutely not but let's make our way
over to the exam
guide okay and here it is it's pretty
darn long and so we'll just work our way
down here and i'll just say like what i
saw on the exam
what i didn't okay so at the top here we
have define
basic cloud technology so uh know the
difference between traditional
infrastructure public
private cloud yeah i think i saw one or
two questions on that where you had to
choose between private or public cloud
define cloud infrastructure ownership so
that's the
i don't know what that means i assume
that just means the shared
responsibility model
the share responsibility model did not
show up on my exam and neither on my
uh support engineers so you know that
wasn't uh
very useful information essentially
essential characteristics of cloud
computing
again uh i think actually i did see one
it was uh like multi-sol it was my only
multi-select one so yeah
i suppose you'd have to know that um
google doesn't have like
a official definition of characters of
cloud computing like azure and aws does
so i kind of just provided one that was
between the two of aws and azure okay
no difference between uh pass
infrastructure service
software service definitely saw
questions on that describe the
trade-offs between levels of management
uh flexibility when comparing cloud
services didn't see any questions on
that
to find the trade-offs between costs
versus responsibility didn't see any
questions on that either
appropriate implementation alignment
with given budget resources so there
they might be talking about like
different kinds of built-in cloud
reports
uh or using budget alarms so that was
definitely on the exam so
you'd want to know that capex and opex
total cost of
operations okay so aws calls it total
cost of um
ownership i guess operations is what
google calls it
never saw that in their documentation by
the way but i included it because i
assumed you know you need to know it
uh they don't ask that there they might
have had a i think they had like
an example of a capex so there was one
for that
um recognize the relationship between
the two summarize the cost
differences between cloud and on-premise
environments
not necessarily a direct question to it
but a lot of questions revolve around
migration or uh you know the difference
between
on-premise and cloud so not necessarily
call out to those questions but part of
a lot of questions okay
recognize uh your or general google
cloud knowledge recognize how google
cloud meets compliance requirements
locating current cloud google cloud
compliance requirements
um nope never never had a question on
that familiar with compliance report
manager never had a question on that
recognize the main elements of google
cloud resource hierarchy
uh yeah they actually had uh quite a few
questions on this
and these ones are hard you know i don't
even know why they put this in
at the fundamental level just seems too
hard but i cover this in the course for
sure
describe controlling and optimizing
google cloud costs
so billing models so that's the
different built-in models or reports to
find a consumption based uh
use model so um this is all like about
billing like sustainable use like
sustained billing and on-demand
and whether you use something that is um
uh like you're using reserved compute
things like that
uh describe google cloud's uh
geographical segmentation strategy
this is what i was surprised about the
most is that there was
no global infrastructure questions on my
exam whatsoever
and i always give a lot of attention to
global infrastructure and networking
because
those are some of the hardest concepts
understand the fundamental level but
they didn't have any questions
whatsoever they just focused a lot more
on resource hierarchies and
migration defined google cloud support
options
never ever saw a single question on
support like
hey what do you get if you get
enterprise no questions
nothing on slas either describe the
benefits of
google cloud vms google so uh
compute engine vm wear engine bare metal
didn't have any questions on that custom
versus standard sizing
um nope free premium and custom service
options attached storages preemptable
vms of course you need to know what
uh preemptable vms are um but like
this stuff not really like there's no
questions around bare metal
identify and evaluate container based
compute options
so define the function of a container
registry distinguish between vms
containers
google kubernetes engine uh no not
really i think i might have had a one
question about containers
i like to use cloud run identify and
evaluate serverless compute options
to find the function and use of app
engine
yes i had a few questions on app engine
between the distinction of
um standard versus flexible so you need
to know those two different plans
nothing on cloud functions define
rational rationale for versioning
with serverless compute options didn't
have a question on that cost and
performance tradeoffs
to scale to zero um no no questions on
that identify and evaluate multiple data
management offerings so describe the
difference between
uh google cloud's relational
non-relational database uh yeah i had
quite a few questions on that so
uh i saw all four of these options
presented to me during
questions describe google cloud's
database offering and how they compare
commercials offering nothing on that
distinguish between
mlai offerings i think they had like one
question about ml and it was just like
what would you use to do vision and it
was like vision api you know that was it
okay uh moving data around between
pipelines
uh yeah there was a lot of questions
about migration so
you know you had to know clearly the
difference between these offerings here
apply use case
to a high level google cloud
architecture so software development
life cycle never mentioned in the exams
describe google cloud platform
visibility alert offerings
that's just like billing alarms budget
alarms whatever they call them
describe solutions for migrating
workloads lots of stuff on this
lots of stuff on migrate for anthos
migrate to compute engine
something you need to know uh down
through networking no networking in the
in the exam whatsoever never ever i
don't even cover this in the course i
don't think sd-wan
but it was not on the exam and i would
not expect this on a fundamental
certification just makes no sense
describe the best connectivity option
between networking security requirements
um so you should know like interconnect
and then
establishing secure connections via via
vpn so those are pretty standard
private google access um yeah so that's
just making sure that uh you have
an instance that doesn't go out to the
internet uh define
identity and access features considering
included so cloud identity
uh google cloud directory sync i am so
all of those so yeah um that gives you
kind of an idea
um you know i would say this is not very
reflective of the actual exam
you know what i mean like i'd say like
you know 60 70 percent of the stuff
i saw um and i think maybe it's just
that uh
it's still early days and so if you're
watching this from a year from now for
my publish it maybe they've made more
questions but i just think they just
don't have a very large
question bank because when i had my
support engineers take it they're
getting pretty much the same stuff as i
was
where there was like why wasn't there
any global infrastructure stuff
so you know i was very thorough in this
course because i just
did not know what i was going to get and
there was nobody else before me that
made this course
so i just covered everything just in
case so if you're watching this from a
year or two from now you should be in
very good shape because i was very
thorough
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and what i want to show you here is an
additional resource that i think is
going to help you pass the google cloud
uh digital leader and so i'm here on
thecloudgirl.dev
and this website is by priyanka she's a
google uh
developer advocate so she knows her
stuff but what i find that's really
useful is she makes
all these great sketches that help
visualize
a lot of the core services so you know
i'm not doing tons of visualizations in
the course
uh and i'm just giving you just the need
to know information but
if you check these out it might help you
cement the information a bit better
and of course uh there's a lot of
accompanying uh videos to these sketches
here so if you go to the cloud girls
youtube there's a lot of great videos
here so i strongly recommend that if you
feel that you you feel that there's a
deficit whether it's
a compute engine or gke or whatever just
to go check out these additional
resources
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are at the start of our journey
for the cloud
digital leader google cloud
certification
asking the most important question first
which is what is
cloud computing so cloud computing per
definition
is the practice of using a network of
remote servers
hosted on the internet to store manage
and process data rather than
a local server or personal computer and
the way i like to think of it
is that if you're on premise you own the
servers
you hire the i.t people you pay the rent
and the real estate you take all the
risks but when you're using a cloud
provider
someone else owns the servers someone
else hires the it people someone else
pays or
rents the real estate and you're only
responsible for configuring cloud
services and code
and someone else takes care of the rest
okay
[Music]
so to truly understand cloud computing
we have to understand how we got to
cloud hosting
and the way to do that is we're going to
walk through
how servers changed over time and the
benefits and drawbacks to these
different types of servers so
the first on our list here is a
dedicated server this was a
physical machine that you would go out
to a store and you'd purchase and you
put it in your office
you'd have to set up the networking
install everything
even installed the operating system and
the great thing about these things
is that you would get full control over
your server
and so theoretically you would have the
highest level of security possible
i say it's theoretical because of course
with cloud computing you have all these
additional
services that monitor and do things for
you
but this was again the earliest option
out there
um and so they're still in use we still
have dedicated servers today
but you know it just made it very
inaccessible for most people to
be able to run web apps or etc then we
had
virtual private servers so we're still
using
one physical machine but now what we've
done is we've
isolated virtually isolated our
application
using something called virtual machines
basically into submachines and that
allows us to run
multiple workloads because if you have
different machines with or sorry
different apps with different
requirements
by virtualizing the machine we're now
able to meet the needs of each
application
and so that was the evolution there
going from there we had shared hosting
this became very popular in the early
2000s
if you've ever used godaddy or hostgator
you've used shared hosting
the idea is you'd have one physical
machine and instead of virtually
isolating
each customer or tenant from each other
you just had a folder on the machine
and you could have hundreds and hundreds
of businesses on a single machine
and the way the system worked is that
you know you had
limits in place but also uh there was
expectation that
there just would be a lot of people that
would be under utilizing
the physical machine and so there'd just
be a few people that might over
utilize it and so it would work out to
be very cheap
but you know because it's not full
virtualization
you don't have full access to the os and
things like that
so it was very limited and there was
also the chance that some other
customer could end up over utilizing the
machine and that could impact
your workload all right so then came
along
cloud hosting and this is where instead
of having a single machine
you had multiple machines and they
would have virtualization right
and so the idea is that now you could
have a lot more customers
on the exact same machine and it's
highly distributed so you don't have to
worry about
one customer over using a single machine
and you basically get the best of all
worlds so it's flexible
scalable it's really secure it's really
cost effective it's highly configurable
and that's basically the reason why
cloud hosting or cloud computing is so
uh popular today
[Music]
so before we talk about google cloud we
need to ask ourselves
what is google so google is an american
multinational technology corporation
headquartered in mountain view
california and its claim to fame was in
1996 when they invented the google
search engine and so uh the reason why
this is such a big deal was that uh
prior to google and really it didn't
really take off until 2000 because i
remember
when this thing came out where we saw
mass adoption but it was just that other
search engines at the time like alta
vista
hotbot all the ones out there just
couldn't do a very good job of finding
things but google
was smart that they would actually look
at the contents of web pages
they would cache them and that's how
they would determine whether
to serve you content another very
impressive thing that they did was they
didn't use high-end machines
they didn't have the money but they had
the money to buy up a bunch of low end
machines
and they created new technology to
distribute compute and storage across
those machines
and that technology is now open source
and it's called uh hadoop
and we'll talk about it later in the
course but that is something that was
very impressive as well so the name
google
uh is actually a play on the word google
it's just a different spelling
and that word uh precisely means 10 uh
to the power of 100 and so
if you represent it out in this way the
idea was that you had a 1 followed by
a lot of zeros and so i guess this is
google saying hey we are a data driven
company we work with a lot of data and
that's true they do
google is also an initialism for global
organization of oriented
group language of earth you can tell
that they came up with the word google
and then they just decided to try to
make it
uh into something make it to something
so i know that doesn't make a whole lot
of sense but it's just you know they're
having fun i guess back then
another thing we need to understand is
what is a cloud service provider so a
cloud service provider
commonly abbreviated to csp is a company
which provides
multiple cloud services and those cloud
services can be chained together
to create cloud architectures so here is
a
technical architecture for gcp and this
is actually a web application and this
is a pretty standard one so you might
run your web app on
compute engine which is where your
virtual machine is you might have assets
some things you need to store
into cloud storage let's see like your
files and stuff you need a database so
maybe you need a postgres database like
cloud sql
you might have a cdn that sits in front
of your web app just to
cache commonly occurring pages then you
need a mechanism to actually deploy the
application so maybe you want to set all
this up
deploy multiple apps the same structure
so you can use cloud deployment manager
and maybe you have a really fun uh
or a very useful way of doing customer
support by having
a conversational ai like dialog flow
so there are lots of applications out
there so this combination can get very
very variant but this is a pretty common
example okay
so now the question is what is the
google cloud platform well this is what
google calls their
uh their because they are a csp so this
is what they call
uh their platform and it's commonly
referred to as the
gcp and also it's google cloud so
i don't know why but they don't use the
word like in their logos they don't use
the word platform but
everyone knows it as google cloud
platform and we all call gcp
and the first service they came out with
was app engine
all the way back in 2008 i don't
remember them calling it google cloud at
the time i think it was just they wanted
a way for people to be able to
deploy applications really easily so
i'm a little bit fuzzy about that there
but now you know
when we look retroactively back you can
say okay app engine was the first
service they ever released then there's
also google workspace
and you're probably familiar with this
uh because everyone got their gmail
over 10 years ago and so google
workspace is just a rebranding of g
suite and so it's a bundled offering of
sas products for team communication
collaboration for an organization
so there you got google calendar gmail
google meet
google drive google sheets google docs
google slides and you know this course
isn't really about
google workspace or the g suite but you
know it does
overlap because when we talk about
identity getting access
to your google cloud console things like
that it can tie into google workspace
and so that's why
i'm mentioning here and you're going to
see it mentioned a few times in this
course okay
[Music]
so let's talk about the benefits or the
advantages of cloud computing uh no
matter what cloud service provider
you're using you need to know these and
they're generally six to seven points
uh and in particular for google cloud
they don't ask you
these questions on the fundamental exam
like they're not going to say can you
tell me three of the six
but uh they do matter you need to know
them because uh contextually they help
you
understand uh how to answer other
questions okay
and so google doesn't really have a list
like like azure and aws will actually
have a page and they'll say exactly what
they are
and so i just had to repurpose these uh
from azure here
uh just so that you could understand
what they are okay so the first one is
uh that cloud computing is cost
effective you pay for what you consume
there's no upfront cost uh so the idea
here is that you have
on-demand pricing or pay-as-you-go so
when we're talking about
aws likes to call it on-demand and azure
likes to call it pay as you go
and and so that's just two different
ways of saying it but
the idea here is you have thousands of
customers sharing the cost of resources
remember when we looked at
um cloud hosting and we saw that there
was more than one customer on the same
machine
that's how we're talking about it being
cost effective because you don't have to
pay for the entire machine another
benefit is that cloud computing allows
you to go global within minutes okay so
the idea is you if you want to launch a
workload
in canada in the us in the uk wherever
they have a region you just choose that
region and you can
launch that that's a huge advantage than
having a server in-house
whereas the larger on-premise
on-premises they might only have two
data centers in the us and that's just
not
sufficient okay then we're talking about
security
the cloud provider takes care of the
physical security
and a lot of their services by default
are designed to be secure so
they're less likely to have issues right
they're gonna they're gonna
try to enforce best practices and try to
lean you towards something
that is uh going to be better for your
benefit and you
have granular access uh to
control anything you want so this is
something you might not have if you were
self-hosting
but you can say i only want this
particular user
in my google console to only be able to
launch instances they can't shut them
down
maybe they can only choose a particular
size and so that level of granular
control
really does make it a lot more secure
okay
then you have reliability so a lot of
services will have
the ability to back up um they will have
they might have built in disaster
recovery or make it easy to
strategize for disaster recovery uh you
could have data replication
and fault tolerance so that is something
that is just
a lot more better than uh than on
premise okay
there's scalability so the idea is that
when you need more resources you don't
have to go out and buy a machine
you just press a button and now you have
additional additional
compute and if you're not using it even
like two minutes later if you say i
don't need this anymore you just shut it
down and so you only have to pay
for the duration that it runs and the
idea is you can scale up very quickly
uh so you know the your capacity uh
is very uh fitting to that then there's
the concept of elastic
and so scale scalable means you have the
ability to
add or remove machines or or compute or
storage
but elastic means that you can also
automate that so the idea is that
imagine you have a web app and a week
goes by
and you know the weekend's coming up
it's black friday so you know there's
gonna be a lot of sales
and so you might not be around to
provision enough machines you might not
know how many machines to provision for
that event
but uh with um the cloud you can
automate it so it'll just say okay you
have a lot more capacity now
we'll just do it for you we'll spin it
up to meet whatever that demand is
and when people stop using it we'll
we'll scale down the machines for you
we'll just get rid of them for you okay
and the last point here is that the
cloud is always current so
the idea is you have all this underlying
hardware and it has to be patched it has
to be upgraded there's always new
technologies coming out
and that stuff is being swapped out all
the time by the
um cloud provider and they're experts at
it right whereas if you bought a
physical machine
you're going to hold on to it for like
10 years but they might be switching out
machines every year
okay so you're gonna have uh you know
the best-in-class hardware
underlying okay or access to things okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're going to take a quick
look at the four main categories of
cloud services that you'll find on a
cloud service provider
so a cloud provider can have hundreds of
cloud services that are grouped into
various types of services
and the four most common types i like to
call these
the four core uh is uh and specifically
for
infrastructure as a service and we'll
talk about ias in the next video
but we have compute so imagine having a
virtual computer that can run
applications programs in code
then you have storage so imagine having
a virtual hard drive that can store
files
you have networking so imagine a virtual
network being able to define
internet connections or network
isolations and you have databases so
imagine a virtual database for
uh storing reporting data or a database
for general purpose web applications so
those
are the four core and we're going to
give them
some additional um attention this course
around the google cloud offering because
we're going to see them
in the exam and that's usually what
these fundamental certifications are
testing you on
okay and so for google they have 60 plus
cloud services they have
fewer than the other ones but for them
it's less about
having a lot of services and just having
very high quality services so
it's by design you know so when you see
like azure has 200
uh it's it's a little bit too much for
gcp is like okay we're just going to
make sure that these services are
multi-purpose so you don't have to have
as many
as these other ones okay and i just want
to say that the term cloud computing can
be used to refer to
all categories even though it has
compute in the name so
you'll say and i said this i didn't say
it up there but you know you might say
cloud computing but you really mean
everything right it doesn't matter what
it is everything is cloud computing okay
[Music]
so we're just looking at the categories
of cloud computing now let's take a look
at the
types of cloud computing and so we have
this pyramid on the left hand side
and the idea is that each type is
reliant on the
technology beneath it okay and so the
one at the top is called
software as a service also known as sas
and
it is a product that is run and managed
by the cloud service provider
so you don't worry about how the service
is maintained it just
works and remains available the keyword
here is software so imagine just using
any old software but it's
over the cloud on the internet so
salesforce gmail
office 365 you could even consider
facebook or twitter
software as a service okay and these are
specifically for customers the next
layer is
platform as a service also known as pass
and this focuses on the deployment and
management of your apps
so you don't worry about provisioning
configuring or understanding the
hardware os
you can just upload your code and it
will do the rest okay
and so here we would have things like
elastic bean stock on aws
heroku or google app engine and this is
the
original logo and i always love this
logo so i use it whenever i can
but the idea is that if you have a web
application you just want to deploy it
and just focus on your code
that's what a pass is and this is
specifically for
developers and then on the bottom we
have infrastructure as a service
iaas there's no easy way to say say this
as one word but this is the basic
building blocks of cloud i.t it provides
access to
networking features computers and data
storage space
so you do not worry about the it staff
the data centers and the hardware
and for uh we have microsoft azure
aws for google cloud
and this is specifically for admins and
basically when we talk about a cloud
service provider
one of the key components or
characteristics of a
cloud service provider is that they have
an infrastructure as a service offering
if they don't have that we don't usually
call them a
cloud service provider we just call them
a cloud platform
and google cloud originally was a cloud
platform you didn't have
ias offerings and so that's probably
where the origin of the name comes from
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the shared
responsibility model and this is a
simple visualization that helps you
determine what the customer is
responsible for
and what google is responsible for
related to the google cloud
platform and every cloud service
provider has one of these models
they vary generally the categories are
different they just break them down
slightly different but generally they're
all the same
so we're going to spend a little bit
extra time with the shared
responsibility model
just because it does show up on the exam
and it's a very important concept so i
just want to make sure that you know it
crystal clear and from all angles okay
so generally these things are broken
down into different categories so we
have infrastructure
as a service platform as a service
software as a service the types of cloud
computing
and then we have along the side a bunch
of
categories or responsibilities uh and
this again these are google specific
ones so you have content access policies
usage deployment web app security
identity operations
access and authentication network
security guest os data and its content
audit logging networking uh storage and
encryption
hardware kernel ipc inter protocol
something something
it doesn't matter but it's just
something the level
the boot uh hardware and so the idea is
that you have things that google are
responsible and things that you're
responsible for
so for a software it's a service and
notice how much blue there is
you have the least responsibility which
is great because then you can just focus
on
fewer things but remember sas is
something like
microsoft word so imagine what you could
put microsoft word you'd write your
article
right that's the content you might share
with somebody and you're just using the
platform so
that's sas then you have platform as a
service
remember this is like something like app
engine where you have your web
applications you've built it ruby on
rails larvarelle
nextgs whatever you want you deploy it
you upload your code so that's the
content itself
and you you have to choose how you want
to deploy it and you're
responsible for the security of that
application because you're the one who
built it right
um so there's that there's
infrastructure as a service this is the
basic building blocks
the idea here is you can launch a
virtual machine
and so if you do that then you are
responsible for the guest os so you're
actually
adjusting os layer stuff and then
everything under
underneath is is google's responsibility
so
the customer is responsible for the data
and the configuration of access controls
that reside in gcp
the customer is responsible for the
configuration of cloud services and
granting access
via permissions notice i keep using the
word configuration i highlight in red
it's just to help you remember
if you can configure it you're
responsible for it google is generally
responsible for the underlying
infrastructure so it's the hardware
this is a concept from aws i wish all of
them would use it
but the idea is there's in the cloud and
of the cloud so in the cloud is talking
about you the customer
if you can configure or store it the
customer then you are responsible for it
and of the cloud is if you cannot
configure it then google
is generally the one that is going to be
responsible for it okay
[Music]
so now that we've looked at the google's
shared responsibility model let's take
uh something like compute and compare it
across
different types of cloud computing so we
can understand and practice
uh you know what we would be responsible
for or not responsible for
so we have infrastructure as a service
platform as a service software as a
service
and notice we have another one here
called function as a service
you don't usually see these in the
shared responsibility model and it is a
type of cloud computing
but it's kind of a bit of a hybrid okay
so uh it's kind of an edge case and it's
going to just help us understand some of
the caveats and how these models
are a little bit flawed okay so starting
at the
the bare bottom where we have the most
responsibility is with bare metal
and so bare metal just means that
uh it's a physical machine and you're
basically responsible for everything
else you just want
the the cloud service provider to take
care of the hardware for you
so you have control over the host the
host operating system
so literally what's going to be
installed on the phys at the lowest
level
and so at this level that means you can
control the hypervisor if you want to
install
some type of different kind of
virtualization or have no virtualization
all
it's all up to you and so you are the
most responsible this layer
then you have vms virtual machines and
so
this would be compute engine i wrote
compute engine here because i'm not
really sure what the offering is for
bare metal
bare metal is expensive so that's just
why okay but for
uh virtual machines uh here the idea is
you're responsible for the
guest os configuration level that's the
os that is running when you have
um you know a submachine running on top
of the hypervisor
you could also install a container
runtime and so when you think of
and technically uh technically this is a
a little bit of an odd one because
for google you can actually check box on
and say i want this virtual machine to
have containerization so technically
technically
this would be google's responsibility
but if you wanted to you could install
your own
container runtime okay and so
here we see google is responsible for
the hypervisor and the physical machine
all right looking at containers and we
have a few different options here but
we'll talk about
google kubernetes engine gke
and the idea here is that you are not
worrying about the os
anymore you're configuring your
containers and you're worried about the
deployment of the containers and the
storage of your containers so google's
taking care of the
uh the os uh if there's a hypervisor a
hypervisor
and if there's a and the container
runtime so they're doing a lot of stuff
there and so
uh you're getting less and less
responsibility then you have platform as
a service
so this uh would be a managed platform
like app engine
and so here you're just uploading your
code you're say uh
you have some configuration of the
environment you have to uh
choose the type of deployment strategy
you want you have to configure any
associated services but google is going
to be responsible for the server
the os the networking the storage the
security a lot more stuff
okay then you have software as a service
uh there's not a lot of sas products on
google cloud but like we'll just pull
one from the google workspace or g suite
like
google docs and so here you're just
worried about the contents of the
documents
the management of files the
configuration of sharing access controls
and google is just responsible for the
server the os network the storage
security security
uh deployments other like more more
stuff than platform as a service
then you have function as a service and
this one's a bit of an oddball because
here this is serverless compute okay
cloud functions is serverless
but you upload your code sounds a lot
like platform as a service but you don't
have to worry about deployments
about scaling anything else it takes
care of everything so deployment
container runtime networking storage
security
physical machine uh you know every
everything
okay there's another service i don't
have it on here but it's called
um it's called uh cloud run
and that is a serverless container and
so that's where you have it and it's
it's it's technically containers it's
technically serverless so it kind of
like fits
fits in the middle so i'm just saying
that there's some variation there the
exam is not going to be that hard to
figure out what these are but i just
want you to know that there is some
caveats or
variations to this stuff okay it's not
clear cut as you might think it is
just to give a better visual here we'll
just go across bare metal dedicated
hosts virtual machines container
functions
we didn't cover this i just didn't have
room but there was soul tenant node
because when you have a virtual machine
right a virtual machine can either be
single tenant or
multi-tenant and so what that means is
that when it's multi-tenant
and that's the whole advantage of cloud
is that you have the same
you have multiple customers using the
same physical machine but you're
virtually isolated using
having your own virtual machines but if
you wanted to
have the entire physical machine you
could have a sole tenant node so you're
the only person
on that physical machine with those
virtual machines and so that's something
that's in between bare metal
and virtual machine okay so
just looking at the responsibility of
the customer level of control
like look at code here so code you're
responsible across the board
for app containers it's up to the
containers at functions
you're not responsible for it for the
runtime you have control over that in
containers right if you want to run
ruby you can just make a ruby docker
file and upload it now you can run
ruby code you know if they didn't
support it for the operating system
you have control the guest os here for
virtual machines
for the dedicated hosts it's still guest
os and then
at the bare metal it's hardware os for
virtualization if you want to change out
the type of hypervisor or virtualization
method
only bare metal is going to let you do
that so hopefully that gives you a very
clear picture
of the shared responsive model in action
and for different types of categories
it's going to be completely different
okay
[Music]
so let's take a look at an alternate way
of viewing the shared responsibility
model
and this is the way aws and azure does
it and the reason i want to show it to
you is because it's a lot more
uh uh encompassing of everything that
the cloud can offer you
whereas the google shared responsibility
models really focused on the application
so you can really tell they're
developers right
but it's important for you to understand
the full scope so we have
the customer and we have gcp so gcp is
responsible for the hardware
and the global infrastructure so the
regions
right uh you know like the everything
that has to do with regions
uh the zones and zones is a collection
of data centers within a region
and the fault domains fault domains is
um a logical isolate
isolation of uh hardware that's within a
data center
and then there's the physical security
of the data center they're responsible
for that as well
right then you have software so
uh this breaks down to the core four so
you've got your compute your storage
your database
and your networking now onto the
customer side
there's the configuration of managed
services or third-party software
so that could be platforms applications
iam
im's a big one that's a huge huge
component for customer responsibility
configuration configuration of virtual
infrastructure and systems so
operating systems the network firewall
so i noticed you see networking down
below so we're talking about
the actual like routers and switch and
things like this and up here this is
like cloud networking okay this is like
i want to create a vpc uh and i want to
have these subnets in it
and i want to use these cloud networking
services but you're not really dealing
with
lower level software like setting up the
the switch or the router or things like
that okay
then you have security configuration of
data so uh you know whether to use
client-side data encryption whether you
are whether you're using server-side
encryption whether you turned it on what
type of encryption you want to use
protecting the network traffic so
whether you're monitoring it
and put any other kinds of controls to
say okay who's allowed to see what
and your customer data that's a big one
okay so yeah this is basically the aws
um and azure way of looking at or sorry
i said azure but it's more like aws and
oracle azure actually has their own way
it's actually looks a lot more like this
and so theirs they do on-premise they
put on-premise in the mix infrastructure
as a service platform is a service and
software is a service
and so they just break it down to here
and these are going to look very very
very similar
to the google's one so you have
applications uh data
runtime middleware os virtualization
server storage networking how many user
one two three four five six seven eight
nine
these almost almost match up to the osi
uh layer that's the uh like the layers
like the application layer the
networking layer things like that
and so that's basically how azure kind
of does it but it just helps you to see
the names in a different way so
you can see there's still data there's
no mention of like access controls but
it's just assumed that if you have an
application responsible for it
you know things like that okay so
hopefully that gives you a really clear
understanding of the shared
responsibility model
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the cloud
computing deployment models
this one's an important one it will show
up your exam so you want to know the
difference
starting the top here we have public
cloud and this is where everything is
built on the cloud service provider
uh this is also known as being cloud
native so the idea here and i know this
is an aws example and we're doing gcp
just didn't have time to make the new uh
the new graphic here but the idea is
that you have a virtual machine
and a database that's sitting within
subnets within a vpc
uh both aws and google call their vpcs
the same thing so
that makes it easy here and everything's
contained within the cloud service
provider there's no cloud services
outside the cloud service provider okay
then you have private cloud this is
where everything is built on the
company's data center
this is also known as on-premise because
it's
on the premises uh where your office is
and so here you
would use something like openstack to
have private uh private cloud
so openstack i believe it's by rackspace
and the idea here is that it gives you
a lot of the benefits where like imagine
you want to distribute
a virtual machine across many machines
you want to have granular permissions
like
iam and things like that that's what
private cloud is going to do for you
then you got hybrid and hybrid cloud is
where you are using
both private and public cloud and you're
connecting them right you're
off offloading some of your private
cloud compute storage stuff
to the public cloud and that's happening
uh via some kind of hybrid connection
okay
and then we have cross cloud also known
as multi-cloud
a lot of people will call it hybrid
cloud it's not hybrid cloud hybrid cloud
is when you have a private cloud
and a public cloud connected a
cross-cloud is when you are
using multiple multiple
csps and the the workload is spread
across them a really good example here
is something like azure arc or for
google's offering they call there's
anthos
so the idea is that you have a control
plane that will control compute across
multiple cloud providers in on premise
environments
multi-cloud multiple cloud providers or
multi-cloud is just when you use
multiple
providers but you don't necessarily use
data across them okay but
google's going to just treat multi-cloud
and cross-cloud as the same terminology
all right
to try to just kind of give this more of
um
like a business use case or who's using
these things
we talk about uh for cloud this is or
public cloud we're fully utilizing cloud
computing
this is where we're using cloud and
on-premise and this is where uh we're
deploying on-premise using
virtualization
it's sometimes known as private cloud
okay so who's using cloud like public
cloud we're looking at
startups sas offerings new projects and
companies so think of base camp
dropbox squarespace for hybrid we have
banks
fintech investment management large
professional service providers
legacy on premise there's reasons why
they're hybrid they have to keep
certain data on on premise
for regulatory reasons or it could be
because
of um just because they've had they have
so much infrastructure it's just too
hard to move
everything away or they have customers
that are concerned about
the cloud or the public cloud when we're
talking about the public sector like
government
or hospitals with super sensitive data
or very very large enterprises with
crazy regulation like insurance
companies
they might want to have a hundred
percent private cloud
they're starting to um adopt a hybrid
model so
uh we're seeing less and less of this
but you know like hospitals aig which is
insurance company or the government of
canada okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the total cost of
ownership
also known as tco to really understand
what it is that uh you know we are
paying for when we're using on-premise
and what we're paying for or not have to
pay for when we're using gcp
these break down to kpex and opex notice
here at the top we're going to talk
about that in the next slide here
now google cloud doesn't actually ever
mention tco
uh even though it's pretty common across
all the other cloud service providers
but it does tie back to capex and opec
so we're going to cover it anyway and
it's good to know this
okay so to understand the tco concept i
have these icebergs
to really make sure or to sell you that
these are icebergs i put some penguins
and a whale on it here for you
but the idea is that we have things that
are above the surface
and these are things that we generally
think about and then the things below
the surface under the water
are the things that we're not thinking
about that really should helps us factor
in the
total cost of ownership so we're looking
at things that are obvious people think
about well
uh you know for on premise we just have
to pay for our software license fees
right if you have
um microsoft uh servers you pay for
those licenses
and then on gcp well you just pay
subscription fees so maybe you're not
paying for the licenses
but now you're just paying for using the
services
on demand right and so they might look
at and say well you know the costs
aren't
they look pretty comparable but then
when you get below the surface
we talk about because remember on
premise you you have control
you have those physical machines there
right so there's the implementation the
configuration
the training the physical security the
hardware
the it personnel the maintenance there's
a lot of cost
in um actually having those physical
machines and all the stuff around them
where
as uh in the cloud service provider you
are worried about the implementation the
configuration
training like how to use cloud services
but you're not worried about all that
other physical stuff
and the idea here is that you can save
up to 75 percent
shifting over to a cloud service
provider
uh gcp doesn't have an example of a cost
saving example but aws does and they
showed like 75
it's going to be the same for all the
csps and the idea now is all this stuff
in the red here is now the cloud service
provider's responsibility you don't have
to worry about it
so let's talk about capital versus
operational expenditures so
capital expenditures known as capex and
operational expenditures known as
opecs right and so on the capex side
this is where you're spending money
upfront on physical infrastructure
and deducting that expense from your tax
bill over time
so that's where a lot of people go well
you know i can get this machine and then
write it off
uh year after year and i guess that
sounds okay but you're going to save
way more money way way more money than
getting that that small
tax benefit but let's talk about what
are kpex expenses so
you have server server costs of the
computers the storage costs so like hard
drives
network costs routers cables switches
backup and archive costs
disaster recovery costs data center
costs so rent cooling physical security
the technical personnel so with capital
expenses you have to
guess up front what you're going to plan
on spending right because you're going
to
once you have those you're going to hold
on to them for a period of time right
for operational expenditures the cost
associ associated with the on-premise
data center
has now shifted to the service providers
so you only have to worry about
non-physical costs so this is leasing
software and customizing features
training employees and customer services
paying for cloud support
your billing is based on cloud metrics
so compute usage
storage usage and with operational
expenses you can try a product or
service without having to invest
in the equipment so you can spend a lot
more time in things that matter to grow
your business
and you don't have to immediately commit
to a bunch of stuff
you have a lot of flexibility there okay
so that's the huge difference
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at cloud architecture
terminologies so these are very
important concepts when uh
utilizing the cloud uh though google
will not ask you directly on their
certification
uh to describe these concepts or to to
to
pick them out of a lineup of terms okay
however
they are still going to play into
questions so we generally need to know
what these things are
so let's go through the quick list here
and then we'll do a bit of a deeper dive
on
each of these ones okay so first we have
availability
your ability to ensure a service remains
available this is known as highly
available
aha you have scalability your ability to
rapidly grow
unimpeded you have elasticity your
ability to shrink and grow to meet the
demand
and this has to do with the automation
of it you have fault tolerance your
ability to prevent a failure you have
disaster recovery your ability to
recover from a failure
failure also known as being highly
durable so dr
so looking first in more detail here
high availability this is your ability
for your service to remain available
by ensuring there is no single point of
failure or to ensure a certain level of
performance
so i got a bunch of text here but i have
a graphic that makes this really clear
the idea here is that we have a load
balancer
and and for google's it's called google
uh cloud load balancing
and the idea is that we have compute and
we distribute it um so it's separate
virtual machines but
they are in three uh uh different
zones and the idea is that if you were
to lose one or two zones you would still
have a running uh service because the
load balancer would detect that these
ones are unhealthy and reroute the
traffic
to the remaining server okay and that
helps us be
uh be highly available then you have the
idea of
being uh highly scalable so your ability
to increase your capacity based on
the increasing demand of traffic memory
and computing power okay
so you have vertical scaling this is
where you are scaling up you are
increasing
the size of the single machine right so
maybe you are increasing the amount of
storage
the amount of compute things like that
resizing the machine then you have
horizontal scaling so you're
you're just adding additional servers of
the same size and then you're
distributing the workload across those
machines
okay you have high elasticity so your
ability to automatically increase or
decrease your capacity based on the
current demands of traffic memory and
computing power
sounds very similar to the last slide
but the key difference is that it's
automated and you also have the ability
to decrease
okay so the idea here is that uh you
have the
concept of horizontal scaling where you
can scale out
but you can also scale in so scaling out
is when you
add more servers and scaling in is when
you remove servers okay
and generally generally speaking when
we're doing uh
uh things that are elastic it's usually
of the same size there is an exception
where you can have containers
i think it's like mesos or whatever they
allow you to have a mix and match of
different
kind of containers but generally it's
the same size containers okay or virtual
machines i should say
so vertical scaling is generally hard
for traditional architecture so you're
not going to see the concept of
elasticity with vertical scaling it's
with horizontal scaling okay
the way we can do horizontal scaling or
elastic automatic scaling is with
managed instance groups with
google so this is automatically
increasing or decreasing the response
to demand or a defined schedule next we
have fault tolerance so your ability to
uh for your service to ensure there is
no single point of failure or preventing
the chance of failure so i'm just going
to lay out all the stuff here
and so it sounds very similar to high
availability but the idea is that it's
all about preventing
chance of failure so the idea is that um
imagine
or i guess it's kind of the response of
failure so the idea here is that
let's imagine you have a database and
the
primary database for whatever reason
fails okay
and so the idea is that uh your cloud
dns which is at the
like your domain level what it can do is
say okay
fail over to the secondary instance so
you have a redundant application running
you're syncing that data over it's a
standby service the idea is that it's
ready to take over when the first one
fails
okay so whether something happens we can
fault over to it i know it gets
confusing with high availability
we have high durability your ability to
recover from a disaster and to prevent
the loss of data
so solutions that recover from a
disaster is known as disaster recovery
how do you back up your data how fast
can you restore that backup
does your backup still work how do you
ensure your current live data is not
corrupt so there you go that is
our terminologies okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the evolution of
computing
your cloud service provider has all of
these offerings and the idea is that you
need to choose the one that meets your
use case
a lot of times this all has to come
around the utilization of space that's
what we're trying to illustrate here in
this section here
and the trade-offs of why you might want
to use some of these offerings okay
for dedicated we're talking about a a
physically
a physical server wholly utilized by a
single customer that's considered
single tenant and for google cloud we're
talking about
um single node clusters and bare metal
machines where you have control of the
virtualization so you can install any
kind of hypervisor or virtualization you
want the system
the trade-off here though is that you
have to guess up front what your
capacity is going to be
and you're never going to 100 utilize
that machine because it's going to have
to be a bit under in case
the utilization goes up that's you're
choosing the cpus and the memories
you're going to end up overpaying
because you're you'll have under
underutilized server it's not going to
be easy to vertically scale it's not
like you can just say resize it because
the machine you have is what you have
right
you can't add more i mean i suppose they
can insert more memory for you but
that's a manual migration
so it's very difficult um and replacing
the server is also very difficult okay
so you're limited by the host operating
system it's not
virtualized so whatever is on there is
on there um and that's what your apps
are gonna have access to
uh if you decide to run more than one
app which is not a good practice for
these kind of machines
you're going to end up with resource
sharing where one machine might utilize
more than the others
technically with a dedicated machine you
have a guarantee of security privacy and
full utility of the underlying resources
i put an asterisk there because
yes it's more secure but be uh but
it's up to you to make sure that it's
more secure so you have that's up to
your skills of security right
whereas if you had a virtual machine or
anything above that
there's more responsibility on the cloud
service provider to just provide
a circuit secure machine and they can do
a better job than you so
why would you use a dedicated machine
well maybe you're doing high performance
computing where you need
these machines like very close together
and you have to choose what kind of
virtualization you need to have
okay so then we're looking at virtual
machines
the idea here is you can run a machine
within a machine the way that works is
we have a hypervisor this is a
software layer that lets you run the
virtual machines the idea here is now
it's a multi-tenant you can share the
cost with multiple customers
you're paying for a fraction of the
server uh you'll still end up overpaying
for the underutilized virtual machine
because a virtual machine is just like
you have to still say how many vcpus how
much memory
and your app is you know you don't want
an app that uses 100
right you want to use exactly the amount
you need but you can see here
you know there's still going to be some
under utilization uh
you're limited by the guest operating
system now but now it's virtualized so
at least it's very easy to possibly
migrate away
if you choose to run more than one app
on a virtual machine
it can still run into resource sharing
conflicts
it's easier to export or import images
for migration it's easier to vertically
or horizontally scale okay and virtual
machines are the most common and popular
offering for compute because people are
just very comfortable with those
then you have containers and the idea is
you have a virtual machine running
these things called containers the way
they do that is similar to a hypervisor
but instead you have
um like here is a docker demon so it's
just a um
a container software layer okay to run
those containers there's different kinds
docker is the most popular
and the great thing is you can maximize
the uh the capacity
because you can easily add new
containers resize those containers use
up the rest of the space
it's a lot more flexible okay your
containers
will share the same underlying os but
they
are more efficient than multiple vms uh
multiple apps can run side by side
without being limited
by the same os requirements and not
cause conflicts during resource sharing
so containers are really good but you
know the trade-off is there a lot more
work to maintain
then you have functions and functions go
even step further
and the idea is that you uh the the
containers
where we where we talked about that's a
lot of work to maintain now the
cloud service provider is taking care of
those containers generally
sometimes not it depends if it's servers
or not but the idea is that you don't
even think about
this is called service compute but you
don't even think about
the os or anything you just know that
what your runtime is you run
ruby or python or node and you just
upload your code and you just say
uh i want this to be able to run uh for
this long
and use this amount of memory okay
you're only responsible for your code
and data nothing else it's very cost
effective you only pay for the time the
code is running
uh and vms only run when there is code
to be executed
but because of that there is this
concept of cold starts and this is
uh where the virtual machine has to spin
up
and so sometimes requests can be a bit
slow so there's a bit of trade-off there
but functions
or serverless compute is generally one
of the best offerings as of today
but most people are still getting kind
of comfortable with that paradigm okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at global
infrastructure so what is global
infrastructure well it refers to the
global presence of data centers
networking and cloud resources
uh available to the customer and so uh
just kind of some of the stats that
google cloud has they have 25 regions 76
zones
144 network edge locations operating in
200 plus countries
so just an idea like here is an example
of the exterior of a google data center
and this is an interior
so we're going to go and dive deep on
all these cloud infrastructure concepts
starting now
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at regions for global
infrastructure
so regions are independent geographic
areas that consist of zones
and gcp has 25 regions so here we have a
map and you're going to notice that some
are blue and some are white
white ones indicate that they are
planning to
have um regions there in the future in
the next three years
and i think most of most of not all of
their uh regions always have three zones
in them so
that's pretty good on them uh so uh for
the americas we got oregon
los angeles salt lake city las vegas
iowa south carolina north virginia
montreal
sao paulo for europe we have london
belgium netherlands zurich frankfurt
finland warsaw in asia specific we have
mumbai singapore jakarta uh
hong kong uh taiwan tokyo osaka
sydney and seoul okay so there's quite a
few of them
uh i mean like a lot of people are used
to running in us west or us
east i am always running in the canada
region because that's where i'm from so
it's there
um but yeah when you actually want to go
use a region it's as simple as choosing
it so if i'm launching a virtual machine
i with compute instance or compute
engine you're just going to choose the
region you want to go in okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at google cloud's
global infrastructure edge network and
so edge networking is the practice of
having compute and data storage
resources as closest as possible
to the end user in order to deliver the
lowest latency
and to save bandwidth and so we're
talking about edge networking we're
always talking about points of presence
pop or pops
and this is an intermediate location
between a gcp region
and the end user and this location could
be even in a third-party data center
or it might just be described as a
collection of hardware so maybe it's not
even a data center at all
and so here is the big old graphic that
um
that google has for us and if you see
all those wires that's basically
just showing how things are
interconnected the actual global network
between these pops and actually there's
three types of um
of pops or things we want to look at for
edge networking at networking devices or
things
and this graphic will change for all
three this one is i think for edge pops
so just understand that it's not
representative of all these three types
but the first is edge pop so a location
where a user
can quickly enter so ingress the gcp
network for accelerated access to cloud
resources
then you have a cdn and this is a
location to serve
so egress leave to leave the network
for cash websites files assets so they
load very fast for the end user
then you have cloud media edge this is a
location specialized for the delivery
of media such as video content and so
there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at zones for google
cloud's global infrastructure so a
zone is a physical location made up of
one or more data center and a data
center is secure is a secured building
that contains hundreds
of thousands of computers and so this is
an example of
the interior of a data center and of
course you probably wouldn't want to
have a dog
in there unless it's a guard dog
protecting those machines
okay so a region will generally contain
three
zones and i actually think google is
very good about that they always have
three zones but other providers
will try to get a foothold into new
regions and so they might only launch
with a single zone offering but i think
gcp is good in this regard
uh the reason we make mention of that is
because when we're talking about high
availability
the only way to get that is when you
have at least three zones that's the
standard okay
data centers within a region will be
isolated from each other so
different buildings but they will be
close enough to provide low latency
and we'll talk about the the the inter
latent uh the inter
zonal latency uh coming in this section
here
so common practice to run at least three
zones to remain available in case
uh one or two data centers fail okay so
the way you choose zones within
google cloud is after you've chosen your
region you just choose your zone and
sometimes you're choosing more than one
zone okay so it's that simple
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at resource scoping
for
google cloud's global infrastructure so
we were just talking about zones
and i was saying that you can uh when
you launch a resource sometimes you
choose a single zone or multiple zones
and that comes into
resource scoping okay so i just want to
talk a little bit more or reiterate on
zones one more time so
a zone is a deployment area for google
cloud resources within a region
zones should be considered a single
failure domain within a region
and deploy redundant resources in
multiple zones
multi-zones for fault tolerance and
high availability okay so let's now talk
about
product or resource scoping so the idea
is you can
launch a resource in a single zone in a
single region so this is a zonal
resource
you have regional resources this is
where a resource resides in multiple
zones in a single region
you have multi-regional resource so
resources reside across
multiple specific zones you have a
global service this is where resources
reside globally
and regions and zones are abstracted
away very common with serverless
services okay
and then you have internal services
these are foundational services used by
many other services you don't interact
with these
services directly they're managed by
google such as spanner colossus
borg and chubby okay so uh the reason i
bring this up is that you know i saw a
question or two on the exam
and they were using this terminology and
so you know it just helps you to
kind of frame that question better if
you know resource scoping okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at data residency for
google cloud's global infrastructure so
uh what is data residency well it's the
physical or
geographic location of where an
organization
or cloud resources reside and the reason
we care about this is so that we can do
uh or have compliance boundaries these
are regulatory compliance so they're
legal requirements by a government or
organization that describes where data
and cloud resources are allowed
to reside so you know if you're working
with the k n government to say we're
only going to
use your software as long as the data
resides
uh within canadian data centers that is
the idea behind this stuff
so when you're trying to run these kind
of uh workloads and you need to meet
compliance boundaries
uh strictly to find the data residency
of the data and cloud resources
in gcp you can use something called
assured workloads
so this is a feature that allows you to
apply various security controls to an
environment so it's not just for
data residency but that's its primary
feature so data residency
personal data access controls based on
attributes person
personnel support case ownership
controls based on attributes
encryption so in order to apply data
residency
you're going to use an organizational
policy called a resource
location restriction and choose the
allowed region or multiple regions
will to show up in the exam probably not
but you know it's good to get you kind
of exposed to global or organizational
policies because
those kind of do show up on the exam
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at cloud interconnect
for global infrastructure
technically this is hybrid hybrid
services and so you have this in the
hybrid section
but i like to put it in global
infrastructure because it's just
something that
has to do with data centers and
connecting things so that's why i always
kind of front loaded in this section
here
so cloud interconnect provides direct
physical connections between your
on-premise network
and google's network and so cloud
interconnect enables you
to transfer large amounts of data
between networks
which can be more cost effective than
purchasing additional bandwidth
over uh public internet so it's a direct
physical connection so
fiber optics running from data center to
data center okay
and there are two offerings we have
dedicated and partners so for dedicated
this is a direct physical connection
between the on-premise network and
google's network
through a co-location facility we'll
talk about co-location what that means
here in a moment
then you have a partner interconnect
this is a direct physical connection
between the on-premise network
and google's network through a trusted
third-party data center or provider okay
so uh on the dedicated side this is
between 10
to 200 gigabytes per seconds and for
partner it's between 50
megabytes per second and 10 gigabytes
per second the reason
you would be using a partner one is
maybe because you just can't do
dedicated based on your location so you
have to work through a partner
or maybe it's more cost effective or you
know or it doesn't meet your needs so
it's just going to be dependent on that
kind of stuff
but generally the reason people are
going with partners because they just
can't get the dedicated one
so what is a co-location facility so a
co-location
or carrier hotel is a data center where
equipment space and bandwidth are
available for rental
to retail customers so the idea is that
it's a
rent like a rental data center right and
google
uh google uh is like is uh
uh there's ones that they're cool with
using and so
those it's like you have a bit more
direct control over it so you know it
just depends on what you want to do okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at google cloud for
government and so the first thing i want
to
answer is what is public sector so
public sectors include public goods
and governmental services such as
military law enforcement
infrastructure public transit public
education
health care the and the government
itself so google cloud can be utilized
by the public sector organizations
developing cloud workloads for the
public sector
and the way google achieves this is by
meeting regulatory compliance programs
along with specific governance and
security controls
so some compliance programs that would
be used in public sector would be hipaa
for
for health fedramp for dealing with the
us uh the criminal uh justice
information service
uh it's like working with the fbi and uh
we got fips 140
uh hyphen two and we do cover all these
again in the course so don't worry about
having to memorize the second let's just
mention fedramp so
this stands for federal risk and
authorization management program so
fedramp
it's a us government-wide program that
provides a standardized approach
to security assessments authorization
and continuous monitoring
for cloud products and services so what
is govcloud because this is something
you hear a lot with cloud service
providers
so a csp generally will offer an
isolated region
to run fedramp workloads and govcloud
offering in practice can result in
degraded service offerings lower
service availability and higher
operational costs so gc
gcp has an alternate to offering
govcloud where fedramp workloads are
authorized in gcp's
usual region data centers and this game
mitigates the disadvantages of gov cloud
offering
so gcp regions will be authorized for
either a high or moderate baseline
and so you know that was the thing was i
was looking up gcp and i'm like where's
the govcloud i couldn't find it and so
they just have a a different way of
going about it and supposedly
they say that it is better i don't know
all the details about it but that was
what i could
drum up will this show up on the exam
probably not
i didn't really see anything for public
sector on the exam but from fundamental
information you should absolutely know
this okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at latencies for
google cloud's global infrastructure so
what is latency well latency is the time
delay between two
physical systems and what is lag well
lag is the noticeable delay between the
actions of
input and the reactions of the server
sent back
to the client all right uh and you
probably if you play video games you
know what
game lag is so it's basically the same
thing okay it's just between
servers instead of game servers all
right we have
inter regional latency so this is
latency between two regions
and then we have interzonal latency this
is latency between
zones residing in a single region and i
just want to generally give you an idea
of the the latency in milliseconds this
isn't going to be exact because i
honestly couldn't find
something definitive by google and there
are benchmarks out there and they vary
because it's going to be between regions
and different zones
but i wanted to kind of give you kind of
a bit of a de facto way of understanding
generally what they'll be and so i would
imagine that between two zones
or sorry two regions you could see the
worst case of 500 milliseconds
so that's in the triple digit and then
when we're talking about inter zonal
latency maybe 10
50 milliseconds so double digit
milliseconds okay
the reason this is important is because
i saw a question on the exam
and it actually asked about 10
milliseconds and it was talking about
a high availability and if you knew if
you knew that
um that it's in the double digit between
interzonal stuff you wouldn't have chose
multi-region you would only choose
a single region with multiple zones okay
so don't get hung up on so much the
exact number but just understand
triple digit double digit for these two
okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at
innovation waves actually known as
chondrative waves uh that's a russian
name so i'm sorry if i pronounced it
incorrectly
but they are hypothesized cycle-like
phenomenons in the global world economy
the phenomenon is closely connected with
technology life cycles so the idea here
is that we have these waves that uh
irreversibly change
the society on a global uh scale and
generally we underpin these for
particular technological advancements
okay so
here we have the steam engine in cotton
we have railway
rail whey and steel we have electrical
engineering and chemistry innovations
here we have petrochemicals and
automobiles
we have information technology and the
idea here is that google is suggesting
that
the the wave that we're in right now
includes cloud technology as
one of the larger factors when we look
at one of these waves in
greater detail there is a common pattern
to the wave that changes the supply and
demand
and so they say there's an expansion a
boom a recession and a depression
and if you can detect that pattern
that's how you know uh that
something is going on okay and so uh if
we are in
um if cloud technology is the case here
then we're definitely in an expansion
phase right now
uh and it's we might be in a boom it's
hard to say
um but uh yeah so there you go
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the concept of a
burning platform so the term is used
when a company abandons
old technology for new technology with
the uncertainty of success
and can be motivated by fear that the
organization's future survival hinges on
its
digital transformation so this idea is
comes back to the oil industry where
you'd have a platform and oil would
catch fire and so
the only way to survive would be to uh
abandon or
jump off uh the platform and so this
term this term is not so popular
uh today but google seems to still be
using it but the idea is that uh you
know it's just you have to take a
leap of faith uh into this stuff if you
want to keep up okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the evolution of
computing power so computing power is
the throughput measured at which a
computer
can complete a computational task and
google
has a variety of offerings for the
innovations in this particular field
the one that we're all most common with
are cpus so this is just like what's in
your computer your laptop
when we're talking about cloud computing
the one that we commonly see
are xeon cpu processors because they're
very very
good processors and so the offering here
at any cloud service provider would be
via virtual machines and so for google
their virtual machines are offered via
compute
engine uh then we're looking at tensor
computing
so uh google created their own
machine learning deep learning framework
called tensorflow and it has a new type
of data structure called a tensor
that is specifically optimized for you
know neural networks
and the idea here is that google decided
to create a piece of hardware
that is specifically designed for their
tensor data structure and so that's what
they have which is this tpu thing and
for this particular use case
it is 50 times faster than a traditional
cpu
all right and this is really for the
space of neural nets uh if you want
to have this offering on uh google cloud
you'd be using
the cloud tpu okay and the last one here
is quantum computing
and so quantum computing is interesting
because it has the potential to be a
hundred million times faster
it is uh we're literally using parallel
parallel uh a universe or dimension uh
using things like quantum entanglement
very advanced concepts in order to
perform uh insane amount of computation
but this field is very early days
and so uh being able to apply it is
not very easy but that doesn't mean that
you can't play around with it
google has an offering aws has an
offering for this but in particular
google has been producing uh different
hardware so they first had foxtail in
2016
then bristol cone in 2017 and i think
the latest one they have is
sim sigmore in 2018
all right and so this is all accessible
via the google quantum ai
all right
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the concept of
digital transformation and this is the
adoption of digital technology
to transform services or businesses
through replacing non-digital or
manual processes with digital processes
like going
paperless we're replacing older digital
technology with newer digital
technologies so that means
uh you previously you're using
on-premise and you're moving into hybrid
architecture or using
uh cloud native technology all right and
so
uh this you could describe uh is that
google has their own
google digital transformation framework
or concept
based off of google seven solution
pillars so we have infrastructure
modernization
business application platform portfolio
application modernization
database and storage solutions smart
analytics
artificial intelligence and security so
in terms of the actual exam they're not
going to ask you what are the seven
pillars
or what digital transformation is but
you know the exam is all
um uh business use case scenario so
there are some tidbits in here which
might help you with some of the
questions and that's why we're gonna go
through
all the pillars okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look here at google
cloud's solution pillars and there's
seven
in total here and there's a lot of text
so let's work our way through it
so the first is infrastructure
modernization so replacing
legacy hardware and software systems
with cloud solutions
allows organizations to adopt hybrid
architectures and have more
infrastructure mobility
choosing a mix of best cloud service
provider offerings for their
organizational use case so in this case
if we're talking about hybrid
architectures
one service that we could utilize would
be anthos and this allows you to manage
compute from both
on premise and public cloud in a single
unified interface
moving on to business applications
platform portfolio
so the backbone of csps are built on top
of robust well-documented apis
standardized across
all offered cloud services organizations
can focus on the configuration
interconnections of various systems
instead of having to build their own
systems so what are they talking about
here we're talking about cloud sdk
cloud api cloud cli and the google cloud
documentation for number three we have
application
modernization so building web
applications on top of cloud services
allows organizations to globally deliver
and rapidly iterate
faster than ever before csps offer
automated deployment pipelines ai
powered code reviews
easy staging and testing of new features
the ability
to test in production roll back changes
apps are more durable and can remain
available
when facing catastrophic regional
failure so
one thing that makes it really easy to
build up very robust web apps is if
you're able to migrate your web app over
to app engine
because it just takes care of a lot of
the stuff for you and all you got to do
is upload your code and do some
configuration make some choices but
more or less it makes it very highly
durable available and scalable
then you have database and storage
solutions so most companies can tolerate
losing application code
you can always write uh you you can
always rewrite
losing data is not something you can
recover cloud service providers have
guaranteed slas of
data durability as well as the ability
to easily migrate
and secure your data so in this case if
we're looking at cloud storage which is
on
you know the storage or file side side
of the the scenario here
uh it can store files and documents as
objects and its availability is 99.5
percent
uh and they haven't it's sla backed okay
and the way they do that is that they're
replicating your data across multiple
zones so if the zone fails
you'll just recover uh cover files from
another zone it does that automatically
for you
for number five we have smart analytics
so when you store data on cloud service
providers you can tap
into big data and business intelligence
cloud offerings assisted by ai to help
you analyze your data
so for google there's looker and this is
data exploration discovery uh business
intelligence platform acquired by google
and it is now part of gcp
uh then you have artificial intelligence
so ai deep learning ml or specialized
domains that uh traditionally
required uh scarce and expensive subject
matter experts
cloud is commoditizing uh commoditizing
simplifying a knowledge
while driving costs lower for adoption
so there's a lot of tools here that
google has but the the
primary ones is vertex ai this is a
unified platform for aiml deep learning
automl
they have their own deep learning
framework they've developed it's really
easy to use this is my
uh most uh favorite framework and this
is the one i always use
then we have security so cloud services
by default have strong mechanisms
built in for security governance
compliance csps are continually
developing new and innovative security
offerings
not just at a service per service level
but to analyze recommend and remediate
at the project and organization level
you can easily and quickly audit and
apply security control so you become
compliant in a fraction of time
than on an on-premise solution and so
things you get
uh when you're working the cloud iam i
mean if you're using private cloud i
suppose you'd get that with openstack
but
i am so role-based access controls and
user management uh
one that i really like that google has
is beyond corp it's a zero trust model
framework
uh then there's the security command
center so it's it's a centralized
uh it centralizes visibility control for
security and stuff or misconfigurations
uh but there's a lot more there but this
is just to kind of help you ground
each of these pillars into something
practical okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at what the google
cloud console is
and this is a portal that is a web-based
unified console that provides an
alternative to the command line tools it
allows you to build manage and monitor
everything from
simple web apps to complex cloud
deployments and so this is generally the
main way you're going to be
interacting uh with google cloud because
it's the easiest way to do it
so the idea is that you have this
hamburger menu you can drop down
and see all the possible services you
can also search for them
you can organize different projects here
and switch between
them and in the background here what you
can see me doing is i'm actually
trying to launch a new compute uh engine
uh
virtual machine instance uh you can also
get uh notifications and things like
that but basically everything you want
to do is via
the console okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look here at cloud
sdk so
sdk stands for software development kit
and it is a collection of software
development tools
in one installable package so you can
use the cloud sdk to pragmatically
create
modify delete or interact with google
cloud resources
and the sdk is offered in a variety of
programming languages so we got java
python node.js ruby which is my favorite
go.net
php and so here's this example of us
using the sdk with ruby code so
we've installed the the package as a
ruby gem that's how we did it
and we're accessing a bigquery and we're
just iterating out that table
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at cloud cli
so cli stands for command line interface
and what it allows you to do is process
commands to a computer program
in the form of lines of text and
operating systems implement a command
line interface in a
shell or a terminal that's how you're
going to interact with one
and so this is what it looks like to use
the cli so once it's installed
what you'll do is write g cloud and then
whatever it is that you want to do so in
this case we are
you want to work with a compute engine
so we write compute for ssh
ssh into our instance and so it's just
as simple
as that okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look here at cloud
shell and this is a free online
environment with
a command line access for managing your
infrastructure in an online code editor
for cloud development so the idea here
is uh these are the two interfaces uh
they're very pretty pretty similar but
the idea is you'll press this little
button here
it will launch generally a shell and if
you want to switch over to the editor
you just press that
and here you can see this is basically a
bash terminal and this one here is a vs
code environment so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at projects and
folders for google cloud so a project in
google cloud is a logical grouping of
resources
and a cloud resource must belong to a
project so up in your navigation
you're going to see the project you're
currently on you can drop that down
change another project or
quickly and easily create additional
projects a project is made up of
settings permissions and other metadata
a project can't access another project's
resources unless you use shared vpc or
vpc network pairing
resources within a single project can
work together easily for example by
communicating through internal network
subject to the regions and zone rules
each google cloud project has the
following
a project name which you provide a
project id which you can provide or
google cloud can provide for you
a project number which google cloud
provides as you work with google cloud
you'll use these identifiers in certain
command lines and api calls
so each project id is unique across
google cloud
once you have created a project you can
delete the project but its ids can never
be used again
when billing is enabled each project is
associated with one billing account
multiple projects can have their
resources usage billed to the same
account
a project serves as a namespace this
means that every resource within each
project must have a unique name
but you can usually reuse resource names
if they're if they're in separated
projects
then there's the concept of folders so
folders allow you to logically
group multiple projects that share
common iam permissions
folders are commonly used to isolate
projects for different departments
or for different environments we'll see
more of this when we cover resource
hierarchies okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at the google cloud
adoption framework also known as gcaf
and this is a white paper that can
determine an organization's readiness to
adopt google cloud
as well as providing steps to fill in
knowledge gaps and develop new
competencies okay
so um to really understand uh the google
cloud adoption framework we need to know
what is a white paper
so it is a report or guide that informs
readers
concisely about a complex issue it is
intended to help readers understand an
issue
solve a problem or make a decision and
white papers are generally pdf
format but they could also be in html
format as well
so white papers are common among all the
cloud service providers and they're
almost always uh essential to study at
the fundamentals level and so for
the google cloud digital leader i
recommend going through the cloud
adoption framework which is what we're
gonna do here okay
so the gcap is composed of four themes
through maturity phases
the cloud maturity scale uh epics and
programs
so let's get into it
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at themes for the
google cloud adoption framework so
themes are uh
just four different areas that your
company needs to excel in in order to
be successful with their cloud adoption
so starting at the first here we have
learn the quality and scale of the
learning programs you have in place
to upskill your technical teams your
ability to augment your i.t staff with
experienced partners so
who's engaged how widespread is that
engagement how concerted is the effort
how effective are the results number two
here is lead so the extent to which it
teams are supported by a mandate from
leadership to migrate to cloud
the degree to which the teams themselves
are cross-functional collaborative and
self-motivated so
how are teams structured have they got
executive sponsorship
how are cloud projects budgeted governed
and assessed
the third theme here is scale so the
extent to which you use cloud native
services that reduce
operational overhead and automate manual
processes and policies
so how are cloud-based services
provisioned how is capacity for
work workloads allocated how are
applications up
updates managed and for the fourth one
here we have secure so the
capabilities to protect your services
from unauthorized and inappropriate
access
with a multi-layered identity centric
security model
dependent also on the advanced maturity
of the other three themes okay
so what controls are in place what
technology is used
what strategies govern uh everything as
a whole
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at phases for the
google cloud
adoption framework and this is all about
the maturity of the organization because
depending on where you are
is going to determine the type of action
or advice here based on the phase okay
so
for tactical this is short-term goals
which is individual workloads are in
place
but there is no coherent plan the focus
is on reducing the cost of discrete
systems
getting to the cloud with minimal
disruption the winds are quick
but there is no provision for scale so
really they're just trying to
utilize anything and it's not there's no
real plan in place okay
for strategic this is where you are in
the midterm
of maturity so a broader vision governs
individual workloads which are designed
and
developed with an eye to future needs
and scale uh have begun to
uh embrace change people and processes
are not now involved in the adoption
strategy
itt teams are both efficient and
effective increasing the value of
harnessing the cloud
for your business operations then we
have uh
uh transfer transformative or
transformational there we go
and so this is like long-term goals so
cloud operations are functioning
smoothly so you're in the cloud now but
you're focusing on
integrating the data and insights
working in the cloud
so existing data is transparently shared
new data is collected and analyzed
predictive and prescriptive analytics
via machine learning is used
uh people and processes are being
transformed which further supports
technological changes
it is no longer a cost center but has
become instead a partner to
the business
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the cloud maturity
scale for the google cloud adoption
framework and so this is a matrix made
up of the themes and phases that we just
reviewed
and it will help your organization
pinpoint their exact adoption position
so on the horizontal scale we have learn
lead
scale and secure to determine our
adoption themes
and then on our vertical scale we have
tactical strategic
and transform transformational for
organizations maturity
so where it intersects with learn and
tactical the idea here is that you are
self-taught and you
are reliant on third parties
for strategic learn these are organized
training with third party assisted
for learn and transformational it's peer
learning and sharing with third party
staff
augmentation so just to kind of make
sense because i know these are kind of
abbreviated so it doesn't make a whole
lot of sense but the idea is that
if you are learning and you are in the
short term phase then you're probably
going to be
self-taught in this right okay and then
if you're strategic you're going to be
you're going to have organized training
because you are bringing people and
processes in as we saw in the
as we were describing the maturity
phases
and then for transformational we have
peer learning and sharing because we're
now
established in the cloud but we're just
trying to collect data make things a lot
better okay
for lead lead for tactical looks like
it's teams by function and you have a
heroic project manager
basically anytime you want to adopt
cloud no matter if it's google or other
ones you need
somebody and your team that's going to
act as the hero or the evangelist
for that adoption uh for the adoption of
the cloud and you've got to find that
person
to carry you through all the stages okay
so for lead and strategic we have
new cross-functional functional cloud
teams so this is where you actually have
a specialized team
in your organization because you're now
in the cloud right uh
and so that's going to help support the
workloads and move it further
and then down for transformational lead
you have cross-functional feature teams
great uh autonomy so the idea is you
don't just have a single team but you
have multiple teams
that are feature specific so maybe you
have data data team
you have a devops team uh and the idea
is that you also want to make sure they
have the control to do what they need to
do
in their own space right that means in
google cloud they're going to have their
own folder
and they can self-govern all their
projects in there they're not they can
do their shadow i.t and they don't have
to
ask the centralized i.t to do stuff for
scale and tactical so change is slow
and risk is ops heavy um because
basically
everything is still in the old uh the
old on-premise system right so that
makes sense
for scale and strategic templates ensure
good governance without
manual review um so you know you just
want to make sure that you have
infrastructure as code is in place and
you're putting uh governing rules in the
midterm
for transformational scale all change
constant low risk and quickly
fixed so you're really in good shape for
scale here uh
you know your just scale is going to be
really easy right so whereas this you're
doing a lot of automation still to
try to get your scale for secure fear of
public internet trust in private network
that's of course why people are on
premise because they're really afraid to
be in the public cloud or
or on third parties in general
so that is something you're going to
have to fight with at that stage
for strategic you have central identity
hybrid network
you know so that could be using the
beyond corp which is the zero truss
model or you could be doing federation
uh between
uh your azure active directory on prem
into uh like with cloud identity using
like
uh google syncing directory uh service
uh then uh the last one here is secure
and transformational trust
only the right people device and
services this is what they're talking
about they're talking about the zero
trust model here
so that really is where beyond corp
would come into play
uh for the google cloud adoption
framework okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at epics for the
google cloud
adoption framework so when you've
determined where your organization is in
the adoption process
using that cloud maturity scale then you
need to define
epics and epics are work streams to
scope and structure
cloud adoption epics are defined so they
do not overlap
they are aligned to manageable groups of
stakeholders they can be further
further broken down into individual user
stories
if you've ever done agile development
epics and user stories are pretty darn
common
and you can definitely use them in jira
so if you if you line these things up
that's what you might want to do
uh so we have this venn diagram where we
have uh three areas so we've got people
processes and textures broad categories
of different kinds of epochs everything
within this
venn diagram is going to be epics okay
so
under people we have behaviors people
people's operation communication right
under process we have cost control
incident management
instrumentation for tech we have
resource management
networking and then we have um these
places where they
intersect so we have external experience
upskilling
sponsorship teamwork architecture
infrastructures code
ci cicd identity and access data
management all right so
if you're limited for time and resources
focus on the epochs in the colored
segments
uh and since these align with learn lead
at scale
and secure that's what these are when
you're seeing those four
okay just to help that make a little bit
more sense uh there's programs and these
are a logical grouping of epics that
correlate to themes to allow you to
focus on some
specific adoption efforts so the idea is
that you have
um learn which is for training programs
change management so that would be uh
lead cloud operation models with scale
secure account setup which is secure and
the idea is like okay well
there's these epics how do i know how to
write them out or do user stories
i would imagine that that's where you
would work with google or the google
partner network to find somebody that
actually knows how to
go and implement this stuff because i
did find that the documentation was a
bit lacking for this but i imagine that
there are people out there that
have a good idea how to actually utilize
this framework okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at tams which stands
for technical account manager
and no matter if you're using google
cloud azure aws they all have tams
and this is a human resource assigned to
work with your organization
when paying for google cloud's premium
support so tam can assist with
google cloud adoption framework by
performing a high level
assessment of your organization's cloud
maturity tell you how to protect
prioritize your training change manage
programs
partner relationships cloud operating
models secure account configuration so
the idea here is that you know if you
don't know how to apply
the google cloud adoption framework you
want to get a tam because they're really
going to help you connect you to people
that do know how to do it or give you
a bit of a kickstart in that process
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the cloud maturity
assessment tool
this is a guided form to assess your
organizations
against the google cloud's adoption
framework along
its four themes learn lead scale and
secure so it's a simple multiple choice
form
and once you're done you'll get an email
with your maturity phase so it's going
to say
okay for learning uh you're strategic
right that's where you are
it'll give you some additional
information on how you compare it
against the average
uh is this tool that useful nah not
really it's not that hard to assess
where you
are um but you know it is a good
starting point if you're just not sure
just to kind of get you warmed up to
this framework okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at compute for google
cloud platform and so there's a variety
of services so let's get to it the first
being compute engine
and this one is for virtual machines or
vms
uh and this is generally the primary or
traditional type of compute you are
going to utilize
on a cloud service provider then there
is bare metal so bare metal
is where you have full control of the
hardware so you can install any kind of
hypervisor you wanna
on it or virtualization it's going to
allow you to have very low latency on
google cloud
then we have app engine which is a
platform as a service build and deploy
apps on a fully managed highly scalable
platform without having to manage the
underlying infrastructure
we're going to spend a little bit more
time on app engine because the exam
definitely
pops up with a few questions that talk
about its different core offerings
we have cloud gpus so add gpus to your
workloads for machine learning
scientific computing and 3d
visualization
you have google kubernetes engine also
known as gke
so reliably efficiently and securely
deploy and scale containerized
applications on kubernetes
you have soul tenant nodes and this is
known as
dedicated virtual machines and all the
other different providers so
the reason you'd want to use these is
you need to meet compliance you have
your own licenses uh you need to keep
these instances physically separated
uh with dedicated hardware because maybe
you know you're not allowed to run it
with uh
as a multi-tenant so there's all sorts
of reasons for that you have cloud
functions
these are functions as a service so you
can create serverless single purpose
functions that respond to the events
i guess i could have put cloud run on
this as well which is serverless
containers but
we have a container section so it's not
a big deal we'll get to that
some kind of auxiliary services that are
used that are important to know with
compute
would be google cloud vm engine or
vmware engine so migrate and run your vm
workloads natively on google cloud
you have migrate for compute engine so
migrate servers and vms from on premise
or another cloud to compute engine
this was formerly known as velostrata
preemptable vms
so deploy affordable short-lived compute
instances suitable for batch jobs and
fault tolerant workloads
we're going to cover that again when we
go to our pricing section shielded vms
so deploy hardened virtual machines on
google cloud
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a deeper look here at
app engine so app engine is a platform
as a service for your applications
you can quickly deploy and scale web
applications without having to worry
about the underlying infrastructure
and a great way of thinking of this is
if you know heroku it's basically the
heroku
of gcp so the idea here is you can use
your favorite programming language
whether it's node.js
java ruby c-sharp go python or php
you can also bring your own language
runtime
and you do that by creating a custom
docker container
so there is all our familiar logos just
to kind of
put home as to what you can use it has
powerful application diagnostics
you have cloud monitoring cloud logging
to monitor the health of your
performance
cloud debugger and air reporting to
diagnose and fix bugs quickly
application versioning so easily create
a development test staging
and production environments traffic
splitting so route income
incoming requests to different app
versions a to b tests
and do incremental feature rollouts you
have application security so defining
access rules with app
engine firewall and you can leverage
manage ssl tls certification
certificates by default so the idea is
that you have all this infrastructure
and this is not even the full list but
all the stuff around your application
that you would generally have to do
yourself but they do it all for you okay
now there are two types of environments
that you can launch with app engine you
got flexible and standard it's
very very very important that you know
the difference for the exam because they
will have scenarios
where you have to pick one or the other
okay so you can simultaneously
use both environments for your
application so it's not you'd have to
use one or the other
it just depends on what kind of workload
you're running an app engine is well
suited to applications that are designed
using
microservice architecture so splitting
it down the line let's talk about
standard and then we'll talk about
flexible so standard i would describe as
being serverless compute
so it starts in seconds it's going to
run in a sandbox meaning that there's an
uh
like you don't have uh like you're not
deploying a container
it's just you're uploading your code
okay it's designed for rapid scaling so
it can handle uh sudden spikes of
traffic
it supports specific language versions
uh but it's
not a custom run time so if you've ever
deployed a serverless function where
you're just like choose ruby
that's the language you get of a
particular version okay you're not going
to get that much flexibility
around that it can scale to zero
instances so that's another
characteristic of serverless compute
its pricing is based on hours it cannot
you cannot use ssh to debug it which is
very common for
serverless apps there are no background
processes
we're looking at flexible these are
fully managed containers so it starts in
minutes
uh runs with docker containers on
compute engine
vms that's what it's doing underneath
it's designed for predictable and
consistent traffic
it supports uh generally any language
version or uh
you can run a custom runtime
must have at least one instance running
the pricing is based on vcpus memory and
disk you can ssh to debug it
and you can have background processes so
just understand
those two and you'll be good for the
exam okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at containers
for
google cloud platform so uh containers
are a type of compute uh but there is so
much going on here uh with google that
uh it deserves its own page so
we have google kubernetes engine so gke
which is reliably efficiently and
securely deploys and scales
containerized applications on kubernetes
you have cloud build so continuously
build test and deploy containers using
the cloud
google cloud infrastructure you have
artifact registry so store
manage and secure container images and
language packages
you have container registry so store
manage and secure your docker containers
images
these sound really similar and that's
because
this version this is actually the second
version of container registry so
both of them exist but generally it's
recommended always to use
artifact registry okay you're not going
to probably see that
like them lined up against each other
but just so you know
uh the benefits always towards artifact
registry over container registry okay
um if you want to use a virtual machine
uh
like a compute engine you can pretty
much just
check box it on and now you have a
container optimized os
so it's really easy to use containers
even with compute engine which is nice
you have cloud run which is a stateless
container fully managed environments and
you can also use it with anthos
so this one and i really should have
highlighted this in yellow here but
stateless containers is something you
want to remember for your exam
they also have containers for the ai
platform
deep learning so this is when you'd be
using vertex ai
you might need to have a bunch of
tooling around that
and then there's also um the google
marketplace for kubernetes applications
so you can so if you're
using kubernetes and you just need
something that's already pre-built and
you're willing to pay or
some free stuff in there you can go
there and get them okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam bro
and we are looking at kubernetes which
is an open source container
orchestration system for automating
deployment scaling and management of
containers
it's originally created by google and
now maintained by the cloud native
computing foundation also known as cncf
uh what's interesting is this foundation
also has their own certifications like
the certified kubernetes administrator
and the certified kubernetes developers
so don't be surprised if you see me
making courses for that in the future
uh kubernetes is commonly called k8 the
idea here is that the 8 represents the
remaining
letters so u b e r and e t
the advantage of kubernetes over
something like docker and you've
probably heard of docker for containers
before
but it has the ability to run containers
uh distributed across multiple vms
that's what kubernetes can do that
docker cannot
do on its own a unique component of
kubernetes are pods a pod is a group of
one or more containers
with shared storage network resources
other shared settings
that is kind of the special kind of
infrastructure or architecture
that kubernetes has kubernetes is is
ideal for
micro service architectures where
companies have tens to
hundreds i really should have
highlighted that in red for you tends to
hundreds of services they need to manage
if you don't have i didn't say
containers i said services
because that could be there's even more
containers than uh
tens to hundreds you know what i mean
there could be thousands but the idea
here is that
kubernetes does add a lot of management
layer to it
but the idea here is that uh you know
when you have a lot of services it is
the best
choice okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at databases
uh for the google cloud platform and the
first on our list is bigquery and this
one is a big
deal because not only is it a data
warehouse it's a
serverless data warehouse and the reason
why that is important is because
traditionally uh data warehouses are
extremely expensive
but this one because it's serverless
that means it can
scale to zero and uh it's uh
you know only when you're using it do
you pay for it okay and so that is
a very unique cloud offering azure says
they have kind of a serverless
data warehouse it's totally not true the
only one that has it is google
and so it's a big deal okay and it's
definitely going to show up more in this
course and it will absolutely be on the
exam okay
so it can store terabytes or petabytes
of data using nosql
it is a wide column database service and
it also has built-in ml which we'll
re visit later on okay then there's
cloud spanner this is a fully managed
relational database
this is not postgres this is not mysql
it is a proprietary relational database
designed by google
for scale it has you sql so you'd have
to do a tiny bit of translation if you
already have an existing database
but the idea is that if you want
something that scales like crazy then
this is the service for you
if you're using relational databases
you've got cloud bigtable this is a no
sql key value store it is a fully
managed nosql database for large
analytic analytics and operational
workloads
um so that's there we have cloudsql and
this is a relational database service so
if you're using mysql
postgres sql server it's just a managed
service to host them there
then you have firestore it's the nosql
document database
it adds nosql document database to
mobile and web apps
it can get kind of confusing because
there's another service called firebase
which we cover in this course
and it has firebase firestore but it's
the same
underlying service okay this one is very
similar to
mongodb it's not mongodb it's it's a
proprietary
service by google but one of its key
features is that it has a real-time
component to store and sync data in real
time
and that is a very big deal and that
particular
note there you want to remember because
that will show up on the exam if
someone's asking for
a database and there's a real-time
component it's going to be firestore
okay
you've got memory storage this is not
going to show up in the exam but it's an
in-memory database to achieve
extreme performance using a managed
in-memory data store service
so think of redis that is basically what
this is
and then last on our list here we have
database migration service dms this is a
serverless easily minimal downtime
migration to cloud
sql okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at databases so
a database is a data store that stores
semi-structured and structured data
and a database is more complex datastore
because it requires using formal design
and modeling techniques
databases can be generally categorized
as either a relational database so
structured data that strongly represents
tabular data such as tables rows and
columns that means it could either be
row oriented or
column oriented or non-relational
databases semi-structures
data that may or may not distantly
resemble tabular data
and so the way these things work is
you'll generally have a specialized
language to query in such as sql
a specialized modeling strategy to
optimize retrieval for different use
cases
more fine-tuned control over the
transformation of the data
into useful data structures and reports
and normally when we just say
database we're generally referring to
relational row-oriented data stores so
think mysql postgres msql okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at the concept of a
data warehouse so
a it's basically a relational data store
or database
designed for analytical workloads which
is generally
column oriented okay so companies will
have terabytes or
millions of rows of data and they need a
fast way to be able to produce
analytical reports
data warehouses generally perform
aggregation so aggregation is grouping
data so like finding a total of average
data warehouses are optimized around
columns since they need to quickly
aggregate column data
and so data warehouses are generally
designed to be hot
hot means that they can return queries
very fast even though they have vast
amounts of data
data warehouses are infrequently
accessed meaning that they aren't
intended for real-time reporting but
maybe once or twice a day or once a week
to generate business uh
generate business or user reports a data
warehouse needs to consume data from a
relational database on a regular basis
so
that's what we're kind of seeing over
here where imagine that this is our data
warehouse
and we want to generate a report the
idea is that we're either ingesting data
from sql or if we're ingesting data from
a non-uh
tabular like structure we have to use
etl so
to transform the data into the format
that we want okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at a key
value store so key value databases or
data stores is a type of non-relational
database nosql
that uses a simple key value method to
store data
and the way i like to describe them is
that they're dumb and fast and they
generally like features like
relationships indexes aggregation
transactions
you name it they don't have it but what
they do have is speed okay
so a key and value store is a is a
unique key
alongside a value and the idea here is
that a simple key and value store will
interpret this data resembling something
that looks like a dictionary so an
associative array
or a hash and so when we look at it kind
of like a table
it can resemble tabular data but it does
not have consistent columns per row
hence it's called schema-less because it
doesn't follow a particular scheme
due to the simple design they can scale
well beyond a relational database
and key value stores are generally the
ones that are the most scalable but the
idea is that because
of the simplicity of these things uh
usually you are
you know like these are really great for
like leader boards where the data is
exactly stored the way you want to see
it okay so if you have to do joins or
data manipulation then these are not
going to be very ideal
but the data is exactly as you need to
see it then they work really well
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at document stores so
a document store or document database is
a new sql database that stores documents
as its primary data structure
so a document could be xml but it's more
commonly json or json-like
documents are a sub-class of key value
stores
uh the the main difference is that they
can store
nested dictionaries nested hashes okay
uh the club the components of a document
store compares to relational databases
the easiest way to explain it
so where you would have tables they call
them collections where you'd have rows
they call them documents where you have
columns they call them fields
indexes are the same and yet do you have
some ability to do joining
via embedding and linking so you know
you can leverage that tabular data to
kind of think about
uh how document stores are but
fundamentally they're not
uh tabular data okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at serverless
services for google cloud platform so
what is serverless well serverless
architecture or fully managed services
that automatically scale are highly
available durable secure by default
abstracts away the underlying
infrastructure and are built based on
the execution of your business task
so the idea here is you pay for the
value you don't pay for idle servers
and serverless can scale to zero meaning
when not in use
the services don't generally cost
anything so let's look at cloud
functions this is functions as a service
when we're talking about serverless on
any csp
this is what people look at first is
what is the um serverless functions okay
and so you choose a runtime upload
single function code so they're not full
web apps just
parts of code and they're intended to be
short-lived and
everything else is taken care of for you
you have cloud run this is for
serverless containers so run stateless
containers on a fully managed
environment
or via anthos you have app engine
platform as a service so build and
deploy
apps using traditional web frameworks
and all the underlying infrastructure's
taken care for you
platform as a service is not always
serverless but app engine specifically
has
a serverless offering which is um the
standard version
you have event arc and this is a
serverless event bus so you build event
driven solutions by asynchronously
delivering events from google services
sas
and your own apps used for application
integration
um aws's one is called uh eventbridge so
it's the same thing there
so the idea is it's application
integration for google services
and other third parties okay you have k
native this is serverless k8 containers
deploy and manage service cloud native
applications for kubernetes
you have workflows this is a serverless
state machine so orchestrate and
automate
google cloud and http based api services
with serverless workflows
you got bigquery serverless data
warehouse understand your data using a
fully managed highly scalable data
warehouse
with built-in ml then you have cloud
storage this is serverless storage so
it's an object store and the idea is
that this stuff is
highly available it's distributed across
multiple
data centers you just upload files you
don't think about
anything like about the disks or
anything else okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at storage for google
cloud platform so we've got cloud
storage persistent disk
and file store uh there is um cloud
search for firebase that's not going to
show up on your exam
but let's dive into these three uh
really quickly about their
architecture and why they would be used
in certain circumstances
so for persistent disk the idea here is
that it's using
blocks as a means of storage so it has a
virtual disk and it stores things just
like it would on a regular disk
the idea here is that you have direct
access to the operating system
uh and it supports only a single right
volume
all right we'll talk about the use cases
at the end of going through these three
architectures
then we have file store which is a file
share
so the file is stored with the data and
metadata we have multiple connections
via the network share
supports multiple reads but for uh
rights they're going to get locked when
someone's writing okay
then you have uh cloud storage which is
for object or blob storage
and so data is stored as objects so
there's metadata
unique id it scales with limited uh with
uh
next to no upper limit in terms of the
storage supports multiple reads and
writes
so there are no locks in place so what
would you use these things for well the
first one the idea is that you would if
you had a virtual machine and you need a
volume
you could attach a block storage this is
just basically a virtual hard drive
so you could have a vm with multiple
block storage
uh or virtual hard disks but the thing
is is that
um that virtual disk is only being used
by
one operating system at the time the
single vm okay
so if you needed to have a
a virtual hard disk that could be
accessed by multiple virtual machines
that's good where you're going to be
using a file share and that's what file
store
is or you could also just have users
connect to it because it's using this
nfs and smb protocol and these are ways
where you could easily
mount the drive to your windows computer
or to a virtual machine okay
and so then last we have is
cloud storage which is an object
serverless storage the idea here is that
you can just
upload files you don't have to choose
the size of the drive the type of the
drive
you don't have to worry about backing up
the drive or the redundancy of the drive
it just works right and there's no
concept of a drive it's just
there's a bucket and you put everything
in it uh the only uh drawback here it's
not intended for high
iops so input outputs reads and writes
like it's pretty darn fast but the idea
is that you know
if you uh you know it's not going to be
used as the
primary drive of a virtual machine right
it's going to be for accessing
files okay so hopefully those three
categories are clear
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at
cloud storage so cloud storage is a
serverless object storage service
you do not have to worry about the
underlying disks right sizing
availability durability
uh the file system underneath you only
pay based on the storage so the address
storage and the download so
actually accessing or requesting files
files are called
objects and folders are called buckets
it has unlimited storage with no minimum
object size
probably there is an upper limit most um
serverless object storages do have a
particular limit but theoretically it's
unlimited storage
worldwide accessibility and worldwide
storage locations
low latency so time to first bite
typically 10 of milliseconds
has a high durability so it has nine
nines of annual durability when i say
99s it's because
it's 99 and then followed by nine nines
okay
it has geo-redundancy if the data is
stored in multi-region or dual region
it has a uniform experience with cloud
storage features security tools and apis
and i want to cover available storage
classes because these do show up on the
exam this isn't something that other
fundamental certifications would
go this deep on but google really wants
you to know
better in detail their core services so
for available storage classes we have
standard
and so here this is for frequent file
use so if you're building a web
application or just general
use you're going to be going with
standard storage now this is the
least a cost effective solution it's not
expensive but
there's ways to save okay you have
nearline storage this is when you're
going to be accessing on average a file
once a month or less
right it's going to be cheaper than
standard storage
but the key thing is once a month or
less
then you have cold line storage this has
a higher access cost than nearline store
but a lower at re at rest cost so that's
kind of just a bit of a trade-off there
you have archive storage this actually
has no sla
um availability it's a zero availability
uh
sla uh because it's just it's offline
right so a very
slow retrieval very cost effective
rarely or never intended to be accessed
you're using these to store like
um uh you know like reports or
accounting information that you have an
obligation to store for seven years
that's when you'd be using that
notice that there's this number here it
says 0
30 90 365 this is the minimum storage
duration
it's the minimum days a file needs to
remain in a storage before deleting if
deleted prematurely a charge will occur
so the idea is they want you to hold on
to them for a particular time
uh to effectively use them right because
if you delete them sooner then it
doesn't make sense for
um for you or for google cloud but yeah
i just want to emphasize
that available storage classes will be
on the exam and they showed up more than
once for me so
definitely know the difference okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at networking for the
google cloud platform so the most
important service to talk about is
virtual private cloud vpc
is a logically isolated section of the
google cloud network where you can
launch
google cloud resources and the idea is
you know once you have your slice of the
network uh the amount of resources you
can launch is based on how many
available ip addresses and that's
determined by
cider range so cider range or cider
notation is a
format that looks kind of like an ip
address it has this forward slash
uh thing on the end here and that is
what's determining how many available ip
addresses are if you have 65 000
that means you can launch pretty much 65
000 virtual machines
you don't ever just launch something
into a vpc you'll launch it into a
a subnet of a vpc a subnet is a
subdivision
of the virtual private cloud uh and the
way that works is that you would
actually have to choose a cider range as
well
that side of range is going to be
smaller than the the vpc one
uh interestingly enough the the larger
the number is the smaller
the ip range is that's just how the math
works you don't need it for
to need to know for the exam but i like
to cover this stuff anyway because it's
fundamental
information we have public subnets and
private subnets public subnets can reach
the internet private subnets
can't reach the internet uh now there is
no a hard rule about that like there's
no constraint
that is just like you don't say create a
private subnet you just create a subnet
and if you don't want uh you if you want
to treat it as a private subnet just
don't give them any
external or public ip addresses so here
i have a
little diagram i made here for you just
to kind of explain some of the
components
this is not an exhaustive one networking
has so many
features here um it just got too
complicated so we'll just have a very
simple example here so here we have our
vpc
a vpc has to be launched within a region
so here it is in us
west one we have a public and private
subnet
uh these would be launched in particular
zones that's how you get
um multi zones so you create a subnet
across one subnet per zone so you have
three zones and that way you'd be highly
available
we have uh compute engines these are
virtual machines running here
so if we wanted a virtual machine in our
public subnet to reach the internet it
has to have an external ip address
uh it would also communicate through
internet gateway uh
in google cloud you don't have to create
an internet gateway like aws it's just
there there's already a route set for it
um so that's really nice you don't have
to think about that
for a private subnet if it has to go out
to the internet not internet coming in
you'd have to use a network address
translation uh so
cloud nat that's pretty standard across
all the cloud service providers
if you're trying to get uh traffic into
a virtual machine sitting a private
subnet
that is where you need some kind of
hybrid connection so a cloud vpn or
cloud
interconnect you'd probably be using
both of these in combination that's
usually how it goes
or just the cloud vpn but that basically
establishes a private connection to
uh this vbc and it's it's private subnet
and that way you could just treat it as
the same network the way you're going to
protect
your your resources is via uh firewall
rules
firewall rules um are at the instance
level and
uh they're also stateful so you can say
allow or deny which is
when again if you're in aws it's totally
different right you have um
you have uh different controls for that
okay
uh but yeah that's generally the main
components there okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at more networking
services for the google cloud platform
now these are just basically
auxiliary services not all of them you
really need to know in detail for the
exam but you should know them in general
uh because and they can kind of help you
out so let's go through them all so we
have cloud armor this helps protect
against
ddos and web attacks we're going to
cover that later again this one could
show up on your exam
cloud load balancing is just a load
bouncer high performance load balancer
uh we have cloud cdn so this is uh a
content distribution network it caches
your data globally so that you know your
websites load fast stuff like that
um cloud nat to provision applications
without public ip addresses
allows web apps to communicate in
private subnets out to the internet to
download things like packages
or software updates things like that
cloud dns publish and manage your domain
names using
google's reliable resistant low latency
dns service
uh traffic director this is a global
load balancer this is
this has to do with like service mesh
stuff um cloud interconnect so
connect your infrastructure to google
cloud on on your terms from anywhere
cloud vpn securely extend your
on-premise network to google's network
through ipsec
vp and tunnel that's how you get a
secure connection
from your uh on-premise to your your
network
google cloud network cloud router
dynamically exchange routes between your
google cloud virtual uh vpc network and
your on-premise networks using bpg
so that's just a component you need to
do a hybrid connection
and then we have some auxiliary services
like very auxiliary services for just
kind of like monitoring things like that
so network intelligence center
a single console for comprehensive
network monitoring verification
optimization
network telemetry traffic track network
flows for monitoring forensics
real time security analysis expense
optimization
network service tiers optimize your
network for performance or cost so
for your exam um
you know cloud vpn cloud interconnect
cloud armor and that's about it
okay now they talk about they say like
they're supposed to be things like
sd-wan and and service mesh i never saw
those on the exam
so these are the real three that you
need to know but these are all the other
things that are involved okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we still got one part left with
networking these are just kind of like
features of vpc
that i just want you to know they're not
core to any questions on the exam but
they might show up as choices and so
it'll help you eliminate them as the
wrong answer okay
so we have private google cloud this
allows your instances to reach google
apis and services
using an internal ip rather than a
public ip address so
uh you know sometimes services are
publicly accessible uh maybe like
firestore or something like that or
bigquery
and so the idea is you want them to stay
in the network right because
you're paying outbound or egress costs
or
you're concerned about security and so
having private google cloud turned on is
a good idea
that doesn't necessarily mean that your
subnet's a private subnet because you
turn this on
it just means that when it communicates
with google services it's going to use a
private ip address
for shared vpcs this is a way of sharing
subnets with their projects so connect
resources from multiple projects to a
common vpc
this sounds like vpc network peering
it's more like a convenience feature
where you're not doing it at the
networking level it's more at the
project level
so it confuses me a bit but you know i
get it there's vbc networking peering
so private connect to vpc networks which
can reduce latency costs and increase
security so vpc appearing is common and
all
cloud service providers yeah just
joining those vpcs together
serverless vpc access allow cloud
functions cloud run services app engine
standard environments
apps to access resources in a vpc
network
using those private ip addresses i
wonder if you have to have private
google cloud turned on for that but it
sounds like the other way so private
google cloud is like
my machine connecting with other google
cloud services
and serverless vpc access is just
services that are generally public
facing where you access them with
republic ip address
access things via the private network
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at internal services
for the google
cloud platform so these are services
that you
generally cannot use and they're and
they're designed to be
uh supportive of all the underlying
infrastructure for many google cloud
services
i just want to get you exposed to these
because
they might show up as choices as
distractors on your exam
and you might see them in the
documentation with no context and so you
just might wonder what these things are
so that's why we're going to cover them
and the first one actually is an
exception where you can use this service
but
it's spanner and so spanner uh without
the word cloud is the internal service
globally consistent scalable relational
database
and then google made this available to
us as cloud spanner
then you have borg it's a cluster
management manager that
runs hundreds of or thousands of jobs
from
many thousands of different applications
across a number of clusters
each with up to tens of thousands of
machines borg i think is inspired by
star trek right the borg
we have chubby a distributed lock
manager dlm
as a service that temporarily prevents
files and records from being used by
another user or operation
on a virtual machine and then you have
colossus
cluster level file system successor to
the google file system
gfs provides the underlying
infrastructure for the google cloud
storage service
from firestore to cloud sql to to uh
to firestore again i suppose and to
cloud storage i guess i was trying to
write something else there but that's
okay
but there we go
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at what is
apogee so apigee corporation was an api
management and predictive
analytics software provider before its
merger into google cloud so apogee is a
founding member of the open api
initiative so
that's what we're talking about open api
3.0 specification
originally known as the swagger
specification so
open api specification is an open source
standard for writing
declarative structure of an application
programming interface api
and can either be written in either json
or yaml format
so here it is but what they're talking
about here is that there's things called
api gateways and api gateways is
a hosted version of um an api
uh and that and if you're familiar with
apis the idea is you can define
endpoints you can say
i want a route to users and it's a get
and the idea is i want to send it to
somewhere i want to send it to this
lambda to this uh virtual machine or
whatever okay
uh csps will have fully managed api
services known as api gateway
these api gateways generally support
open api standards so you can quickly
import or export apis
so like on aws you can use open api 3.0
or swagger which is 2.0
same thing with gcp same thing with
azure they all have these things okay
but in particular google uh has
apogee okay and so the apogee services
were
blended into google cloud platform okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at api management so
api management is where you have
api gateways uh that are basically
hosted api endpoints that access google
cloud resources
we've got a couple of options here we
have the apogee api platform this is an
api
develop secure deploy monitor apis
everywhere expensive but has
many features then you have cloud
endpoints this is also an api gateway
develop deploy and manage apis of google
cloud cheap and simple good integrations
with app engines and other services
i don't know if cloud endpoint came
before apogee uh but
i mean i can understand why there's two
offerings here you know they acquired a
company that had an api gateway
and then they just wanted a cheaper one
that's more like serverless
kind of offering on the right-hand side
so but we'll look at what apigee does
because it does
a ton so we have api analytics we have
api monetization where you can actually
people pay to access particular
resources via the api
apogee sense so add intelligent behavior
detection to protect apis from attack
apogee hybrid so manage api on-premise
on google cloud or in a hybrid
environment
so you can use your apis outside of
google cloud which is cool
cloud healthcare api help secure apis
that
power actionable healthcare insights i
think that last one
is on the apogee side for cloud
endpoints
now it doesn't sound like it does much
but it has one really cool thing which
is a developer portal
so the idea is that once you've created
your api you can press a button and it
takes about 10 minutes
what we'll do is it'll spin up a a a
website
or web app that allows you to explore
the api and that's really useful if
you're just like looking for
documentation or you want to interact
with the api
for the developers on your team and i
really like that feature so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at data analytics
services for the google cloud platform
so the number one here is
bigquery understand your data using
fully managed highly scalable data
warehouse with built-in
machine learning you've got cloud
composer create schedule monitor and
manage workflows using a fully managed
orchestration service
built on top of apache airflow you got
data flow
develop real-time batch and stream data
processing pipelines
it is using apache beam in this case
cloud data fusion so quickly build and
manage data pipelines using fully
managed
code free data integrations with a
graphical interface you have data prep
by uh trifacta so explore clean and
prepare data for analysis
data proc perform batch processing
querying streaming using a manage
apache spock hadoop service
you got google data studio tell great
stories to support better business
decisions
pub sub ingest event streams from
anywhere at scale
data catalog discover and understand
your data using a fully managed
scalable data discovery and metadata
managed service
cloud life sciences process analyze and
annotate
genomic and biomedical data at scale
using containerized workflows
for the exam you want to know the
difference between data flow and data
proc
because these will come up like
side-by-side and choices and they seem
very similar because they do
the same thing actually these three all
do the same thing they're etls they
take data and they they do batch
transformations on them or streaming on
them but this one here data proc
is when you want to use hadoop uh it is
it is uh then you have data flow and
this one
is more of a fully managed service and
then cloud data fusion this is where
you actually have a graphical user
interface and it's code free
all right so you know if you understand
the difference between those three
services
uh you're going to get yourself some
extra points there on the exam
other than bigquery nothing else really
should up here just those three okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
we're looking at dataproc versus
dataflow versus cloud data fusion
because i said these three are important
to know the difference between
so data proc is for open source
pipelines it can use apache spark
apache hadoop service it's for batch
processing querying streaming
you know when i say etl or elt this is
just batch processing okay
and so one of the things
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are going to make sure we know
the difference between dataproc
dataflow and cloud data fusion because
they're going to show up on the exam
and they can get confusing okay so
dataproc
is for open source pipelines apache
spark
apache hadoop so it can do uh batch
processing querying and streaming
and so the real focus here is really on
spark because spark
is known to be the fastest tool i think
it's like 50 times faster 100 times
faster
than standard hadoop jobs uh and just
overall super super fast extremely
popular so
uh you know that is the reason why you'd
go with data proc because you're using
apache spark or hadoop the downside here
is there's more
management to be involved here some of
it's abstracted away but not all of it
then you have data flow this is a fully
managed pipeline for
batching and streaming okay it's powered
by apache beam which is technically open
source
but that is not an open source tool for
actually doing
the batching and stuff it's to manage
the pipeline okay so if you need a fully
managed service
that's what you're going to use then you
have cloud data fusion this is a
a way of visually building pipelines
it's no
code enterprise solution for building
etail pipelines
via drag and drop interface i don't
think you can use this for streaming it
has 150 plus pre-configured connectors
and transformations
so you just drag and drop stuff uh you
just run it and
as it's consumed that's what it does uh
if you're using azure this is the same
thing this is similar to azure data
factory
or aws this is uh similar as uh glue
okay
um you know again i don't think it does
streaming but i think that
cloud data fusion probably would have
the highest price point for best
performance you would be using data proc
for the least amount of headaches but
still do anything pragmatically you'd be
using data flow
okay so those are the three and remember
them okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at developer tools
now these aren't really going to show up
on the exam
or if they are we've already covered
them the most important ones
but i just wanted to go over these just
so that you had a full scope just for
your own knowledge
of things that are here i couldn't even
be bothered to even pull out icons for
this one
but let's get through it here because i
think that you know you might be able to
take something away from this that you
might use in your own
development workflow okay so you have
artifact registry so this is for storing
containers
you have the cloud sdk we covered that
earlier this is a
package to interface with the command
line interface or permanently write code
in your code
you have container registry this is the
older form of storing containers
recommended to use artifact registry
nowadays you have
code or cloud code man that's a hard one
to say
extend your ide with tools to write
debug deploy kubernetes applications so
it's just
um probably i think you installed that
with visual studio code but it's just
stuff around kubernetes cloud builds so
we looked at this
in our in our container section this is
for running
containers for build environments uh
cloud
source repository so manage code and
extend your git workflow by connecting
cloud build app engine stuff like that
it's just a way of connecting
uh get repos to various services cloud
scheduler
scheduled batch jobs big data jobs cloud
infrastructure operations
uh using a fully managed cron job
service if you're used aws
that's cloud watch right cloud tasks
asynchronously execute dispatch deliver
distributed tasks
when you're working with cloud functions
you're going to be working with cloud
tasks
cloud code for intellij so debug
production cloud apps
inside intellij okay uh tools for
powershell so you can work with
powershell with google
they got tools for visual studio code
eclipse app engine plugins
a maven app engine plugin so it's all
for java there the gradle and the maven
firebase test lab so test your mobile
apps from a variety of devices
and device configurations that one i'm
interested in checking out
firebase crash analytics but these are
all within firebase so
that's the only issue there so get
clear actionable insights into your app
issues techton
so create cid uh style pipelines using
kubernetes native
building blocks workflows orchestrate
and automate cloud
google cloud http based services that's
a serverless state machine
event arc build event driven solutions
by asynchronously
delivering events from google services
that is just a service event bus so
a lot of these we've already covered but
just just wanted to show you some of
these tools because maybe you use one of
these
ides and you just want okay i'm going to
go check this out i use
eclipse that'd be cool you know
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at hybrid and
multi-cloud services for
google cloud now it seems like we're
reiterating over the same
services again and again in different
ways and that is on purpose because i
want you to know these services
so you can remember them for the exam so
let's get to it the first is anthos so
modernize existing apps build web apps
build high uh in
hybrid and multi-cloud environments when
enabling consistency between on-premise
and cloud environments remember anthos
allows you to extend your control plane
to not only
other multi or other cloud service
providers but also
on premise can do compute and kubernetes
you have anthos deployed on vmware so
monetize existing apps and build new
apps on your vm environments they're
never going to ask you to do
a vmware deployed on or at those
deployed on vmware but vmware can show
up on the exam so you should know what
that is
anthos gke so that's google kubernetes
engine so deploy manage scale
containerized applications on kubernetes
powered by google cloud
this is this is just showing you that
anthos handles google
google kubernetes environment ethos
config management automate policy and
security at scale for your hybrid
kubernetes deployments
you have cloud run for antho so easily
leverage and uh the benefits of
combining kubernetes and serverless
apogee api management deploy secure um
and monitor apis everywhere remember you
can use apogee
in hybrid or multi multi-cloud okay so
that is one of its advantages
to google cloud marketplace for anthos
easily deploy containerized apps
with features of pre-built deployment
templates and consolidated billing
migrate for anthos so if you're trying
to
move um servers onto
google cloud this is going to be
specifically for
containers i've seen this questions on
the exam where you have to choose
between migrate for anthos
and migrate for compute engine and so if
it's a virtual machine you're using
compute engine if it's
containers you're using migrate for
anthos okay
there's operations so aggregate metrics
logs and events from your infrastructure
you get signals
uh and the speed of analysis that's
under compute
engine you have traffic director this is
a global load balancing
uh across clusters and config
sophisticated traffic control
policies for open service mesh what you
really
need to know is anthos because anthos is
what's going to show up on the exam okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at internet of things
so internet of things are physical
objects embedded with sensors software
and other technologies that stream data
to cloud services or
other edge devices an edge device is a
device that is an entry point to a
service provider network
so uh google has exactly one offering
for iots and that's iot core
securely connect and manage iot devices
using a fully managed service
if you're running what kind of things
would be iots maybe you'd have something
like
a smart plant health sensor
video security this is a the ring device
by amazon where will
uh when people press the button will
record uh you have conversational ai so
a home assistant you know like alexa
google home
uh temperature control with nest uh
there's these iot kits this is the
ada bus one but core two is pretty much
a standard one for iot gets to
start learning how to use iot uh and of
course drones so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at cloud deployment
manager so to understand this we need to
know what infrastructure is code is
so iac is the process of managing and
provisioning cloud services through
machine readable definition files so
yaml or json files
rather than manual configuration when
you want to have governance
in your cloud you want to use iac
because it it means that it will
exactly define what there is and that is
a really great way to keep track of
exact configuration okay so for google's
it's called
cloud deployment manager so that is
their iac service
you write them as yaml files and you
deploy them via the cloud cli i was a
bit surprised to see that they didn't
have like an
upload and so i was a bit confused as to
um
how they go do this if you search for
ise for google cloud you'll see
terraform a lot
which is a third party provider for some
reason they just kind of like bury their
own
iac solution but it does exist and i
don't believe there's a json format just
the yaml files
but there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at media and gaming
services
for google cloud what's interesting on
the actual exam they'll
use a gaming company as the business use
case so many times
but they never give you the choice of an
actual gaming specific service which
is a bit of a shame to me but they
actually have a service called game
servers
and delivers seamless multiplayer gaming
experience to a global player base
what this actually is it's an open
source game management server called
agnos
that runs on kubernetes and i guess the
idea here is that
um you're able to create realms so uh if
you're ever making a massively
multiplayer game
uh the idea is you can set up different
regions and the idea is that uh
you know like it's just gonna work
really easy where players come in and
say okay i'm in the u.s region
or i'm in europe and i want to connect
there things like that
they all have open queue so manage
complex media rendering tasks using open
source render manager
then they have transcoder ai so convert
video files and package them for
optimized
delivery to web mobile connected tv that
would be for video on demand kind of
stuff okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the operations
suite which is just a collection of
operation or monitoring services for
google cloud so
allows you to monitor log trace and
profile your apps and services so
the main one here is cloud monitoring
provides visibility into the performance
availability and overall health of the
cloud powered applications
you got service level monitoring so
define and measure availability
performance and other service levels
for cloud powered applications for cloud
logging air reporting you have cloud
logging so store search analyze
monitor and alert on log data and events
from google cloud and aws
air reporting identify and understand
application errors
then you have apms so you have cloud
trace fine performance
uh bottlenecks and production cloud
debugger investor
investigate code behavior and production
and cloud profilers to continuously
gather
performance information using low impact
cpus and heap profiling services
is this stuff going to show up in the
exam probably not you should just know
cloud monitoring here okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
we're going to look at a couple other
products that google has
probably going to show up in the exam
but you should know about them anyway
one thing you can do
is you can utilize google maps platform
within the gcp so if you want to create
interactive maps
uh and interact with that api you can do
that the other part is chrome enterprise
so this is a chrome management policy
to meet product productivity and
security needs we might cover it in the
security section
it's i think you can use it alongside
beyond corp
uh but which is their zero trust model
framework but uh yeah those are just two
kind of loose ends i just wanted to
throw in the course okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at firebase so this
is google's fully managed platform for
rapidly developing and deploying web and
mobile apps
really it's a platform as a service
utilizing serverless technology
firebase offers the following services
and features so uh
cloud firestore machine learning cloud
functions authentication hosting
cloud storage real-time database crash
of linux performance monitoring test lab
app distribution google analytics
in-app messaging predictions a to b
testing cloud messaging
remote config dynamic links so firebase
is basically an alternative to using
google cloud directly
for users who want to focus on building
and deploying their applications in a
highly opinion framework
if you ever heard of aws amplify it's
basic that's the aws
uh competitor for this the only thing
that uh i find
like this service is great but i find
that it's very hard to migrate off of
firebase onto google cloud
but the idea is that you know if you
just you don't really want to learn all
the the
infrastructure as the service stuff and
you just want all this convenience
around you this thing is really great
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at migration services
for google cloud the first center list
here is the database migration service
and this is when you're migrating open
source relational databases
into cloud sql didn't see this one on
the exam which is kind of a surprise
because i think that would be kind of an
essential one
might show up in the future maybe i just
didn't get any questions for that
we got bigquery data transfer service
this is when you're importing data
into bigquery again another one i did
not see
on the exam then we have migrate for
compute engine and migrate for anthos
these are two you want to remember
when you want to import from your
on-prem into
um or migrate on-prem into your google
cloud
you're going to be using compute engine
for vms and for anthos you're going to
be using containers you got to remember
the difference between these two because
they will show up in a lineup for sure
another one and this time it's for
storage not compute but you have
cloud storage transfer service so this
is when you're migrating just general
storage
like data it could be from s3 it could
be from on-prem
uh and then there's also transfer
appliance this is where
uh you are transferring storage but you
have so much data like terabytes of data
that you need a physical drive to ship
the data
so these two i'm giving you extra
emphasis here these two and these two
are going to show up
in a lineup on the exam for sure so know
the difference between them okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the
types of migration for google cloud and
they define three
and the idea here this is a migration
from on-premise to the cloud okay so
we've got a spectrum here the stuff
that's easiest is going to be the left
the stuff that's going to be the hardest
is going to be the right so we have lift
and shift
improve and move and rip and replace so
quick summaries of these three types of
migration before we
dive a little bit deeper into each of
them for lift and shift there's little
to no enough modification
we're taking the least advantage of the
cloud but it's going to be the fastest
migration strategy
for improve and move we refactor your
existing app uh take advantage of the
most
of the cloud offerings slow migration
process rip and replace we're rebuilding
from scratch
we're taking advantage of the maximum
value of the cloud offerings but it can
take the longest amount of time
so those are the three let's just
reiterate them on with a little bit more
uh text here to reinforce what they are
okay so for lift and shift move
workloads from a source environment to a
target environment
with with minor or no modifications or
refactoring
this is going to be ideal when a
workload can operate as is in the target
environment
little or no business need to change for
considerations
you this requires the least amount of
time because the amount of refactoring
is kept to a minimum
the team can continue to use the same
set of tools and skills they were using
before
doesn't take full advantage of the cloud
platform features such as horizontal
scaling
fine grain permissions highly managed
services for move and improve we
modernize the workload while
migrating to take advantage of cloud
native capabilities
so this is ideal when your architecture
or infrastructure of an app isn't
supported in the target environment
a major update to the workload is
necessary some considerations here is it
takes longer than a lift and shift
migration
it must be refactored in order for the
app to migrate
there's extra time and effort as part of
the life cycle of the app
and it requires that you learn new
skills the last one here is rip and
replace so decommission an existing app
and completely redesign and rewrite it
as a cloud native app this is ideal when
the current app isn't meeting your goals
you want to remove legacy technical debt
some considerations here is that it
requires the most amount of time to
develop
and you it requires the most amount of
time
to learn okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at migration path
and the reason i want to go through this
stuff is not because they're going to
ask questions on the exam but it's going
to help you contextualize
a lot of the business use case scenarios
because you know this isn't like a
normal
uh fundamental certification they just
make it a lot harder so you need that
contextual knowledge okay
so there are four phases of your
migration there's assess
plan deploy and optimize this is going
to be text heavy but we'll work our way
through it and you'll
leave with some knowledge okay so for
assess perform a thorough assessment and
discovery of your existing environment
in order to understand your app
and environment inventory identify app
dependencies and requirements perform
total cost of ownership calculations
and establish app benchmarks we got
plans to create the
basic cloud infrastructure for your
workloads to live in and plan how you
will move apps
this planning includes identity
management organization project
structure networking sorting your apps
and developing our prioritized migration
strategy we got deployed to design and
implement
execute a deployment process to move
your workloads to google cloud
you might also have to refine your cloud
infrastructure to deal with
the needs optimize begin to take
advantage of cloud native technologies
and capabilities to expand your business
potential to things such as performance
scalability disaster recovery cost
training as well as opening the doors to
machine learning ai integrations for
your app
so we'll spend more time right now into
each of these four phases just to kind
of cement this knowledge okay
phase one this is the assessment phase
you gather information about the
workloads you want to migrate
and their current runtime environment so
you're gonna take an inventory build a
list of your machines hardware
specifications
operating systems and licenses you'll
have catalog apps so build a catalog
matrix
to help you organize apps into
categories based on the complexity and
risk
in moving to google cloud i don't think
we show it in here but the idea is if
you want to see it they have an example
in the google cloud
documentation educate your organization
about google cloud
so train and certify your software and
network engineers on how the cloud works
and what google cloud products use maybe
you could use this course to do that
experiment and design proof of concepts
so choose a
poc and implement it uh calculate the
toss
uh the total cost of ownership tco so
compare your costs on google cloud
with the cost you have today use the
google calculator
choose which workloads to migrate first
so identify apps with features that make
them likely to be first movers all right
and starting with a less complex app
lowers your initial risk because later
you can apply your team's new knowledge
to harder migration apps phase two so in
the plan phase you provision to
configure
the uh the cloud infrastructure and
services that will support your
workloads on google cloud so
establish user and service identities so
for google accounts an account
that usually belongs to an individual
user that interacts with google cloud
service accounts an account that usually
belongs to an app or a service rather a
user
google groups a name collection of
google accounts
google workspace domains a virtual group
of all the group accounts
that have been created in your
organization group workspace accounts
it's good to know what all these things
are because
you know there is overlap in the course
for these okay
cloud identity domains these domains are
like google workspaces but they don't
have access to google
workspace applications this is one you
just need and we cover cloud identity
but this is just when you need
um access to google cloud but not to um
you know the g65 or the the g suite okay
so design your resource uh organization
so organize your resources using
uh the google resource hierarchy
organizations are the root of a resource
hierarchy and represent a real
organization such as a company
folders are an additional layer of
isolation between projects that can be
seen as sub organizations
projects are base level organization
entities and must be used to access
other google cloud resources hierarchy
architectures we have environment
oriented function oriented granular
access oriented we cover these
uh in its own section because that's how
important it is this one
super super important for this course is
understanding the stuff you'll see exam
questions
around our resource hierarchies okay
define groups and roles for resource
access so set up groups and roles to
grant the
necessary access to resources design
your network topology and establish
connectivity so set up the network
topology a community from your existing
environment to google cloud
this could be via cloud vpn peering so
vpc pairing cloud
interconnect okay and those three well
at least the two cloud vpn and cloud
network
are going to show up on the exam for
phase three this is the deploy phase
implement a deployment process and
refine it during the in
the migration so you have fully manual
deploys
lets you quickly experiment with the
platform and tools but it is error-prone
and often not documented in repeatable
configuration management tools
abbreviated to cm so
configure an environment in an automated
repeatable controlled way
uh run remote commands on vms that check
the state and remediate
of an instance to the desired
configuration state you have config
container orchestration so consider
using kubernetes so you don't have to
worry about the underlying
infrastructure in the deployment logic
so you could use google kubernetes
engine for that deployment automation so
automate the deployment process by
implementing continuous integration
and can use delivery pipeline you have
infrastructure as code
write a script that defines resources to
be created or updated in a single
deployment action
share and stand up entire workflows and
environments easily
ic tools here is google deployment
manager or hashicorp
terraform and terraform is just it's an
iac but it works across
all cloud service providers and it's
really important to know all these
different type of deploy types
at the fundamental levels that can
really help you on the exam okay
phase four the optimize phase start
optimizing your target environment so
build and train your team
train your development and operations
team to take full advantage of new
cloud environments monitor everything
monitoring is the key
to ensure that everything in your
environment is working as expected
prometheus google cloud logging google
cloud monitoring
automate everything so manual operations
are exposed to a high error risk
and are also time consuming automation
leads to cost and time saving
savings and reduces risk so we're
looking at google cloud composer which
is using apache airflow spin maker
they're not going to ask those on the
exam
codify everything so by implementing
processes such as infrastructure as code
policy as code make environments fully
audible and repeatable
use managed services instead of
self-managed ones cloud sql
automl gke app engine optimized for
performance and scalability so
horizontal scaling
vertical scaling and you want to reduce
the cost so take advantage of sustained
use discounts suds committed use
contracts
uh which sometimes are committed
committed use discounts so
cud so don't get too hung up on the word
contract there flat rate pricing
such as bigquery which i think is the
only service that does that kind of flat
rate pricing okay so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at migrate for
compute
engine and enables you to migrate lift
and shift from your virtual machines
uh with minor automatic modifications
from your source environment to the
google
compute engine the reason we're giving
this a little bit more detail is because
on the exam i just saw some more
questions that are kind of around the
feature set of compute engine
uh and so i just didn't want you get
tripped up uh on the exam okay so
continuously replicates this data from
the source to vms to google cloud
no downtime on the source via transfer
quickly
clone and test a migrated vm so after
it's migrated you can use test clones
and make sure everything's working fine
if not you can roll back i'm
highlighting this one in particular
because i saw it on the exam
easily perform all migration tasks with
google cloud console so
just understand there's no down time
with this thing it continuously
replicates and you can use test clones
all right
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at anthos for google
cloud
and i know i've mentioned mantha so many
times but it is in the
exam so that's why i want to uh show it
to you from different angles so
ethos is a modern application management
platform used for managing hybrid
architectures
that span from google cloud to other aws
or on-premise data centers running
vmware
ethos is a single control plane to
manage kubernetes compute in hybrid
scenarios
uh core components of anthos would be
infrastructure containers cluster
management
it has a managed service mesh this is
great for
seeing where your resources are and
trying to be able to define slo
service level objects to give guarantees
to your customers
multi-cluster management configuration
management
anthos is a great enabler for this with
microservices
but there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at migrate for anthos
and google kubernetes engine normally
it'll just be migrated for anthos but um
we just extend it with the full name
here so you understand what the utility
of anthos is which is for migration of
containers to
gke uh so when migrate for antos you can
migrate your vms from your support
source platforms to google kubernetes
engine anthos anthos clusters on vmware
and those clusters uh on aws so you can
bring them in from a lot of different
places
you use auto-generated container
artifacts including
container images docker files deployment
animals and persistent data volumes
to deploy migrator workloads and
integrate with services such as antho
service mesh
atlas configuration management
stackdriver cloud build for maintenance
using cicd pipelines
micropharynthis is offered at no charge
and no anthra subscription is required
when migrating to gke
charges for other gcp services uh may
still apply
okay so the big takeaway is that you use
this for migrating containers to gke
and there's no cost to doing that and
you don't need a subscription okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at storage transfer
service which allows you to quickly
import online data into cloud storage
set up a repeating schedule for
transferring data as well as transfer
data within cloud storage
from one bucket to another it's going to
enable you to move or backup data to a
cloud storage bucket either from other
cloud storage providers
or from your on-premise storage move
data from
one cloud storage bucket to another so
that it is available to different groups
of users and applications
periodically move data as part of data
processing pipeline or analytical
workflow
you can schedule one-time transfer
operations or recurring transfer
operations
delete existing objects in the
destination bucket if they don't have a
corresponding object in the source
delete data source objects after
transferring them
schedule periodic schedule
synchronization from a data source to
data sync
with advanced filters based on file
creation dates
file names and the times of day you
prefer to import data so
what i want you to understand here is
that you can use it for cross region
replication so
because you can move it on a schedule
from bucket to bucket that you can
get data from other cloud search
providers like aws
or you can get it from on premise okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at transfer appliance
and this is a hardware appliance you can
use to securely migrate large volumes of
data
so migrate hundreds of terabytes up to
one petabyte
uh comes in two configurations so 100
terabytes and 40
80 terabytes imagine when they say a
petabyte you just have multiple
multiples of these drives that you would
ship so the one on the left here would
be the 480 terabyte the one on the right
is the 100 terabyte
you can mount uh transfer appliance as
an nfs volume making it easy to drag and
drop files
or rsync from your current nas to the
appliance when you want to use transfer
appliance your data has to be
greater than 10 terabytes that's
generally when you want to do it
or it would take more than a week to
upload your data over the network you'll
want to remember these last two
they will absolutely help you on the
exam
for just features in general they're
tamper resistant so they cannot be
easily opened
apply tamper evident tags to the
shipping case they're ruggedized that
means like
they're just they have like an exterior
case that makes them uh
so they're not damaged you know trusted
platform module tpm chip is installed on
these so they're immutable root file
system and software components
that haven't been tampered with it has
hardware
at attestation so they validate the
appliance before you can connect
connect it to your device and copy data
to it
for other features when you're in
transit it has a
aes 256 encryption customer managed
encryption keys
nist 888 compliant data erasure okay
for performance features all sl drives
are ssd so there's no moving parts it's
very fast iops
multiple network conductivity options
here we got 10 gigabytes per second 40
gigabytes per second
it's uh scalability with multiple app
appliances so you use multiple
appliances to increase the transfer
speed that's
where i imagine you get up to a petabyte
of data
globally distributed processing so ships
quickly to and from the data center to
google cloud
minimal software so use common software
already on your linux or mac or windows
system
okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at ai and ml services
and the most important one here is
vertex ai
so this is google cloud's unified ml
platform for building ml solutions end
to end
and so a lot of the stuff you're going
to be doing uh when it's
ml or deep learning it's going to be
with vertex okay
so let's just kind of define what a ml
pipeline looks like so we have data
readiness
feature engineering training hyper
parameter tuning model serving
uh understanding uh edge so that would
be like deploying to the edge
like on mobile devices model monitoring
and model
management uh and so we're just gonna
break it down here uh into three
sections
and so before we get into the actual
functionality of
machine learning services we need some
way to actually
uh run these models so they're
specialized or trained or run or infer
but they have specialized um uh virtual
machines and containers so that's part
of the deep learning environment
these will be a compute that already has
pre-installed on them
uh like python and tensorflow
and they might be optimized for gpus
things like that
now that we have our compute we need a
an actual environment to build these in
and the golden standard across the board
for no matter what platform you're on is
jupiter notebooks
and every single platform just like gcp
they'll just call them like
vertex notebooks but really they're
jupiter notebooks okay
so now that we have an environment or a
developer environment we can work on and
we have our computer let's talk about
the services
throughout this pipeline so starting the
left-hand side we have data labeling
this is a service that um the idea is
that if you want to
train a supervised machine learning
model it needs to have
labeled data because it's going to use
that to learn so the idea is that you
can
uh input data and then get people to
help you label it okay
you have data sets that is just a
curation of your data that's going to be
ingested into
the um the pipeline or into the ml model
or prepared for feature engineering
uh feature store is you extracting out
key
data and making it a machine readable
for the ml model
you have experiments this is when you
are trying
different iterations of the ml model so
you need to
remember like parameters and
configurations
uh and the history about them you have
uh ai accelerators this is just
um i think this is fractional this is
fractional gpu
the idea is that if you have a a virtual
machine
and the gpus are too expensive you can
just have fractional gpus
uh visor optimization this is a
a closed closed uh source
service that does optimizations on your
um models i imagine it's for hyper
tuning
so we have training so that's where you
are just training your model so you use
uh like a a container or a virtual
machine to do that
then there's actually the predictions so
that you um
doing inference uh explainable ai so the
idea is there's this big
there's a big concern about the ethics
or responsibility of ai and so
if you can see how it works then you can
uh
detect for bias or other unfair unfair
things
we have hybrid ai so i imagine that is
just being able to
take a model and deploy it on a phone or
low end devices
like on the edge closer to the the
people uh for model model we have
continuous monitoring you want to watch
for things like
um uh drift or drag degradation because
if you have a
a machine learning model uh it can like
it can get worse at predictions over
time you know that sounds very unusual
but it's something that can happen
so you want to watch out for that kind
of stuff and for model management we can
collect a bunch of metadata
and i imagine that would be just for
like we'd have um
a model catalog like a place to store
our models for easier deployment
then we want to automate this entire
thing so we have pipelines this is
called
ml ops it's the automation of the
end-to-end pipeline for building
training inferring
you know deploying a model then we have
auto ml
and so this is um basically automates a
bunch of this away it's kind of like
your platform as a service for
machine learning so this can do it for
vision for video
for language for translation for for
tables
the idea is you just upload uh your data
and then it pretty much does the rest
for you uh it will actually
run a bunch of experiments and you'll
just choose which is the best one
uh so it really makes it easy if you
don't know what you're doing okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at tensorflow so
tensorflow is a low-level deep learning
machine learning framework created by
the google brain team
and tensorflow is written in python c
plus plus
cuda and there are apis to allow you to
use various other
languages and so tensorflow is all based
around this idea of a tensor
so a tensor is a multi-dimensional array
and so they call it ts.tensor in their
their stuff and it's similar to a numpy
and the array of objects and so
tf.tensors
can reside in accelerator memory like a
gpu
so they're basically a new type of data
structure that's just very specialized
for
machine learning and google actually has
created their own hardware called a
tensor processing unit specifically
optimized
for tensorflow and the tensor data
structure
the way you write tensorflow is in
python an example of an ml model in
tensorflow is here on the left hand side
technically this is curious curious is a
high level abstraction
of tensorflow and so it can get a bit
confusing
initially the difference in crease and
tensorflow but they're essentially the
same thing because keras is
packaged with tensorflow for the google
cloud platform they specifically offer
tensorflow enterprise so they accelerate
and scale ml workloads
on the cloud with compatibility tested
and optimized tensorflow
along with enterprise ready services and
support okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are talking about vertex ai again
and the reason why is i just want you to
understand the history of it like how it
came about
uh to avoid some confusion in the google
cloud console
so vertex ai is the unification of ai
platform and the addition of automl
to offer an end-to-end solution for all
your custom ml and dl needs
so ai platform is technically uh
deprecated
you can still use it but it's not
recommended to uh
to use the platform they're always
suggesting you to migrate over
to vertex ai but the idea here is you'd
be able to prepare
supervised training training with data
labeling notebooks to write and document
building ml models
a model registry to hold all your
trained models pipelines for setting up
automated ci cd
to rapidly deploy new changes also known
as mlops
and the other component to vertex ai is
automl so easily trained
high quality custom ml models you just
upload your data
choose what you want to predict and it
does the rest okay
uh and i actually had a bit of a hard
time finding this service i was typing
like automl
but really there's a thing in there
which is called tables and so
you could build and deploy machine
learning models on structured data so
you just like
you'd upload the the or actually be a
data set so you upload a data set and
from there you say okay i want to
analyze this tabular data okay through
automl
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at ml and dl
environments so we're talking about the
compute and the notebooks okay so to
predict train tune predict for machine
learning models you need to use compute
optimize
and specialize for ml and dl tasks so an
ml
compute solution will be pre
pre-packaged with specific ml frameworks
data science libraries and you'll have
to make the choice between a cpu
or utilizing gpus cpus are great for
classical machine learning so supervised
unsupervised learning things that are
math-based like or statistics-based
algorithms
gpus are really well suited for deep
learning they're very powerful but
they're also really really expensive so
you got to really decide whether you
really want to use gpus or not
you have deep learning images and you
have deep learning containers
so here i'm launching up a notebook
instance so
a notebook instance has to utilize some
kind of um
compute and so i believe this is a vm
here that we're launching
and it has a tensorflow enterprise as
the
pre-packaged ml framework it probably
has data science libraries along with it
and uh here it is using gpus so we have
nvidia tesla t4
and of course there's cpus alongside
gpus but
you know just use the gpus on their own
there's also cloud gpu so this adds gpus
to your workloads for machine learning
scientific computing 3d visualization
why do you need this well this is
fractional gpus because gpus are so
expensive
sometimes people just need a little bit
of gpus and that's where this service
kind of fulfills that
cost effective gap for notebooks it's a
web-based application for authoring
documents that combine live code
narrative text equations visualizations
a notebook makes it easy to code all the
steps in ml solution while intermixing
documentation
it makes it easy to rerun segments of
code for a fast and iterative developer
experience
vertex ai notebooks are powered by
jupiter labs ide so jupyter is the
industry standard for interactive
notebooks
for building ml models or for data
analysis if you're already in the data
sphere you know what this is if you
don't
you should go out there and learn it
it's very useful so that is the ide
and then this is the jupiter notebook
okay
so yeah there you go
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the ai services
offering for google cloud platform
so ai is when machines mimic human
behavior or can perform human tasks and
ai
leverages ml and dl and generally ai
refers to fully managed ml sas offerings
i don't know why google decided to call
vertex ai with ai in it because it's
really just for ml
and and deep learning anytime we just
say aye people just think fully managed
services okay but these are the fully
managed services that
google offers they're not part of vertex
ai so they're just outside of it
um but let's take a look here so we have
vision ai it derives insights from
images text and more
and custom or pre-trained models video
ai enabled powerful content discovery
engaging video experiences
natural language api so derive insights
from unstructured text
recommendations ai so provide a catalog
of records
will make suggest recommendations to
users
translation so dynamically translate
between languages
document ai natural language processing
to train and simulate human review of
documents talent solution the capability
to create
update read update delete job postings
this one is such an
oddball you know i think i looked at it
before but i don't fully understand it
for the exam uh you know
they will they might give you a lineup
of vision or
video ai okay so if you know what these
generally do it's not really that hard
to figure out here
so we don't have to go very deep on
these ai services okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at
conversational ai and this is technology
that can participate in conversations
with humans so chat bots voice
assistants
interactive voice recognition systems so
ivrs
uh use cases here would be online
customer support accessibility
hr processes healthcare internet of
things computer software
mostly we're seeing it as the first one
there online customer support
so google has really good conversational
ai and they have a few different
offerings here so we have agent assist
empower human agents with continuous
support during calls by identifying
intent
providing real-time and step-by-step
assistance you got dialog flow so
build engaging voice and text-based
conversational interfaces
and they have more than one offering
here so they have dialogue cx so
provides an advanced
agent type suitable for large or very
large agents
a dialog flow es so provides the
standard
agent type suitable for small and simple
agents just some auxiliary services here
we have text to speech so convert text
to natural sounding speech
using ml and speech to text to convert
speech to text using power of ml
i suppose the last two there should have
been our ai service lineup but we got
through it
will you see this stuff on the exam
probably not but you should know it
because it's one of google's
greatest strengths and i'm really
surprised that didn't have it in the
exam
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at identity and
access services and also
security services for the google cloud
platform
so the top here we have identity and
access management so i
am this establishes find great identity
and access management for google cloud
resources
we've got cloud identity so easily
manage user identities devices and
applications from one console
identity platform add google grade
identity access management to your apps
beyond corp enterprise a zero trust
solution that
enables secure access with integrated
threat and data protection
identity aware proxy that's always
useful beyond corp so
use identity and context to guard access
to your applications of vms
manage service for microsoft active
directory
active directory so this is just if you
need active directory and you want it
hosted on
google you can do it that way resource
manager this is a
hierarchical managed resources on google
cloud
security key enforcement so enforce the
use of security keys to help prevent
account takeovers
tighten security keys to defend against
account takeovers from phishing attacks
these are security keys made by google
not going to show up in the exam but
they look really cool
they're supposed to be really good so
check them out before we move on to the
next slide i just want to give some
focus here
you want to know what im is you want to
know what cloud identity is you want to
know what beyond corp
identity aware proxy is you definitely
want to know
what managed service for microsoft
active directory is these are the ones
that are going to show up on the exam
okay
moving on to security so access
transparency get visibility over uh
your cloud provider through near
real-time logs binary authorization so
deploy
only trusted containers on kubernetes
engines cloud asset inventory so view
monitor
analyze google cloud and anthony's
assets across projects and services
cloud audit logs gain visibility into
who did what where when all that stuff
on google cloud
cloud data loss prevention sometimes i
write
protection in there but it's prevention
discover and redact sensitive data
cloud hsm protect cryptographic keys
with a fully managed hardware security
module service
cloud key management service manage
encryption keys on the cloud
this one is the multi-tenant this one is
the single tenant okay
security command center so understand
your security uh and data attack service
shielded vms so deploy hardened virtual
machines on google cloud
vpc service controls protect sensitive
data in google cloud services using
security perimeters incident response
management improve your incident and
medium time to mitigate
i'm just going to erase the ink here for
a second the ones you should be focused
on for this exam
is cloud data loss protect prevention
and security command center that's why i
give them the icons here so they stand
out okay
so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at user protection
services and this is like stuff that
would be offered via
android or via the chrome browser right
so
um you know not core to google cloud but
you should know these things anyway so
you get phishing protection so help
protect your users from phishing sites
recaptcha enterprise so help protect
your websites from fraudulent activity
spam and abuse
web risks so detect malicious urls on
your website and in client apps
but i thought this one was the most
interesting is that if you want this
i'm not a robot thing you can get that
in google cloud okay and put it on
within your apps okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at secure by design
infrastructure for
google cloud and this isn't exactly
going to show up in the exam but the
idea here is it's going to
help you understand to what level google
takes its security
seriousness okay so we have operational
device security so
develop and deploy infrastructure
software using rigorous security
practices
operation teams detect and respond to
threats to infrastructure from both
inside and external actors 24 7
365. okay internet communication
communications over internet to public
cloud service
are encrypted in transit network and
infrastructure have multiple layers of
protection to defend our customers
against denials of service
attacks for identity identities and
users and services are strongly
authenticated
access to sensitive data is protected by
advanced tools like phishing resistant
security keys
storage services so data stored in the
infrastructure is automatically
encrypted at rest and distributed for
availability
reliability guards against unauthorized
access and service interruptions
service deployment any application that
runs on our infrastructure is deployed
with security in mind
we don't assume any trust between
services and we
we use multiple mechanisms to establish
and maintain trust
infrastructure was designed to be
multi-tenant from the start
hardware infrastructure from the
physical premises to the purpose
built servers networking equipment and
customer security chips
to our custom security chips to the
low-level software
stack running on every machine our
entire hardware infrastructure is google
controlled
secured and hardened uh data centers so
google data centers features
layered security with custom design
electronic access cards alarms vehicle
access barriers perimeter fencing metal
detectors biometrics
laser beams okay laser beam intrusion
detection
they're monitored 24 7 by high
resolution cameras that can detect and
track intruders only approved
employees with specific roles may enter
continuous availability infrastructure
underpins how google cloud delivers
services that meet our high standards
for performance resi
resilience availability correctness
security
design operation and delivery all play a
role in making service continuously
available
so hopefully that makes you confident in
google security practices but there you
go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at compliance report
manager this provides you with easy
on-demand access to critical compliance
resources at no additional cost
really this is just downloadable pdfs
that prove that gcp is compliant with
various compliance
and security standards so you don't have
to log in to access this you just go
to the compliance reports manager uh and
it's not even in google cloud it's in
the marketing websites
and you just check box what you want and
then you can go ahead and download that
and
read through it and see that they're
being compliant okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are going to look at a bunch of
different compliance programs that
google is meeting
not the most exhaustive list but the
most popular and these will be the most
popular with other cloud service
providers
and they're good to know okay so we'll
work our way through here
the first here we have is the iso and
iac
uh or iec these are commonly used
together because
one is international standards for
software and the other one is like when
you're using physical
or physical devices like hardware okay
so we have control implementation
guidance
enhanced focus on cloud security
protection of personal data
in the cloud so we talk about personally
identifiable information
privacy information management system
framework so outlines controls and
processes to manage data privacy and
protect
pii i know ctos they're always going for
the 2701
but the numbers are there too useful to
remember so 2701 27017 27 018
uh 27701 and i do actually have these
memorized because that's how frequently
they come up
uh we have uh systems and organization
control sock
and there's three layers of socks sock
one sock two stock three so stock one
18 standard and uh standards and report
on the effectiveness of internal
controls
at a service organization relevant to
clients internal
control over their financial reporting
i'm not hearing people going after stock
one but they're always going for stock
too
evaluates internal controls policies
procedures that directly relate to
security of a system
at an organization stock three a report
based on
trust service criterias that can be
freely distributed yet here
2701 a bunch and sock two a bunch okay
uh pci dss so payment card industry data
security standard a set of security
standards designed to ensure all
companies that accept
process store and transmit credit card
information maintain a secure
environment
you got fips so federal information
processing standard
140 hyphen 2 so us and canadian
government standard
that specifies the security requirements
for cryptographic modules to protect
sensitive information
this one's one you're going to want to
remember uh when you're using
um a cluster provider that stores
cryptographic keys they're going to be
fips 142
uh and it's either going to be um for
multi-10 or single tenant i think
if you're doing like cloud hsm which is
a single tenant it's going to have
fips 140 hyphen 3 okay um
which is better it's it's more more
strong okay we got the personal health
information protection act so
ph ipa i'm in ontario so this one's
pretty relevant to me
but it's just an example of one that's
outside the standard
hippo one okay we have hipaa so health
insurance portability accountability act
this is a u.s federal law that regulates
patient protected health information
we have csa so this is an independent
third-party assessment
of a cloud provider security posture
we have uh fedramp so federal risk and
authorization management program we
spent more time with this earlier on in
the course so u.s government standard
sites approach to security
authorizations for cloud service
offerings so
how the government works with the cloud
criminal justice
information services so cjis any u.s
state or
local agency that wants to access fbi's
cjis databases required to adhere to the
cjis security policy
then we have the general data
protections regulation
uh gdpr so a european privacy law
imposes new rules on
companies governments agencies
non-profits other organizations that
offer good secure
services to people in the european union
union or collect
and analyze data tied to the eu
residents you want to know gdpr you want
to know fedramp okay so there you go
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're going to look at privacy and
transparency for
google and this is more just to
communicate the practices they do for
these things okay
not necessarily going to show up your
exam but something you should know at
the fundamental level when you're
convincing the executives
why to use google cloud okay so google
cloud enterprise privacy commitments
describe how we protect the privacy of
google cloud platform and google
workspace customers
so you control your data customer data
is your data
not google's we only process your data
according to your agreements
we never use your data for uh targeting
so we do not process your customer data
to create
ads profiles or improve google ad
products which it kind of feels a bit
i feel like google's probably done it in
the past but they don't do it anymore at
least
we are transparent about our data
collection and use we're committed to
transparency compliance with regulations
like gdpr
and best privacy best practices we never
sell customer data or service data
we never sell customer to third parties
security privacy
our primary design criteria for all of
our products
prioritizing the privacy of our customer
means protecting the data you uh
you trust us with we build the strongest
security technologies into our products
google provides resources on privacy
regulations such as lgpd
gdpr ccpa the australian privacy act
my number act p-i-p-e-d-a and a bunch
more for transparency google has trust
principles
you own your data not google google does
not sell customer data to third parties
google cloud does not use customer data
for advertising
uh all customer data is encrypted by
default
we guard against insider access to your
data
we never give any government entity
backdoor access
our privacy practices are audited
against international standards so there
you go
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at cloud
armor and to understand the service we
need to know what a distributed denial
of service attack is
a ddos attack so a malicious attempt to
disrupt normal traffic by flooding a
website
with large amounts of fake traffic so
you got an attacker on one side and a
victim on the other side and the
internet sits between them
so what the attacker does is they use a
bunch of remote machines
and they issue commands to those
machines and tell those machines hey go
produce a bunch of
spoofed data and send it over the
internet
and it's going to go towards the victim
now the great thing is that when you're
using a cloud service provider you're
within their network
they generally have built-in ddos
protection now what's unusual with gcp
is they don't really
call that out very clearly but i'm sure
that they have
some layer of built-in ddos protection
but the service that provides you know
more robust ddos protection is going to
be cloud armor
now cloud armor is a bit different from
other uh
closer providers in that it does ddos
protection and it's also a web
application fireball these are usually
separated as two different services and
other providers gcp
decided to roll it into one some of its
feature sets are ip-based and geo-based
access controls
support for hybrid and multi-cloud
deployments adaptive protection
detect and mitigate attacks against your
cloud load balancing workloads
predefined waff rules to mitigate owav's
top 10 risks
named ip lists rich rule language for
web application firewalls
visibility and monitoring and cloud
armor has two tiers you got the standard
so pay as you go
and manage protection plus starting at
three thousand dollars a month
pretty standard to see those two tier
prices for
ddos protection not that standard to see
these two tools rolled into one but
that's just how they do it okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at private cloud
which allows you to package google cloud
resources into service offerings that
can be made available
and discoverable in a catalog internally
to your organization to quickly
deploy govern stacks and workloads so
this is what the catalog would look like
the idea is that you would build
different kinds of products within this
catalog
or workloads whatever you want to call
them stacks and the idea here is
uh you would apply permissions to say
who in your organization is allowed to
launch them
and so this is a great way to stay
compliant because you have these
workloads that you uh your
uh your developers or your engineers
have made sure that are safe to be used
within your organization
and then it allows your departments to
just procure
resources they need okay so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at security command
center
and this is a centralized security and
risk management platform for your google
cloud resources
so there's a lot that you can do in here
i don't know if you can make it out
but you got threat detectors vm patching
cryptographic keys binary authorization
security standards you might have
noticed these terms as we're uh
listing through them very very quickly
so there's a lot of stuff that lives
within this
command center that you can do uh three
things i want to highlight
that could be relevant to your exam is
asset discovery and inventory so
inventory and historical information
about your google cloud resources
threat detection so audits your cloud
resources for security vulnerabilities
threat prevention fixed security
misconfigurations with single click
remediation
if the exam is asking you which service
has a holistic view or
everything in one place to do stuff for
security this is the service okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at google cloud data
loss prevention so dlps detect and
protect
sensitive information within gcp's
storage repositories
so we're looking at personally
identifiable information so pii so any
data that can be used to identify a
specific individual
really great example here is of mick
lovin from a movie from 10 years ago he
has a fake id here but it gets the point
we're talking about uh you know driver's
licenses uh
government ids passports email address
mailing address birthdays any of that
kind of personal identifiable
information
then there is protected health
informations phis
this is very similar except it's talking
about the identity health information
about a patient
some of it features of dlp here it
provides tools to classify
mask tokenize and transfer sensitive
data support for structured and
unstructured data
create dashboards and audit reports
automate tagging remediation policy
based findings connect dlp
results into the security command center
data catalog or export
to your own security information and
event management system siem or
governance tool
schedule inspection jobs directly in the
console ui over 120 built-in information
types so info types
and info types define what sensitive
information can be scanned
so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at beyondcorp for the
google cloud so the xero trust model
operates on the principle of trust no
one
verify everything and so the idea here
is malicious actors are being able to
bypass conventional access controls
demonstrating traditional security
measures are no longer sufficient
so beyond corp is google's
implementation of the xero trust model
and it's going to allow us to do things
such as single sign-on access control
policies access proxies
user-based authentication device-based
authentication
authorization and by shifting access
controls from the network perimeter to
individual users
beyondcorp enables secure work from
virtually any location without the need
of a traditional vpn
so the principles here for beyond corp
are access to services must
not be determined by the network from
which you connect access to services is
granted based on contextual factors from
the user and their device access to
services must be authenticated
authorized and encrypted okay
so a zero trust model puts identity as
the
primary security perimeter because
remember we shift that over to the users
away from
traditional firewalls to be protected
beyond corp is just
itself is just a collection of identity
access and security services to meet the
zero
trust model requirements okay so uh
that's where it gets confusing because
there's beyond corp enterprise which
actually is a service and beyond corp is
more
of a conceptual idea of these uh
identity access and security services
okay so
the idea is that we have apps and data
so web apps virtual machines
sas applications infrastructure apis
we're trying to restrict control access
to these things
uh to mitigate uh security risks right
and so on the left-hand side we have um
user trust and device trust right
and this is where we're gonna be looking
at their identity and their behavior
for devices its identity and the posture
posture being
the conditions in which the environment
they're in right
so the idea is that they're going to
come into the google network through
a global front front end and this is
where we're going to get context
location and time so that could be
extracting information like the ip the
location the region the session age the
time the device type things like that
we're going to pass that through a rules
engine and then from there we have an
enforcement point where
it makes further decisions before it
accesses our apps
and data so this is generally the idea
of a zero trust model okay
uh and this is kind of the rough outline
of where beyond corp is going to be
um the idea here is that we now
incorporate services so here we're using
cloud identity
this is for endpoint verification this
is just google's front end this isn't a
service in particular this is just the
google network okay
then you have access context manager and
then for enforcement points we have
cloud
iap cloud iam cloud identity
vpc service controls i've highlighted
the three in yellow because to me that's
really what beyondcorp is it's adding
those three components
into it but basically beyondcorp is the
collection of all these services working
in this model okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're going to be looking at a few
services here that are identity but i
put them in the security section to kind
of group them close to beyond corp
so the first is access context manager
so access content manager allows google
cloud organizations admins to define
fine grade attribute based access
controls for projects and resources in
google cloud so
access context manager keeps mobile
forces you uh
forces that are utilizing bring your own
devices secure okay
so you create an access policy and to
determine what level of access based on
attributes such as device type operating
system ip address
user identity and so the idea here is if
it's a little bit hard to see but the
idea here is that
uh you're going to name it so i say high
access level
and then i can say okay i want to
restrict to this ip range
uh in this region you can even have
device policies and additional
information
you'll get that output and that's the
way you'll have to control it now
at high or access level doesn't do much
on its own we have to mix that in with
a vpc service control so that's what
we'll look at next
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at vpc
service controls and these allow you to
create a service parameter
and uh service perimeters function like
a firewall for gcp apis so the idea here
is you can go here and say
okay this parameter is going to be just
for these projects uh
and just for these particular services
and then you can even apply access
levels that's where access levels come
into play
and you have ingress policies and and
egress policies
now i just want to point out that i kept
on saying the word access policies
and uh google really makes it think that
you create these by yourself but they
actually are
automatically created for you when you
create an access level service perimeter
or the
iap is turned on they cannot be directly
managed by the customer
so confusing in the documentation and i
was looking for
everywhere for this but i guess they're
just kind of like there um but that's
you're that's not going to find access
controls okay
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
we are looking at cloud identity aware
proxy iap
so iep lets you establish a central
authorization layer for applications
accessed by http
s so you can use an application level
access control model
instead of relying on a network level
firewall
so you can define access policy
centrally and apply them to all of your
applications and resources
using iap when you want to enforce
access control policies for applications
and resources
so the idea here is that you go in there
they have for hbs ssh and tcp resources
and so it's only for a particular
services for app engine compute engine
https
load balancer but what you'll do is
you'll go on say i want to enforce iep
for this particular thing
and then you can open up this menu and
say okay i'm going to add these people
with this role
for this particular service so there you
go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at beyondcorp
enterprise and this is a zero trust
model platform the idea here is that you
can enable it and through the chrome
browser cloud management you can protect
against threats such as malware and
phishing
for your chrome users as they download
and upload files
beyond corp enterprise is built into the
chrome browser with no agent required
and so you might get some visuals like
this saying like okay who's at risk
for which users what domains and some
summaries of things like that so
beyond corp enterprise does identity and
context aware access controls policies
based on user identity device health
contextual factors integrated threatened
uh data protection
prevent data loss stop common threats
real-time alerts detailed reporting
support your environment cloud
on-premise hybrid access
saps apps web apps cloud resources
wherever
easy adoption with our agentless
approach non-disruptive overlays to your
existing architecture no need to install
additional agents
talking about chrome right rely on
google cloud's global infrastructure
scale reliability security of google's
networks 144 edge locations and over 200
countries and territories
so there you go that's beyond corp
enterprise but don't get mixed up with
beyondcorp which is just a collection of
services this is
a whole different beast okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the concept of a
directory service so a directory service
maps the names of network resources to
the network
addresses and the directory service is
shared information infrastructure for
locating managing administrating and
organizing resources
such as volumes folders files printers
users
groups devices telephone numbers and
other objects
a directory service is a critical
component of a networking operating
system
and a directory server also known as a
name server is a server which provides a
directory
service each resource on the network is
considered an object by the directory
server
information about our particular
resource is stored as a collection of
attributes
associated with that resource or object
so very well known directory services
would be
a dns so domain name service this is the
directory service for the internet so
you don't know but you're using it
right now there's microsoft active
directory this is basically the industry
standard
uh for uh most or almost all
organizations in the world
underneath you have azure active
directory also known as azure id this is
a managed service on the azure
cloud there's apache directory server
oracle has their own
there's open ldap cloud identity which
is google's
identity as a service provider and then
you have jumpcloud which is
a one that is kind of an agnostic one
where you can connect a bunch of
directories to it okay so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at cloud identity and
this is identity as a service by google
cloud that centrally manages users and
groups
so you get a bunch of stuff in here like
user lifecycle management account
security single sign-on cloud directory
device management reporting analytics
app management
accessible through apis does a bunch of
stuff
and the idea here is a confederate
things between google cloud
active directory azure id and many more
directory services
you can manage access and compliance
across all your all users in your domain
you can create a cloud identity account
for each of your users and groups
uh then you can use identity access
management so i am to manage access to
google cloud resources for cloud
identity account
if you want to give someone access to
your google cloud without having a
google workspace account so not having a
gmail
and the g suite this is what this is
what you would do is use cloud identity
so that it could just get access to just
google cloud
so there are two versions of cloud
identity we have free and premium
and there is a lot of features here but
let's just run through it to get the
idea or the
the scope of what cloud identity can do
so it can handle device management
and the free version we have basic
mobile management directory
or device inventory basic password a
passcode
enforcement remote account wipe
android apple ios in the premium you get
advanced mobile management
advanced passcode enforcement security
policies
application management network
management remote device wipe
reporting uh application auditing
company owned devices mobile audit mdm
rules
so that would be mobile device
management rules okay
therefore directories you have in the
free basic directory management
organizational units and groups and
they're unlimited that's pretty standard
in all directory services
admin managed groups groups for business
google cloud directory sync which we'll
give
closer attention to later on admin roles
and privileges
google admin app for android google
admin app for ios just showing you works
on both
admin sdk api so you can pragmatically
work with the directory secure ldap
for the premium we have user lifecycle
management and there's no user cap on
this
secure ldap i guess it's in both so
maybe we don't have to list it in both
there
single sign-on and automated
provisioning so for free we have setups
sso
using google as an identity provider to
access pre-integrated list of
third-party saml apps
set up sso using google as an ipd to
access custom saml apps
set up sso using a third-party ipd with
google as a
service provider for premium we have
automated user provisioning
for security we get user security
management
self-service password recovery which is
a great feature
azure ad also has this so i really like
this two-step verification
uh so i guess that's multi-factor
including security key management
uh we have enforcement control so with
security key enforcement and management
password management and strength alert
for premium first party session
management
google security center for reporting we
get admin login saml groups token audit
logs
security reports saml logs app reports
account active activity reports for
premium here we get device audit logs
auto export audit logs to bigquery and
you get an ss
or sla of 99.9 of premium
so here you can see it does a lot you
don't need to remember all the stuff for
the exam but
you know if you're going to take
anything away from here just understand
that
google cloud directory sync is a sub
service of cloud identity okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at active directory
now this isn't a
google service per se but the thing is
no matter what you're using no matter
the cloud service provider
you'll want to know active directory
inside and out because it's fundamental
knowledge and most enterprises are using
it
and now with everyone going towards a
zero trust model uh
you know identity and active directory
just go hand in hand okay
so we're gonna put some extra attention
here on this one so
microsoft introduced active directory
domain services in windows 2000 to give
organizations the ability to manage
multiple on-premise infrastructure
components
and systems using a single identity per
user
so here's the big architectural diagram
that i created so the idea is that you
have your your enterprise which is the
forest here
and these are made up of domains a
domain is a as a means to host
these different uh directory services
uh and it's also the means to which
people
authorize or authenticate uh uh to your
directory okay so the idea is that
you can think of domains as actual uh
servers and you're gonna have to have to
have redundant ones because if the main
one goes down
you'll wanna make sure people can still
log in and do their business
and you might want domains that are
closer uh
to the region uh to which they are
authenticating so things are very very
fast that's why we're seeing
a lot more here uh than just a single
one okay
when we look inside of a domain doesn't
matter if the child or domain
we have organizational units these are
just ways of
structuring maybe departments or things
like that and with organizational units
we have
objects and so objects could be groups
users printers uh servers
uh devices we saw a larger list when we
listed out directory service so we don't
need to go through it but the idea is
that
it's just basically uh things within
your network okay
uh then we have active directory domain
services uh
shortened to adds so these are the
services
or the consists of multiple directory
services all right i know it gets
confusing because there's directory
service
and then there's directory services but
these are services within a directory
service if that makes any sense
so domain services these are the
foundational foundation stone of every
windows domain network
stores information about members of the
domain including devices users verifies
the credentials
and defines the access rights the server
running this service is called
a domain controller all right so usually
when we talk about the actual server
that people are calling them domain
controllers all right
uh so uh some of the services that can
be found
uh within active directory would be
active directory
l lightweight directory service so this
is an implementation of ldap protocol
for
azure directory domain services we're
going to definitely talk about ldap in
this course
we have active directory certificates
services so it
establishes an on-premise public key
infrastructure
create validate revoke public key
certificates for internal uses
all right we have active directory
federation services so a single sign-on
we talk about single sign-on in this
course too
so users may use several web-based
services network resources
using only one set of credentials stored
at a central location
we have active directory rights
management service this is a server
server software for information rights
management ship with windows server
uses encryption and a form of selective
functionality denial
for limiting access to documents there's
a bunch of
terminology for active directory i want
to get you used to it so let's go
through it domain
is an area of a network organized by a
single authentication database
and an active directory domain is a
logical grouping of 80 objects of a
network
a domain controller is a server that
authenticates user identities and
authorizes
their access to resources so this is the
logical grouping
and this is the actual server that does
the work a domain
computer uh is a com is a computer that
is registered with a central
authentication database
a domain computer would be an 80 object
an ad object is the basic element of an
active directory
of active directory such as users groups
printers computers shared folders
gpos group policy objects is a virtual
collection of policy settings it
controls what 80 objects you have access
to
organizational units is a subdivision
within an active directory
into which you can place users groups
computers and other organizational units
very common to
make your departments out of ous
directory service
such as active directory domain service
provides the methods of storing
directory data and making the data
available to the network users
and administrators a directory service
runs on a domain
uh controller so you know hopefully you
have some kind of idea what active
directory is
uh but yeah that's the quick crash
course okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at managed service
for microsoft active directory
and this is just active directory hosted
on the google cloud platform
why would you want to do this when you
have cloud identity well there's just
a lot of uh rich features with an active
directory that a cloud identity doesn't
have or maybe your team is used to using
active directory
you can use cloud identity and active
directory together because you can just
federate your active directory over to
cloud identity
but traditionally active directory has
always been hosted on premise
however a lot of people are shifting to
the cloud because you just don't have to
deal with those servers anymore so
there is a use case for this i think a
lot of people if they're going to be
using a manage
active directory they're going to use
azure ad just because
azure or microsoft is the best at it but
other cloud service providers such as
aws and and gcp
will give you a managed version of
active directory so compatibility with
80 dependent apps
so runs real microsoft 80 controllers
uses standard active directory features
so
gpos remote server administration tools
virtually maintenance free so high
available high availability
automatically patched configured with
secure defaults protected by appropriate
network firewall rules
seamless multi-region deployment so
simply expand the service to additional
regions
while continuing to use the same manage
80 domain
hybrid identity support so support your
on-premise 80 domain to google cloud
deploy a standalone domain for your
cloud-based workloads
so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the concept of
identity providers also known as ipds
and so a system entity that creates
maintains and manages identity
information for principals
and also provides authentication
services to applications with a
federation or distributed network
a trusted provider for your user
identity that lets you use
authenticate to access other services
identity providers could be things like
facebook amazon google twitter github
and linkedin
so federate identity is a method of
linking a user's identity across
multiple separate identity management
systems and the way you're going to do
this is via open id so open standard and
decentralized authentication protocol
so this is your ability to be able to
log into a different social media
platform using google or facebook
account
open id is all about providing who you
are
you have oauth 2.0 this is the industry
standard protocol for authorization of
oauth doesn't share password data but
instead uses authorization tokens
to prove an identity between consumers
and service providers
oauth is about granting access
functionality
and i put these in the lineup because
you know what i even get these two mixed
up but they go hand in hand all right so
providing who you are
about granting access to functionality
then you have saml so security assertion
markup language is an open source
or open standard for exchanging
authentication and authorization between
an identity provider and a service
provider
an important use case for saml is single
sign on via the web browser and that's
the reason we're bringing up saml
is so that we can talk about single
sign-on
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look here at single
sign-on also known as sso
and this is an authentication scheme
that allows a user to log in with a
single id and password to different
systems and software
so sso allows it departments to
administer a single identity
that can access many machines and cloud
services so here on the right hand side
is the many things that we want to
access and on the left-hand side we have
our directory service in this case it's
azure active directory and we have a
user that wants to
connect with a single uh username and
password to all the stuff so through the
saml protocol which we covered in the
last
slide we can do single sign-on to all of
these
uh services and the key thing to
remember is that sso is seamless so once
a user logs into their primary directory
they don't have to keep on entering
their passwords in it's just gonna seem
like they
they're already logged in when they
visit these resources okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look here at
lightweight directory access protocol
ldap as an open vendor neutral industry
standard for application protocols for
accessing and maintaining distributed
directory information services
over ip and networks so a common use of
ldap is to provide a central place to
store
users and usernames and passwords ldap
enables for
same sign-on so same sign-on allows
users to
use a single id and password but they'll
have to enter it every single time they
want to log in
so the idea is you might have an active
directory
server on premise and it's going to
synchronize with an ldap
directory so you can get access to
things to like google cloud
kubernetes jenkins and you're noticing
that i'm not listing out generic web
apps these are more kind of like
heavy-duty
um workloads because that's where ldap
kind of
is used a lot okay so why use ldap when
sso is more convenient
because this is so you don't have to
enter your password username every
single time well the thing is
sso systems are often built on top of
ldap
but ldap was not designed navally to
work with web applications
so you don't do single sign-on with ldap
and a lot of times you just don't see
direct integration with them
so you'll see ldap more on on-premise or
using devops workloads like kubernetes
or jenkins
so some systems only support integration
with ldap and not sso so it's just times
when you have to use it
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at google cloud
directory sync so enables administrators
to synchronize users groups and other
data from an
active directory ldap service to their
managed service for
ad for microsoft active directory within
google so
it's just a synchronization service and
so this one will show up on the exam for
sure so make sure you know what it is
so you can choose it correctly okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look here at service
level agreements also known as sla so an
sla is a formal commitment about the
expected level of service between a
customer
and a provider so when a service level
is not met and if customer meets its
obligation under sla
customers will be eligible to receive
compensation
so financial or service credits uh you
can think of them as store credits
because you can use them towards
uh the most uh the the services provided
by the csp
whether it's compute storage databases
etc but there will be sometimes
exceptions so maybe like registering
domains because that actually cost
money okay so uh then you have service
level indicators so slis
this is a metric or measurement that
indicates what measure of performance a
customer is receiving at a given time a
sli
metric could be uptime performance
availability throughput latency error
rate
durability and correctness then you have
slos
so service level objects that is the
objective that the provider has
agreed to meet so slos are represented
as a specific target percentage over a
period time
so an example here could be uh
availability sla of 99.99
in a period of three months target
percentages
uh that you commonly see are 99.95
percent 99.99
99.999999999999
and so though that is uh not nine nines
after the decimal point so we'll say
nine nines of availability nine nines of
durability then you have one that's for
eleven so
you'd say like nine elevens of
durability
uh and so the idea here is that um the
sla contains
slos right and these are at the service
level and then the slos are based off of
the sli's
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're going to go through the slas
for google cloud platform now it's in
the exam guide but it doesn't really
show up on the exam so
uh i don't think you have to pay close
attention here and this is really boring
because we're just going to list out a
bunch of numbers
but you know maybe you'll remember some
that are 95 and some that are 99 and
that might help you on the exam so let's
get to
it so for compute engine uh and mostly
i think all of these are going to be in
the monthly and generally for uptime
but for covered services instances of
multiple zones 99.99
single instance 99.5 percent load
balancing 99.99
uh then what we have here is uh cloud
sql and cloud functions
it's a monthly uptime of 99.95 percent
for bigquery and app engines
it's uh monthly uptime for 99.99
for cloud storage it's going to vary
based on the type of storage but
standard storage in multi-region dual
region is going to be 99.95 percent
standard storage in regional location
for cloud storage near line cold line
multi-region dual region it's going to
be 99.9 percent
nearline or cold line storage class and
regional location
uh cloud storage is going to be 99.0
percent
that's because of the the durability is
reduced you're paying
for uh like i mean like it's cold line
you're not going to access it very often
so
it's less of a problem but that makes
sense why it's slower for cloudnet uh
this one is just the outlier where it's
99.9
uh and then ai platform training
prediction is 99.95
it's like the one up here i should have
grouped it up here but i didn't
uh so for big cloud bigtable we have a
bunch
of different values so if it's
multi-cluster routing so 99.
triple nines if it's less than uh or
fewer than three regions it's just two
nines
single cluster routing policies 0.9
zonal instance
0.9 for apogee
and it's very unlikely they'll ever ask
you slas for apogee on the exam but
we have them here anyway so for standard
99 for enterprise 99.9 percent for
enterprise plus 99.9 percent
for cloud spanner uh you have uh three
nines
of durability for multi-region and then
we have two nines for regional instance
so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at gcp support plans
so we got basic
standard enhanced premium and then just
for costs this one's free this one's 29
bucks this one's 500
and this one uh you have to contact
sales so this is premium is your
enterprise support
enhanced is your business support when
you're looking at aws or azure they'll
charge a hundred dollars but for some
reason
gcp charges 500 i think that is
not smart on their part because it
really makes it hard for adoption when
you are a small to medium company
um no idea why they did that but that's
just what it is okay
so uh you get unlimited access to
support for standard enhanced and
premium they just mean like
i guess to access the platform i i would
think that it's unlimited across the
board but that's just how they display
it there
for billing support that's asking
billion queries you can use email phone
or chat
uh in terms of response time uh standard
is
uh priority two so the the larger the
number the lower the priority okay
priority zero is
is the highest right so you can expect a
four hour response here
and enhanced support you're looking at
one hour response and for premium you're
looking at 15 minute response times
but i mean this varies based on this is
when you actually have a severe
issue so it's not for general questions
okay
for technical support uh you can only do
email with standard
uh and this is pretty common like with
either azure or aws they'll call it
um the standard will be just called
developer support so yeah it's just
emails
and you're looking at pretty much a
24-hour response time for that
uh and for technical support for
enhanced and premium you got
case emails and phone uh so that is a
um i don't know if they have chat
because i didn't really want to pay for
500 to find out if they had chat but
i've definitely experienced
chat via billing support and it's pretty
darn good but if you want to get on the
phone for someone you got to be paying a
lot more
for 8 out of 5 response for high impact
issues
uh so eight out of five means um eight
hours out of the day so you're standard
at five days a week so that's your
standard work week
24 7. so anytime you want to ask a
question
they're going to be able to help you out
okay you only get english support and
standard if you need japanese
mandarin chinese or korean that's an
enhanced support and premium support
and so some of the features that are
found in both enhance and premium
is active assist recommender api
third-party support cloud support api
technical support escalation
for enhanced support you get access or
you can purchase additionally technical
account advisor advisory service tas
in premium support you get a tam so a
technical account manager and so that is
a person that is assigned to you
you get event management service
operational health reviews
customer aware support new product
previews training credits and access to
purchase
mission critical services so you can see
there's a lot of stuff
here in terms of the exam i didn't see a
single question
about like what support plan does what
which i was shocked because when you do
aws and azure you
see that kind of stuff there um it's
definitely on the exam guide so i don't
know why i didn't see any questions
and people all the other people i asked
never saw those questions either maybe
they'll add them in the future so it's
worth knowing this page i think
in terms of all these feature sets
they're definitely not going to ask you
them on the exam but we're going to
cover them anyway all this stuff here
because i think that if you are learning
fundamental knowledge
and you want to convince your
stakeholders you know why to use gcp you
want to know the full offering of
support okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at active assist
recommenders so active assist is a
portfolio of intelligent tools and
capabilities to actively
assist you in managing complexity in
your cloud operations
so make improvements easily prevent
mistakes from happening find out
what went wrong quickly and so here on
the right hand side is a recommendation
where it's uh
saying this is my current configuration
but it's recommending that
i reduce this instance to 6p pcus
and 20 gigabytes so i can save a bunch
of money so
uh three activities is making proactive
improvements to your cloud with smart
recommendations preventing mistakes from
happening in the first place by giving
better analysis helping you figure out
why something went wrong by uh using
intuitive troubleshooting tools
if you use something like trusted
advisor and native bus or azure it's the
same thing okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at cloud support api
and this allows you to integrate google
cloud's customer care within your
organization's
crm so the api supports create and
manage support cases
lists create download attachments for
cases lists and create
comments and cases and so the the cloud
support api
is available to customer cares with
enhanced or premium support so
why would you want this well if you have
your own crm right so you
use a crm to have your own cases for
customers
it allows you to kind of centralize all
of your case
information in one place so that you
don't have to have
uh your users or your support team go
out and make cases
in google cloud that you can just
integrate directly into a single
platform
this is a very unique offering i haven't
seen this on a bus i haven't seen this
on azure so this is pretty cool that
gcp does this
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at third-party
technology support for
uh google cloud support okay so which
third party with
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at third-party
technology support uh for google cloud
so
support will assist you with integrating
non-google services
and open source technologies that are
running on or integrating with google
cloud services
and we got three approaches to
delivering third-party technology
support
so we have collaborative support so
google cloud partners with other
companies to create joint
support experience so netapp cloud
volumes for google cloud
ibm power f5 network b bi gip
dell technologies data stacks uh astra
data bricks so what google is saying is
that they have partnerships with these
companies and so
when it comes to supporting these
particular providers they can directly
go to the people
uh that make it to get you the best
support for it for
workload-centric support google cloud
has expertise in a variety of
third-party technologies and consists
with the setup configuration
troubleshooting of those technologies
so it's just that they're working with
stuff every day all day so you know it's
just they
accumulate that knowledge third-party
support so google cloud provides
commercially reasonably assist with
installation configuration
and troubleshooting of third-party uh
software
so operating systems databases web
servers devops tools
sql servers third-party support is
available to customer care
with enhanced or premium support so this
is really good because you know
if you use ruby on rails ruby on rails
isn't a google cloud thing but
it's nice that they'll take their best
effort or reroute it to someone that has
domain knowledge within their support
teams
but there you go
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at technical account
advisory service and this provides
proactive guidance and reactive support
to help you succeed with your cloud
journey
so taas delivers the following services
so guided onboarding to help you get
started
with enhanced support and set up your
operations with google cloud
best practices and additional support
for the most critical cases including
proactive monitoring and guidance on
case escalation
monthly quarterly yearly reviews to
assess your operational health across
google cloud and deliver recommendations
for improving your usage
of enhanced support recommended training
paths and courses tailored to your
organizational needs
when you purchase tas you pay a monthly
fee with a minimum one-year contract
after the first year your contract is
month to month
so third-party technology support is
available to customer care support with
enhancer premium support so it's just
something you can pay for additional
on top of enhanced support or premium
support just to get
you know more guidance okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at assured support so
this enables you to secure your
regulated workloads and accelerate your
path to running complying workloads on
google cloud
so for regulated workloads we have
fedramp
moderate technical support services u.s
region and support technical services
il4 technical support services cjis
technical support services fedramp high
technical support services so you can
see there's a lot going on here so to
help you meet your compliance
requirements assured support
ensures that your workloads are handled
by google support personnel that possess
certain attributes
uh the supported personnel attributes
include geographic access location
us only background checks and u.s person
statuses
i imagine this goes along with assured
workloads
but i'm not too sure but yeah there we
go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at mission critical
services so this assess and mitigates
potential service direct disruptions
for environments that are essential to
an organization and cause significant
impact to operations when disrupted
to prepare you for this service google
cloud analyzes your current operations
and onboards you to mission critical
operations mode
a mode standardized by google the
onboarding process includes the
following
assessing key elements of your mission
critical environment including
architecture
observability measurement and control
delivering a gap analysis to help you
prepare for mission critical operations
bringing your organization into mission
critical operation modes to drive
continuous improvement
of your environment through proactive
and preventive engagement
after you've onboarded you've received
the following services drills
testing training for mission critical
environments customer centric
incident reporting proactive monitoring
and case generation
priority zero so p0 support case filing
privileges with five minute response
time
war room incident management impact
prevention follow-ups
so you can see this is a pretty darn
serious service uh but it's only at the
top tier of support okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at cloud aware
support so this is a service that
provides you with a jump start to
resolving technical issues
improving your premium support
experience so while onboarding your
organization to
premium support your tam focuses on
building customer wear a support
so customer care creates customer wear
support by learning about
and maintaining information about your
architecture
partners google cloud projects and this
information ensures that your
your technical support engineers can
resolve your support cases promptly
and efficiently okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at operational health
reviews so this helps you measure your
progress and proactively address
blockers
to your goals with google cloud so the
reviews serve as a regular touch point
with your tam
where you can discuss various topics
related to your customer care experience
including
the efficiency of cloud operations
including support trends
analysis of trends in operational
metrics incidence case escalations and
outages
tracking of open cases status reports of
high priority cloud projects
so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at premium support
event management service for planned
peak events such as product launch
major sales events and with this service
customer care partners with your team to
create a plan and provide
guidance throughout the event so with
event management service your team is
supported with the following tasks so
preparing your systems for key moments
and heavy workloads
running disaster tests to proactively
resolve potential issues
developing and implementing a faster
path to resolution to reduce the impact
of any issue that might occur
so after the event your tam works with
you to review the outcomes and make
recommendations for future events
to initiate the event management service
for an upcoming event contact your tam
but there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at training credits
for premium support so
you'll receive training credits for
google cloud quick labs we'll talk about
quick labs in a moment
that you can distribute to your users in
your organization your tam identifies
learning opportunities and indicates
which training resources can be most
beneficial to your organization
with this training your developers have
resources to find answers quickly and
test out ideas in safe environments
so for a one year contract with premium
support you get 6250 credits
so just to talk a bit about qwiklabs it
is a platform
that allows you to run labs so the idea
is that it can provision resources for
you
so you don't have to worry about um
making a mistake or getting over billed
and it'll have a checklist that you can
go through to do that so
labs are becoming very common with cloud
service providers or sorry like training
providers even myself i have lab systems
uh but this is one that is owned by
google so they used to have i mean they
do they had
stuff for aws azure gcp but now that
google's bought it it's a lot more
google focused uh and also they have
some free stuff there um
there's actually ones included for this
uh digital cloud leader
course uh and they're not very good none
of the content is really covered in so
those ones
in particular aren't very good but that
doesn't mean there's not a lot of great
content on there so
you might want to go check that out okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at new product
previews so
for premium support customers you have
access to previews of new google cloud
products
by proving a product you have an
opportunity to prepare your architecture
for a new solution before it becomes
more broadly available to the market
with your organization's goals and minds
your tam analyzes your google cloud
projects
and usage to identify opportunities to
test and use new products and solutions
when your tam identifies an opportunity
they introduce you to product teams
and you help you gain access to preview
as you test the product
your tam also shares your feedback with
the product team in addition to working
with tam you can request and manage
access to previews via cloud console
in the cloud console you can check the
status of your request and manage which
users and organizations have access to
previews
having access to previews is not a big
deal i mean like if you use
azure they actually make it very easy
for anybody to test out previews and
they're rolling that stuff out all the
time
for aws you can see previews if you're
part of the
um community builders program it's not
that hard to get in but you have to be a
bit active in aws
where you get direct access to um people
building out the products
and seeing the product so it's a bit odd
that google does it this way where it's
only for their premium customers but at
least they know that
people that are enterprises paying a lot
of money they're going to give really
good feedback so maybe it's part of
their strategy and it works for them
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at technical
account managers also known as tam i
swear we covered this somewhere else
but i don't remember where so if it's
covered twice that's okay because this
one is more of the textbook
explanation that google gives you and i
imagine the other one was just me kind
of describing tams
in general so as a premium support
customer you are assigned a technical
account manager
and also known as a tam and the
technical account managers are trusted
technical advisors
that focus on operational rigor platform
health architectural stability for your
organization
so tam support and guide you through
in the following ways they can assist
you with onboarding to premium support
assess your cloud maturity and works
with you to create an adoption roadmap
and operational
uh operating model advises you on best
practices for google cloud
delivers frequent operational health
reviews connects you with
technical experts product managers
support and engineers
works with you on support cases case
escalation high priority cases
your tam will analyze the incident at
find the
root causes by default you'll receive
eight hours per week
of foundational technical account
management services if you require more
assistance you can purchase additional
tam services
but there you go that's the tam and only
at the premium support the enterprise
level
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at cloud billings
account which is used to define who pays
for a given set of google cloud
resources
as connected to a google payments
profile so over here on the right hand
side you can see that link
so projects are going to be going to
your billing account and then your
billing account is linked to a payment
profile
if you want to see uh that you can
create multiple under payment profile
you create multiple
billing accounts so here's just a single
one but it's very easy to create
multiples
so billing account includes one or more
billing contacts predefined in a
payments profile
billings can have sub accounts for
resellers so you can build resources to
be paid by your customer so let's
compare the two
so that we fully understand these two
offerings okay so for cloud billing
account it is a cloud level resource
managed in the google cloud console
tracks all of the costs charges and
usage credits incurred by the google
cloud usage
a cloud billing account can be linked to
one or more projects
projects usage is charged to the linked
billing
billing account results in a single
invoice per cloud billing account
operates in a single currency defines
who pays for a given set of resources
is connected to a google payments
profile which includes payment
instructions
to find how you pay for charges has
billing specific roles and permissions
to control
accessing and modifying billing related
functions so establish
i am so on the payments profile side
we're over here now
uh it is a google level resource managed
at payments.google.com
connects to all of your google services
such as google ads google cloud
phi phone service processes payments for
all google
services not just google cloud stores
information like names address tax id
when required legally
or who is responsible for the profile
stores your various payment
instruments so credit cards debit cards
bank accounts other payment methods
you'll be used
to buy through google in the past
functions is a document center where you
can view invoices payment history and so
on
controls who you can view and receive
invoices of various cloud billing
accounts and products so hopefully that
is clear
on the exam they're not going to ask you
to choose out of these at a lineup so i
wouldn't worry about that it's just more
for your benefit okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at billing account
types so there are two types of cloud
billing accounts we got self-serve or
online accounts
payment instrument is a credit or debit
card
ach direct debit depending on the
availability in each
country or region costs are charged
automatically to the payment instrument
connected to the cloud billing account
you can sign up for self-serve accounts
online
the documents generated for the
self-serve account include statements
payment receipts
tax invoices that are accessible to
google cloud console
then you have invoice or offline
accounts so payment instrument can be a
check or wire transfer
invoices are sent by mail or
electronically invoices are also
accessible in the cloud console
as are payment receipts you must be
eligible for invoice billing
and you can learn more about it
somewhere in the documentation so that's
kind of interesting
i don't know i don't remember seeing
whether aws or azure had that but it's
cool that you can do that kind of
offline method
for payment profile types there's two as
well we've got individuals so
you're using your account for your own
personal payments if you register your
payment profile as an individual then
you
can only manage the profile you won't be
able to add or remove users or change
permissions on the profile
and then we have business you're paying
on behalf of a business organization
partnership or educational institution
you use google payment center to pay for
uh play apps
games google services like google ads
google cloud fi phone service
a business profile allows you to add
other users to a google payment
profile you manage so that more than one
person can access or manage payment
profiles
all users added to a business profile
can see the payment
information on that profile so there you
go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at charging cycles so
for self-serve cloud billing accounts
your google cloud chart costs are
automatically charged
in one of two ways so you either have
monthly billing so costs are charged on
a regular monthly cycle
or threshold building costs are charged
when your account has occurred
a specific amount for self-serve cloud
billing accounts
your charging cycle is automatically
assigned when you create the account
you do not get to choose your charging
cycle and you cannot change the charging
cycle
for invoice uh cloud billing accounts
your typical
receive one invoice per month and the
amount of time you have
to pay your invoice so your payment
terms is determined by the agreement
you made with google so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at cloud billing i am
roles so
cloud billing lets you control which
users have administrative and cost
viewing permissions
for specified resources by setting
identity and access management so im
policies
on the resources so to grant or limit
access to cloud billing
you can set an im policy at the
organizational level the cloud billing
account level or the project level
cloud billing roles in iem include
billing account creators so this creates
a new self-serve online billing accounts
billing account administrator manage
billing accounts so but not be able to
create them
building account users so link projects
to billing accounts
building account viewers so view billing
account cost information transactions
project billing manager so link can
unlink the project to and from a billing
account
billing account cost manager so
i can view and export cost information
billing in the documentation here i've
just pulled up one this is for
uh billings admin it just shows you all
the permissions that are possible okay
so
stuff i just this is basically a
condensed list of all this information
all these descriptions and stuff
but if you want to have an idea of
exactly what you have access to you can
see that there okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at billing health
checks
and also budget alerts so billing health
checks are recommendations to avoid
common billing issues so within your
billings overview
you'll see this billing health checks
and it'll say it'll do to be read like
saying look at these things
here's some ideas and things that are
good and so over
if you click into that you can see a
full kind of checklist the first
recommendation is to go ahead and create
a budget alert so this allows you to
make multiple alert thresholds to reduce
spending
surprises and unexpected cost overruns
lots of great suggestions here but let's
take a look more detail at budget alerts
so you can narrow down the budget scope
to specific projects or specific
resources you're going to go ahead and
provide a value so here i say a hundred
dollars
notice that it draws a trend line so you
can see where your spend is currently at
and you can you set multiple thresholds
that preemptively warn you when your
approach
your budget limit so here i'm saying uh
fifty dollars ninety dollars a hundred
dollars
this is really nice because other uh
cloud service providers uh what they'll
do is you'll just set a a threshold to
say
um a single threshold which is like 20
percent and if you wanted uh
these incremented stuff you'd have to
make multiple uh
uh budget alerts or or or plans or
whatever you wanna call me other csps
but it would cost you more money whereas
this one is just you can just do it all
in one go which is really nice
so notification options so email alerts
to billing admin users
link monitoring email notification
channels to the budget uh
connect a pub sub topic uh to this
account uh this budget so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and i just want to show you how would
you get to all the cool building
features in google cloud console well
you just go to billing
in the drop down and from there you're
going to have a lot of options but the
ones that google wants you to know and
you definitely need to know these for
the exam are the built-in billing
reports there's four
that they have in mind so there's
billing reports so an interactive
pricing explorer including graph
visualization
cost table reports a tabular breakdown
of the cost to analyze details of
invoices
cost breakdown reports so at a glance
waterfall overview of monthly charges
and credit
pricing reports so access sku prices for
google cloud services
here they are just notice that they're
not one-to-one in terms of naming so
that's why i highlighted these in in
black so you could just see like
cost sales reports is called cost table
pricing reports just called pricing
things like that okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at the billing
reports
in greater detail here so building
report is to view and analyze your
google cloud usage costs
using many selectable settings and
filters so configuring various views of
cloud billing reports can help
you answer questions like these how is
my current month's
google cloud spending trending what
google cloud project cost the most
last month what google cloud service
cost me the most what are my forecasted
future costs based on historical trends
how much am i spending uh by the region
what was the cost of resources with
label x
and you can also have customized report
views that are savable and shareable so
on the exam they actually might ask you
you know like okay you want to do this
right
which uh built-in report will let you do
that so you need to remember
these okay and which they apply to all
right
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at cost table reports
and a cost of report is to access and
analyze the details of your invoices and
statements
i know this image is really small but
down below it actually shows like kind
of like a summary of
um cost just like an invoice you can
filter that out to understand those
totals and things like that
so because your generated invoices and
statement pdf only contains simple
simplified summarized views of your cost
the cost table report is available to
provide invoice or statement cost
details
such as the following including project
level cost details from your invoices
and statements including tax costs
broken down out by project includes
additional details you might need such
as
ids sku ids project numbers the
report view is customizable and
downloadable to a csv so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at cost
breakdown reports so a cost breakdown
report is an at a glance waterfall
overview of your monthly costs
and savings so this report shows the
following summarized view of monthly
charges and credits
the combined cost of your monthly google
cloud usage on demand rate calculated
using non-discounted
list prices savings realized on your
invoice due to negotiated price if
applicable for your
google cloud billing account uh savings
earned on your invoice with usage-based
credits broken down by credit type
your invoice level charge is such as tax
and adjustments so
it's they call it a waterfall because it
looks like a waterfall but the idea is
like
this is just a much clearer view than
using billing reports of course you can
get the same visualization with billing
reports it's just an easier
visualization okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at pricing reports so
use the pricing table report to access
sku prices
for google cloud services including
google cloud google maps platform
google workspace as of the date the
report is viewed the report shows the
following pricing information displays
sku prices specific to the selected
cloud billing account
if your cloud billing account has
negotiated contract pricing each sku
displays the list price
your contract price and your effective
discount if an sku is subject to tiered
pricing each pricing tier for an sku is
listed as a separate row
all the prices are shown in the currency
of the selected billing account
and the report view is customizable and
downloadable to the css view for offline
analysis
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the pricing
overview for
google cloud because they have um a lot
of different schemes for pricing
it's going to vary for service but we
can break it down into seven types of
pricing so we have the free trial
so this is a risk-free trial period with
specific limitations
uh we have free tier these are services
that have a minimum monthly limit or or
of free use and then we're more now into
compute
uh so if we have on demand the standard
price paid per hour minute seconds
milliseconds varies per service
committed use discounts a lower
uh price than on demand for agreeing to
one year or three year contract
sustained use discounts so these are
passive savings when using resources
past a period
of continuous use preemptable vm
instances instances with deep
savings but at a cost of being
interrupted flat rate pricing so
prefer a stable cost of queries rather
than paying on demand so
this is only in particular for bigquery
i don't know if they provi
plan to do it for other services we have
sole tenant node pricing so
uh dedicated compute so this is
basically a single tenant virtual
machine
so for the exam you're going to want to
know
all of these pretty well like broadly
speaking these two
aren't going to show up on the exam but
we're going to cover them anyway just
for your own benefit okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at free trial and
also free tier
so this is going to show up on the exam
but it's for your own benefit so when
you sign up for google cloud
you are going to get 90 days free for
300
uh of credits on the platform that you
can use towards uh
different types of products and services
and so there are some limitations to
this trial that we need to go through
you cannot use these on gpus to your vm
instances
gpus is generally used for machine
learning or deep learning
you can't request a quota increase so
you get 300 bucks or credits and that's
all you get
you can't create vm instances that are
based on windows server images
um you you need to verify a credit card
or other payment method to sign up
and at the end of your trial to continue
using google cloud you must upgrade to a
paid
cloud billing account upgrading early
will end your trial because you really
are in a sandbox to keep you safe that's
one of the benefits of google cloud
where other providers
like aws you have a high chance of going
over
your free trial into real spend okay
so for free tier all google cloud
customers can use select google cloud
products like compute engine cloud
storage bigquery free of charge
within uh specified monthly usage limits
when you stay within the free tier the
resources are not charged against your
future credits
to your cloud billing accounts payments
method after your trial ends
okay so um for app engine we have 28
hours per day
for f instances nine hours a day for b
instances
one gigabyte of egress so data leaving
the network
like downloads the google cloud free
tier is available only for the standard
environment so it's not for flexible for
artifact registry you have 0.5 gigabytes
of storage per month
for auto ml natural language you get 5
000 units of
prediction per month for auto ml tables
you get six nodes
hours of training and prediction for
auto ml translation you get 500
000 translated characters per month for
auto ml
video intelligence you get 40 node hours
for training
5 hours for prediction for auto ml
vision you get 40 node hours of training
and online prediction
one hour for batch classification
prediction
15 node hours for edge training for
bigquery you get
one terabytes of querying per month and
to me that is like
super awesome and one of the reasons why
i like to use bigquery as my primary
data warehouse you get 10 gigabytes of
storage per month
for cloud build you get 120 build
minutes per day for cloud functions you
get 2 million invocations per
month includes both background and http
invocations
uh four hundred thousand gigabyte
seconds two hundred thousand
are yeah two hundred thousand uh
gigahertz seconds
uh gigahertz is that gh said i think
that's what it is seconds of compute
time
five gigabytes network uh egress per
month for cloud
logging and cloud monitoring you get
free monthly logging allotment
free monthly metrics allotment uh for
natural
language you get 000 units per month
for cloud run you get 2 million requests
per month
360 000 gigabytes per second of memory
180
180 000 vcpu seconds of compute time
one gigabyte network egress from north
america per month
and the free tier is available only for
cloud run
okay uh free access to cloud shell
uh including five gigabytes persistent
disk storage so don't fear
spinning up cloud shell it's a very
useful tool
uh cloud source repository so up to five
users 50 gigabytes of storage 50
gigabytes of egress
for cloud vision 1000 units per month
for firestore one gigabytes
uh storage per month um or just in
general sorry not per month
50 000 reads to 20 000 rights 20 000
deletes per day
for google kubernetes engine no cluster
management fee
and that's a big one because um other
providers will charge you a management
fee for
uh the cluster or control plane for
autopilot or zonal clusters per
billing account for clusters created in
autopilot mode pods are billed per
second
cpus memory indus resources requests for
clusters created in standard mode each
user node is charged at a standard
compute engine pricing
for cloud storage five gigabytes per
month of regional storage so that's
pretty good
but only for the us regions 5000 class a
operations per month
50 000 class b operations per month one
gigabyte network egress from north
america to all
region destinations excluding china and
australia per month
free tier is only available in u.s east
1 u.s
west one u.s central regions usage
calculations are combined
across those regions last page i believe
of our free tier here
so for google maps you're getting 10
gigabytes messages per month for speech
to text 16 minutes
a video intelligence api 1000 units per
month
for work workflows 5000 internal steps
per month 2000 external http calls per
month
for compute engine one non-preemptable
f1 micro vm instance per month within
us west u.s central one u.s east one
30 gigabytes months hhd area
hard disk drive five gigabytes months
snap
snapshot storage in the following
regions uh one gigabyte network egress
uh your free tier uh f1 micro instance
is
limited by time not by instance so each
month eligible used for f1 micro
instances is free until you have used
the number of hours equal to that so
just remember
f1 micro when you're looking for a free
instance usage calculations are combined
across supported regions
google cloud free tier does not include
external ip
addresses
uh compute engine offers discounts for
sustainable use
of virtual machines your free tier does
uh
use doesn't factor into sustained use
gpus and tpus are not included in the
free tier offers you're always charged
for gpus and tpus
that you add vm instances and that makes
sense because they're physical pieces of
hardware they're really expensive
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at on-demand pricing
so this is when you
pay for a google cloud resource based on
a consumption based model
a consumption based model means you only
pay for what you use based on a
consumption metric
so that could be hourly minutes seconds
milliseconds
can be a multiplied by configuration
variables such as
v cpus or memory by api calls so maybe
one dollar every 1 000 transactions
on demand is ideal for low cost and it's
because it's low cost and flexible
only pay per hour short term spiky
unpredictable workloads cannot be
interrupted
and for first time apps so generally
it's the one you usually use okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at committed
use discounts also known as cuds and
this lets you commit to a
contract for deeply discounted virtual
machines on the google compute
engine it's simple and flexible and
requires no upfront costs
ideal for workloads with predictable
resources needs you purchase compute
resources so vcpus memory gpus local
ssds
discounts apply to the aggregate number
of vcpus memory gpus and local ssds with
your region
not affected by changes to your instance
machine setup you commit for payment
terms one year to three years
purchase a committed use contract for a
single project purchase
multiple contract share across many
projects by enabling shared discounts
your billed monthly for the resources
you purchased for the duration of the
term
whether or not you've actually used the
services uh
it's going to happen anyway okay so 57
percent uh
is most machine types and gpus and 70
percent is
memory optimized machine types so look
here on the right hand side
just to give you an idea so the idea is
that when you want to do committed use
you choose the product that you want
you're going to choose the plan that you
want the region
and the commitment and then it's going
to tell you your estimated savings
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at sustained use
discounts also known as
suds and these are automatic discounts
for running specific compute engine
resources for a significant portion of
the billing month
so sustained use discounts apply to the
following resources and this is broken
into
two broad categories the first is vcpus
and memory so when you're dealing with
these two components
you have general person custom and
pre-defined machine types such as you
going in and dropping down different
types of machines
compute optimized machine types memory
optimized machine types
sold tenant nodes remember that's kind
of like dedicated machines
and so here it's 10 premium cost even if
the vcpus and memory in those nodes are
covered by the committed use discounts
uh and then the other part here is that
there's ones for gpu devices
so you can apply uh suds to gpus which
is
a great savings okay applied on
incremental use after each
uh reach certain usage thresholds you
pay only for the number of minutes that
you use an instance
uh compute engines automatically give
you uh the best
uh price there's no reason to run an
instance longer for than you need it
automatically apply to the vms created
by
both google kubernetes engine and
compute engine and it does not apply to
vms created using app engines flexible
environment and data flow
okay but what i want to remember is that
suds
is if you keep on using something you're
going to save money and it's going to be
particular with
uh most cpu types most compute types and
gpus okay
oh it also does not apply to e2 and a2
machine types
i missed that there in the end so just
to kind of give you an idea of what kind
of savings you can expect
so there's ones for up to 30 percent and
that's when you're using general purpose
and one predefined and custom machine
types
memory optimized machine types shared
core machine types
sole tenant nodes and so here's kind of
the idea of usage level
uh based on also the incremental charge
okay
and then we have sustained discounts for
20 percent so general purpose n2 and 2d
predefined custom types
compute optimize types and then another
graph so for the exam
they're not you're not going to need to
know these details but you just need to
know
sdds you save money when you have
continued use okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at flat rate pricing
and this is only for
bigquery uh would it be ever be for any
other service i don't think so
but the idea here is that if you have
high volume or enterprise customers who
prefer a stable monthly cost for queries
rather than paying on demand
uh price per gigabyte of data process
this is where flat rate pricing comes
into play so you have purchase dedicate
query processing capacity
measured in bigquery slots your queries
are cons
the idea here is you consume your
queries uh uh
via this capacity and you are not billed
for bytes process if your capacity
demands exceed your committed capacity
bigquery will queue up slots and you
will not be charged
additional fees to enable this flat rate
price
uh yeah the slide doesn't want to go
forward there but to enable the flat
rate pricing
use bigquery reservations so there you
go
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at sole tenant node
pricing so
a sole tenant node a single vent a
single tenant virtual machine
is physical compute engine server that
is dedicated to hosting your own
projects vm instance you've heard me
mention sultanate many times in this
course
when you create a sole tenant node
you're a billed for all of the vcpus and
memory resources on the sole tenant
nodes
plus a sold tenancy premium which is ten
percent of the cost of all the
underlying vcpus and memory resources
it does for sustained use discounts
applied to this premium but committed
use
discounts do not after you create the
node you can place the vm on that node
and then these vms
run for no additional costs vcpus and
gigabytes of memory are charged
a minimum of one minute after one minute
of use soul tenant nodes are built
in one second increments the price of a
node type depends on the following so
number of vcpus of the node type
gigabytes of memory of the node
types region where you create the nodes
so
uh we'll sold tenant show up on the exam
probably so just make sure you
understand
you don't need to remember all the
details to it but remember just
understand what it is and
generally how expensive it is okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the google pricing
calculator so this is a free
web-based cost calculating tool to
generally calculate costs of various gcp
resources
so you do not need a gcp account to use
this tool you can create a shareable
link or email
they estimate to your organization or
key stakeholders so this is generally
what it looks like you choose the
service so here i say i want two
instances
and there's other particular details and
then it's going to
generate a cost so here it's saying it's
97 you can email it
you can change the currency uh very
straightforward so there you go
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the concept of
resource hierarchy within gcp so
this is kind of a graphic of what a
hierarchy could look like
and there's a lot of components that go
into it we did cover this
a little bit earlier in one slide about
folders where we talked about folders
projects and resources
there's a lot of moving parts here and
on the exam they're definitely going to
ask you
about resource hierarchy so let's make
sure we know this okay
first thing is a resource is a service
level uh serviceable resources that are
used to process your workloads could be
bigquery compute engine whatever
uh that is a service you want to launch
then you have resource management how
you should configure and grant access to
cloud resources from your team
set up and or team setup and
organization of your account level
resources
you have domains primary identity of
your organization
to find which users should be associated
with your org you universally administer
policy for
your users and devices linked to either
a google workspace or
cloud identity account a google
workspace or cloud identity account can
only have one
org just so you know then you have orgs
or organizations these are the root
nodes of your
google cloud hierarchy of resources you
can define settings permissions policies
for all projects folders resources cloud
billing account
is its parent organization is associated
with exactly one domain
using organization you can essentially
manage your google cloud resources and
users access
with proactive and reactive management
then you have folders this is a logical
grouping of projects and other
or other folders folders can be used to
group resources that share common ion
policies
you got projects so logical grouping of
service level resources
products can represent teams
environments organizational units
business departments and this is
basically where resource hierarchy is
very
detailed in its variants basis of
enabling services apis and
iim permissions a service level
resources
resource can only belong to a single
project you got labels so categorize and
filter your
resources with key value pairs if you
use database or azure they call these
tags okay
but here gcp they call them labels great
for cost tracking at a granular level
there are three suggested architecturals
you can use
environment oriented function oriented
and granular access oriented
they're not going to ask you what kind
of uh
architecture it is but they're going to
talk about these um like saying like
which
would be a good setup and they'll
describe kind of what the
the setup would be and that's why you
want to know these three types
and we'll go over to the docs to look at
that because that's where the most
detail is for this okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at environment
oriented hierarchy and so this is the
most simple
uh simplest one to implement and pretty
much what you would think that you would
want to do
and so the idea here is you have a
single organization
and you're going to break up your
folders into different environments so
production quality assurance and
development
and then underneath you're going to run
your application so this works pretty
well
in a very simple setup but it can pose
challenges if you have to deploy
services that are shared by multiple
environments okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at function oriented
hierarchy
uh so this one looks a little bit more
complicated but the idea here is that
you have
one organization that contains one
folder per
business function okay so notice here uh
we have apps
management and uh infrastructure
technology
and then the idea is that down below now
we can define production
uh our environments as another layer of
folders you have folders inside of
folders so
each business function folder can
contain multiple environment folders
multiple business functions are apps
management and information
technology more flexible compared to
environment oriented gives you the same
environment separation
allows you to deploy shared services
function oriented hierarchy is more
complex to manage than an environment
oriented
and it's separate access by business so
there you go
this is andrew brown from exam pro and
we are looking at granular access
oriented hierarchy so this one's a
little bit larger we have three layers
of folders
and so the idea here is we have one
organization organization that contains
folders per business unit so now
as you can see here it's retail risk
management
financial commercial i know it's hard to
read but it's hard to fit that whole
image in there
each business unit can contain one
folder per business function so now we
have our function so application sandbox
shared
uh core services data analysis
controlled services
and each business function folder can
contain one folder per
environment so production development
etc
so this is the most flexible and
accessible option
you need to spend a greater effort to
manage the structure rules and
permissions
um the network topology is more complex
so
really like when you're looking at it
the idea is that we had the three
three types so the first one was
environment oriented so this is the
environment
then you had function oriented over here
and then this one here
is granular access oriented so the idea
is that you're just adding additional
folders for organization
for organizing your resources okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are doing the
gcp follow along so the idea here is
that we are going to
just launch a bunch of cloud services uh
it's not going to be super challenging
but the idea is just to kind of help
cement the uh
the knowledge of what we've learned in
the lecture content they don't even
recommend
it necessary for the exam but i like to
do it and i think that you'll appreciate
doing it too
so once you've created your gcp account
you should have an organization and a
default project
uh and so one of the first things i want
to show you how to do
is to set up a resource hierarchy
because the idea is you have your cloud
workloads below which run in projects
and you can organize them into folders
and
this is all tied to your organization
and this is a little bit tricky
and it does show up on the exam so it's
important to know how to do this
and so that's the first thing i really
want to show you uh so
what we'll do is we'll go ahead and make
our way over to im because that's how we
do it
and it's not going to work and i'm going
to show you why and then we're going to
show you how to get permissions okay
so we'll go to iam and on the left hand
side if you expand it down below there's
one that says manage resources
now you could also go up here and type
in manage resources
because sometimes it's really hard to
find things in gcp so you just have to
kind of
work those two ways the idea is i have a
bunch of projects in here and i have my
organization and i want to go ahead and
create a folder
and so i might have a folder coming back
over to our structure here
we might want to have a folder like
applications and then production
so if i try application here
and my organization selected
notice that i have this little caution
sign says you do not have the required
permissions
resourcemanager.folders.create
permission to create folders in this
location so you go
okay well how do i get permissions i
would think that if i'm the owner i'd
have permission to everything but that's
not the case
so if we make our way back to iem all
right we go all the way back here
and we go we're under the top one here
which is
for the users and we see i have the
owner role
if you look up the documentation it's
going to say go ahead and add project or
admin folder
okay so you go admin folder or project
folder and nothing's going to appear and
the reason why is that you can apply
permissions
or roles at the project level and also
the organizational level and because of
that
the the roles that are available are
different so you're never going to find
it at the project level here
and so we've got to do is go to your
organization
all right the way you know that you're
in your org right now is that it has
this little um
uh building and notice now it's just
listing uh people at the organizational
level
and so what i can do here is go ahead
and edit the member and i'm gonna add a
role i'm just gonna type in folder
okay and so now we have folder admin
that's going to give me full access full
control
to create what i wanted to do there
which was folders now if we go to the
left hand side here and go to manage
resources
we should have an easier time creating
folders now and so we'll go ahead here
and call this
application okay we'll hit create
and give it a moment to create and
what we'll need to do is go ahead and
refresh to see that new folder and there
it is so now that we have that folder
let's go ahead and create a folder
within that folder so i think yeah if we
go ahead and hit create folder here
and we'll choose our organizational
structure
oops uh sorry so i got to go and choose
the org
and then now what we can do is choose
the folder so i want application here
and
following our guide here we're going to
go with let's say development
because we're not serious about it
running any kind of production workloads
today
we'll go ahead and create that
okay we'll go ahead and hit refresh down
below and now you can see
we have application development so let's
say we want to move
um or let's say let's we want to create
a new project that's going to sit
uh in here for our development workload
and so below down below
uh you might want to specify the names
but what i'm going to do
is create a new one in here and i'll say
create project
and this is just going to be my app
[Music]
and we will choose its location
okay we'll hit create
and it takes it doesn't take that much
time for these to build so
if we give this a hard refresh there's a
refresh button up here
we should now see our uh are by app so
if we go back to gcp at the top here i
should be able to switch over to my app
all right and so now what we'll do is go
ahead
and create stuff there but that's what i
just wanted to show you was the fact
that
you had that folders and project
structure and how easy it was to create
in some of those
headaches there um i can't remember you
probably can apply permissions at the
folder level let's just
go take a look i'm not running crazy
workloads in
um gcc so i don't always know but uh
what we'll do is go back to
the resource manager manage resources
here and i think
you can yeah i'm not sure but it's not
really in the scope of this
certification but the idea is we have
our project set up and i will make my
way back to that and now we'll start
launching some resources okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are on the gcp fall alongs for
the
digital cloud leader and uh actually
before we launch any resources i
probably should show you a bit about
uh spend and how to control your spend
so this is a new project
that we uh started up and there's
nothing really in it now i was playing
around in this other sample
project here called exam pro and i
purposely ran a bill so i could show you
what billing looks like uh because it
doesn't make a lot of sense like it's
very hard to understand it if there's no
um
uh billing happening so the left hand
side you'll go to billing
all right and we'll just give it a
moment to load here and so we have a
bunch of different options here so
reports cost tables cost breakdowns
commitments etc etc uh and so for the
exam
you're going to want to know about the
different types of reports the overview
reports cost table
cost breakdown and generally understand
the differences they're pretty
thoroughly covered in the lecture
content so you know it's not a big deal
if you don't absorb it here but
um the idea here is uh we can see
and this is just the overview we have
our cost trends so we have some nice
charts here um so it's just kind of like
a breakdown so maybe top products things
like that it's very straightforward
but over here on the right hand side we
have billing health checks and so if we
were to
click this here it's going to give us a
bunch of suggestions that we should do
and so the first is grant access to view
billing reports
assign multiple billing account
administrators
turn off billing account creator role
for domain set up a budgets alerts
link a project or close an unused
account so
um i would say that studying about
budget alert is on our high priority
here because we do not want to
end up spending more than we have so if
we go over
to budget alerts over here you can see i
have my spending limit
and showing that i've spent uh two
dollars and 43 cents out of a hundred
dollars
so if we want to go ahead and create
ourselves a budget it's pretty darn easy
i'll just say
my second budget alert
okay see i had a lot of spend the other
month there and now i don't have so much
um but the idea here is you can go and
say okay do i want to
take an account credits or not credits
would be if you were given gcp credits
uh to utilize for free a lot of times
startups get those
uh but the idea is you can go ahead and
hit next then you can specify the exact
amount
and so i could say fifty dollars right
and it shows you a line where it can
go we'll hit next and this is really
nice which i like
you don't see this in like aws where you
actually have to set up
separate building alarms but in gcp you
just if you just can do it all in one go
so the idea is if you want multiples you
just add multiple thresholds and it's
going to warn you
when it approaches those numbers and if
you go down below you can see that you
can email
receive emails about it and if you also
want to push it to
pub sub you could do that so you could
grammatically code it into your platform
in terms of the exam you just need to
know that you can set thresholds
and why you'd want to use budgets right
just to make sure
you're monitoring your spend now i don't
need to go ahead and create one because
i already have one it's a very simple
process but that is budget alerts
now if we go back over here to reports
this is really cool this is basically a
great way of visualizing your data
so you have a bunch of different options
and you can really pare down and say
okay i want to know exactly what the
spend was for this
uh service and stuff like that so if you
really want to
do visuals that's what you'd use that
reports tab for
then you have your cost table
and cost table is basically like a
dynamic invoice so the idea is like
invoices just
aren't able to show you all of the line
items and so
here we can go and expand and see every
single
uh every single charge at a granular
layer and i'm pretty
sure you can export this um download
here yeah download it as a csv
so it's a better way to um like
review your bill from like an invoice
perspective then you have cost breakdown
and this is kind of like just a
simplified report so like we have
reports up here in
uh and the overview but this is just
more so kind of so you can see it at a
glance uh per month so is it up is it
down where are we right
so not super complicated and
again the questions are not hard on the
exam but really all i wanted to show you
was those four there and how to set
a budget alert and that's pretty much
all we need to know
so what i'm going to do is make my way
back to my sample project
and now we're ready to launch some
resources okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and let's go take a look at
compute engine so what i want you to do
is go to the top left corner here onto
our hamburger menu
and we'll scroll down make our way over
to compute engine and go to vm instances
so this is where we would launch a
virtual machine so we'll give it a
moment here to
load and as you can see i've never used
it within this project so
pretty often you'll have to go ahead hit
enable so you are agreeing to
use a particular service every time you
create a project it's always going to
show you that
but we'll give it a moment to allow us
to use that api
it just takes a little bit of time and i
don't know why sometimes the ui is a
little bit buggy
sometimes it freezes like this and so if
it does do that what you'll need to do
is just go ahead and hit refresh
it's usually pretty darn good the
experience is usually pretty smooth but
not always the case so i'm going to go
ahead and hit enable again
okay and it just does not want to work
right now
so that happens and it's totally
possible that can happen what i
recommend is just uh step away
go get a tea go get a coffee and then
come on back because it'll probably work
in just a bit okay i'll see you back in
a moment
all right so uh after a short tea break
i'm back
and it's now just all of a sudden
working so uh that's the thing with
these large cloud service providers is
that their services are so massive
it's very common to run into
inconsistencies in the ui where you
think you've done something but it's
telling you you haven't
but you know you have and so you have to
have confidence knowing okay i did do
this
and just give it a little bit of
patience and time uh and just check in
again and so here you can see
actually launched multiple times because
i pressed the button four times so
actually worked the first time
but here we are and if you want a quick
start you can you can hit this button
here
and the thing is is that gcp and only
gcp does this but they have a really
really good tutorial system so if you
want to be shown around anything
you hit show me now and it'll it'll help
you step
through all the things that you need to
know and so this one is just kind of
like a tutorial
on how to do something i'm not going to
go through it this is more for you this
is how how to do it to do app with
mongodb
i don't like mongodb so i'm not doing
that today but i just want you to know
that's a great
way to start learning with gcp um but
what we'll do
and you can see we have different
instances here so vm instance templates
uh soul tenants those are dedicated
machines machine images etc tpus
but what we want to do is just go ahead
and create ourselves a regular old
virtual machine so i'll go ahead and hit
create instance
and we'll give it a moment here today's
a slow day for gcp it's usually super
fast
and here we're in here and so on the
left hand side we have new vm
instance new vm instance from template
new vm instance from machine image
or the marketplace now uh i really like
how gcp
uh shows their um forms compared to
aws and azure because they're always
like on one screen
and they're very good about showing you
the price uh which is really nice
uh and here you can do uh you get a
breakdown to kind of see where the
hidden costs are so
it's not just the cpu cost that it's
just like there is a persistent disk
uh and maybe if you're using sustained
you just use discount if you've used it
on a monthly basis
it'll show your savings notice it's like
a negative so it would
show you a reduced cost there but the
idea here is that we want to name our
instance so i'm going to say
my website okay
we'll see if it takes that we can add
labels labels are tags so i can go here
and say
um env
production we'll go ahead and add that
label other provide
providers call them tags for some reason
gcp wants to call them labels but it's
the same thing
notice we can choose our region so i'm
going to see if there is a canada region
i'm pretty sure there is
i just started typing as if i was on
azure and that's not the case i got to
scroll on down and look for it i know
there's a montreal there's always a
montreal
right there at the top and so i can
choose between my zones i'm going to
stick with zone a
notice we have general purpose and
compute optimized
uh notice as soon as i want to compute
optimize 135 dollars we'll make our way
back
e2 is i believe the most cost effective
instances another thing that's really
nice about gcp so they just have fewer
fewer things to look at so it's just a
lot easier to
get set up here but this is good for me
i don't need a
two vcpus and four gigabyte memory i
want to go super small so i'll click on
that now i'm down to seven dollars and
83
i'm a lot more comfortable about
comfortable with that we'll scroll on
down so
confidential vm services enabled a
confidential computing service on this
vm
so this service adds protection to your
data in use by keeping memory of the vm
encrypted with keys that google doesn't
have access to that sounds really good
uh so you can see we can check box that
on and we have some additional settings
we're not going to do that today but i
think that's really cool this is
something i really like is that any kind
of most instances i think most like
basically all instances can support
this container option and what it will
do is it will install
a container layer for you and then you
can just specify your container image
and it's very makes it very easy to
launch containerized
um containerized services like single
container services
azure doesn't do this uh aws doesn't do
this only gcp does this in this kind of
convenient way so i really really like
that
not to say you can't do it on aws you'd
have to go to the marketplace but that
is like a super bonus for
me for gcp uh notice there's some
advanced options here
so like you know like the the command
command arguments you'd probably specify
uh environment variables maybe the entry
point yeah that's the entry point there
if you know anything about containers
if you don't don't worry then you have
your boot disk so this is the
boot disk right and so we have some
options here it starts with 10 gigabytes
uh i would want something larger than 10
gb but we'll take a look around here so
here we could choose uh debian
or wn9 we can change our operating
system
i'm pretty comfortable with debian i i
like debian oh fedora corres that's
pretty cool
i really like fedor cores i just learned
all about that recently
you can provide your own custom images
uh you can set the size of snapshot you
can attach existing disks
but we'll do stick with debian because
that's a pretty safe one there
another one is pretty safe ascentos
that's what a lot of the
cloud service providers base their their
managed
instances on but what we'll do is scroll
on down you can see we can apply
firewall stuff
um yeah that's all fine we don't need to
do any more with that we don't need a
firewall so
we'll scroll up make sure our price is
okay seven dollars and 83 cents
you know what i'm looking for is um a
lot of times cloud service providers
will have
a startup script here it is and this
would be cloud init
okay so cloud init is a pretty
standardized or cf internet cloud in it
can't remember what it's called
but it's a standardized way of providing
your
your virtual machines with a script to
start
like it's the first thing it runs so if
we wanted to solve apache we could do
that
um i'm just trying to see if there's
like an example
here like
it's just a bash script right so i'm
just thinking yeah see it here
and this is actually exactly what i want
too so this is perfect i didn't know
they had this
and so here the idea is that we'll just
take this if you specify the first line
in a cloud in it file
as this with the shebang it's going to
know it's a
bash script but it can also take a yaml
file i believe
but anyway what this will do is it will
install it will do an update
and then it will install apache 2 and i
believe these this is actually for
debian
uh because if we were using um
uh centos it'd be like yum but apt
is for that i don't know if it needs a
pseudo in front of here it doesn't seem
to need it
uh but what we'll do is we'll put that
in there save me a lot of time i didn't
have to try to remember what to write
um you can set custom metadata we don't
need to set any custom metadata today
uh and just looking at some other stuff
availability
policy on host maintenance nope
everything is fine so we'll go ahead and
hit create
and fingers crossed that just works
um i didn't set up any ssh though
huh well if if there's options what
we'll do is we'll just launch another
one but we'll see how this one goes
so what we'll have to do is wait a
little while so i just hit refresh up
here so there's a connect option for ssh
but we're just waiting for it to start
it's just gonna spin so
um let's give it five ten minutes and
i'll see you back here in a moment okay
okay so after waiting a little bit of
time there i did have to hit the refresh
button in order to
see that green status but let's see if
our website works so what we can do is
go over to this external ip that is our
public facing ip address
hitting that button to copy it and we'll
go ahead and paste that on in there and
so
notice that it's not resolving if that's
happening it
either means two things our apache
server is not running or
our fire firewall rules is not allowing
us to
access on port 80. so that is something
we're going to need to figure out so we
need to
sshn i'm so used to providing an ssh key
or
generating during the creation process i
forgot the gcp
doesn't make you uh a set one in the
creation process you can just click here
and it'll let you in so we can open
browser in window on a custom port
view gcloud command i kind of would
prefer to do it in
the google shell so let's just try the
browser first
okay and what it will do is it will
transfer the ssh keys to the vm so you
don't have to do anything it's really
easy to get in
okay and we'll just give it a moment not
fast but
easy all right
and we're in okay so you could type in
ls
pwd just to see where we are uh let's go
see the g cloud command if that doesn't
work we'll just make our way back here
but i would rather i would like to try
to uh
use the cloud shell because i think
that's really nice we'll go view
g cloud command and there it is so what
we'll do
i'm not sure if this is going to work
but what we'll do is copy this
the following can be used in the ssh
to into the instance okay so oh running
cloud shell perfect so
if we didn't click there we could go up
here and click activate cloud shell
cloud shell is like a terminal i think
gcp was the first to have this
azure has one aws now has one but gcp
has the best experience for this
what we'll do is we'll go down here and
say view in gcloud and just hit
run in cloud shell okay gcloud is the
name of the
um the cli okay
and we'll give it a moment to start up
an instance here
i assume it's containerized it's
probably it's probably containers that's
how it's so it's able to launch so fast
usually it's super fast by the way it's
not super fast today
and then it'll run that g cloud command
it should get us into our instance
also another cool thing about gcloud is
it has a editor built in
and it looks just like vs code i'm not
going to switch over to it because i do
not want to
interrupt our terminal but if you want
to do coding you can totally do it
within the gcp platform and again that's
a lot easier than the other ones make it
out to be
so it's pre-filled it in here it looks
like this is a beta feature but we'll go
ahead and hit enter
it's requesting access we'll say
authorized
we will say yes
uh we'll say enter enter so what it did
is it generated out an ssh key for the
cloud shell and then i imagine what it's
going to do is then
take that sshk move it onto the server
and then
allow us to then authenticate that way
okay
and so i believe
yes we are in the instance because it
says my website down below so i'll type
in clear
okay and so one way we could tell if
it's working
is we could uh we could do like a curl
so if we did curl localhost
and it returns html and it does that
shows us that the apache server is
running
probably could also type in sudo apache
or maybe sudo service um
apache to status yeah and it's running
so so it's running and we we did a query
so
probably the issue has to do with the
fact that
our firewall is not open so let's go
take a look there
and see what we can do okay so we need
to go create ourselves a firewall rule
but i just remembered that we're going
to need
the ip address so i'm just clicking back
to the instance here
whenever this page loads i'm going to
grab that external ip address
and click back forward here we'll go
ahead and create ourselves a new rule
i'm just going to scroll on down and
change this over
to specify
um all or all it's just all instances in
the network
and then specify the range and put
forward slash
32 on the end there okay so the top here
we're going to type in port 80
and we'll maybe say website and we'll
say let
our website be accessible
on port 80. it probably would help to
type correctly it's not going to hurt
anything but
you know someone else reads your stuff
they want to make sure that it reads
okay
logs will leave that off default network
is fine priority is fine
ingress means inbound egress means
outbound so we want
to get in like to to get something back
right
we can allow or deny so we are allowing
if we scroll on down below we can
specify the ports this is tcp
we're going to put port 80. and then
we'll go down below and
go ahead and hit create does not like
the name must be lower case
it's hard to remember all these rules
we'll go ahead and hit create
we'll give it a moment
and what we'll do is go back to the
internet hit enter
and see if this is working
doesn't seem to be working just yet
let's give this a refresh see if our
rule appears here so
port 80 that is correct priority so this
has a high priority
so it should be applied 32 203
103. four slash 32 the 32 just means
exactly that ip address
will go up here it did not resolve so
just give me a moment i'll take uh think
about this okay
so i think we might have an easier way
to uh make firewall rules in the way we
were doing it here so what i'm going to
do is go back to my instance here
because i kind of swore that it was here
but i probably just forgot
if we go down to view network details i
think here
uh we'll get yeah so there is we don't
have any network tags so we don't have
any way to specify tag
uh but here we have the external ip and
the internal ip address and what i
wanted to see was what firewall rules
were being applied
so here if we go over here we can see
that we have port 80 so this should
be applying um and down below
we could probably do a connect
connectivity test here
and we'll see what we get back
okay we'll go ahead and create a
connectivity test we'll say
uh port 80 or port 80 test
tcp sounds good to me
and we want this to hit the 35.203.103.0
and that's the ip address we could also
just say the vm instance that's a lot
easier i like that instead
notice it's hitting the primary internal
ip so that's not going to be very useful
because we have to go from the outside
in okay so we'll do
35.203.103
this is ip address used in gcp this is
an ip address used in gcp when you yes
it is
okay um and that's correct so we'll do
port 80 we'll say
create and we'll see if we get some uh
connectivity so
it's just a way for us to effectively
see if it's working
um last time test
last packet trim transmission result so
it's probably running it but i'll just
go here and hit rerun
yeah that's fine and
do i have a refresh button here new i
don't and so
it says it's reachable okay
well it could go ahead and view the
results so we have the vm instance
the ingress egress firewall rules the
static route nat
vm instance so everything seems to be
working so maybe i'm crazy maybe our
thing is working let's go back and take
a look again
okay but it's not working another thing
we could do
is we could open up our cloud shell
and so we were using cloud shell within
the server let's just make sure we're
not on the inside we're not that's good
and what we can do is just do a curl and
paste in that ip address and see if we
get anything returned back
if it times out that means that it's not
going to work
i notice it's not it's timing out so we
still have a firewall rule issue here so
let me just try a bit more but hey we
did learn we did learn about uh
cognitivity test that's kind of nice so
we'll be back in a moment here okay
okay so i think i know the problem is i
haven't tried it yet but i was just
staring at this thinking okay i put the
ip address in why is it not working
well the problem i think is is the fact
that i provided the
ip address for the vm instance but we're
actually trying to say
what is allowed in right so it really
should be my ip address
or a public-facing internet so
what i'll do is i'm just going to say
what's my ip
okay
we'll grab this here now i bet that's
the problem because we're not trying to
allow the own server the own ip address
of the server
into itself that makes no sense it would
make more sense if it was ours so what
i'll do is go ahead and click this
we'll go ahead and edit this rule and
we'll scroll on down
and we'll switch this out for my ip
address now you could do 0.0.0.040 and
that's what you'd want to do if you're
launching a real website here
we'll go ahead and save it how
embarrassing
but uh it just goes to show it doesn't
matter how many years you work with
cloud it's it's easy to get turned
around okay
so we'll go up here hit enter and now
our website loads so there you go
it's not that hard um as long as you
know what you're doing
okay so what we'll do is we'll make our
way back
uh to our instance so we'll say compute
engine up here
probably could pin it um i don't want to
i don't really like pinning things but
so that was our instance um is there
anything else of interest to show here
not really so let's go ahead and just
delete this instance
okay and we'll hit
refresh here okay it's going to delete
i'm pretty confident about it i'm not
too concerned about this resource and so
what we'll do is go back and click on g
uh gcp or google cloud platform and uh
we'll move on to
the next follow along okay
[Music]
all right so we learned about compute
engine let's go learn about
i don't know let's say uh databases so
what we'll do on the left-hand side here
is scroll on down and let's go take a
look for
um sql so there's spanner and there's
sql so spanner
uh it's a relational like it's its own
variant of a relational database but
it's not it's neither postgres
or mysql but if you were to be launching
a web application you'd probably want to
just use the sql service so we'll go
here and we'll launch ourselves our own
sql instance i'll go ahead here and
create an instance
we have the option between mysql
postgres and sql server
i am particular to postgres so i'll go
ahead and click this
and we'll go up here and so lowercase
numbers letters so
my relational database or my
postgres and we'll need a password so
we'll go ahead and generate one there
we'll show the password just so i don't
have to
figure that out later and i need to dump
that somewhere
so i'm just pasting it off screen so
just make sure you
know where your password is uh
postgres13 seems fine to me
i like to launch things in canada so
let's go look for
canada there's montreal
and we have single zone and multi-zone
now notice does it show us the cost here
it's not but i can tell you if you have
it in multiple zones it should cost more
because you're running redundant servers
so i'm going to go single zone
okay i want it to be cost effective all
right we can even specify the zones i'm
going to say any i don't care where it's
going to go
we can customize our configuration
options so let's open it up because
we want again the lowest cost for our
example here
so we got high memory standards shared
core shared core sounds cheap
we have lightweight i'm just checking
the values here over there on the
left-hand side so
look at high memory 26 26
gigabytes that's insane mike like i
don't have a gaming computer that much
we go over here now we're down to three
seven uh seven gigabytes
that's lightweight nothing i don't see
anything changing there but i imagine
it's cheaper
that we have a shared core 600 megabytes
this has to be cheap
all right so this is the one we're going
to choose
for storage ssd is fine
we don't we're not really doing anything
real so i'm going to choose hdd
that should be cheaper right i'm going
to go 10 gigabytes because i'm not doing
anything real
enable automatic storage increase that's
something you'd want to have but for our
purposes i'm turning that off
um do we want to have a public ip
address well i do because i want to
connect
to it maybe do a query on it so we'll
leave that there you might want to turn
that off if you're running a secure
workload generally you would and you
just
only allow um access through
you know the firewalls and stuff like
that
i do not need backups today uh we don't
care what the maintenance windows is
flags are fine we don't need insights
insights are nice if you want to query
and see information
i don't think this costs extra but i'm
going to leave it off anyway we don't
need today
we can set labels as per usual so i can
say env
dev should have been dev last time too
and so i'll go ahead and create this
instance
okay now i didn't specify
a database name so maybe it's just the
the identifier
all right so i'll just wait for this to
provision i'll see you back here in a
moment okay
all right so after waiting a little
while there it looks like our instance
is ready it took about
um i don't know 10 minutes for that to
spin up uh not too bad and so
down below we have the public ip address
the outgoing ip address the connection
name
but looks like there's an easy way to
connect with the cloud shell so let's
click and see if it auto fills it in for
us that'd be really really nice
i'm not sure if that's the case but i
guess we'll find out here in a moment
right
looks like it is so it says gcloud sql
connect my postgres
puts in the username which is postgres
um so it looks good let's go ahead and
hit enter
i might have entered that in twice there
permission denied cloud sql admin api
has not been used in this project before
or is disabled enable it by visiting
this link so
i guess that's what we'll have to go
ahead and do so we'll go and click that
link there
and we'll give it a moment
say enable
usually this doesn't take too long
sometimes you can tell by going up to
the top so that's good
so what we'll do is go back and hit up
we'll hit enter and see if it connects
now
along your ip address for incoming
connection for five minutes
sounds cool can i do stuff
i'll say backslash d oh no we're waiting
okay
well not sure what's going on there
that's not too clear but i mean that's
not usually high we connect to a
postgres instance
what i would do is collect the names and
uh use something like table plus and
that's what i want to do here so that's
what we're going to do okay
all right so what i got here is a table
plus and this is just a way of
connecting to postgres instances so go
ahead and make a new connection to
postgres this is free software by the
way you can go and download it
works on windows mac and etc and so we
got to fill in a bunch of these things
so
uh we need the host we need the username
and the password so the
username is postgres
okay the password i saved earlier so i'm
going to bring that on over here and
paste that
in um the
database name would be what um
it could be this is connection name but
that's not very useful
i mean my postgres is probably because
this looks like it's this is probably
the
name of the database that's probably the
um
database name there is my postgres
what would the host be uh
usually like if it's aws they have a
connection url i suppose you could use
an ip address i'm just not used to
having that so we have a public ip
address and an outgoing ip address
let's try the public ip address here 35
203 16 181
we'll say gcp my postgres here
and so it looks like we have mostly
everything the default port is 5432 so
we'll just do
5432 we'll hit test and see if that
works
fingers crossed okay so what i'm waiting
for is this to go green
it might not go green um
let's just try connect instead
on mac it goes green you'll say hey
you're connected
and it did not connect okay so that's
fine so what we'll do is we'll give it a
little bit of check here so
what else would we need to do okay back
i'll be back here in a moment okay you
know something i was just thinking is
um you know it looks like all our
configuration settings are correct but
maybe our firewall is just not open
so what i'm going to do is make a new
tab here and we'll give it a go
it's all about trying things on the fly
here nothing's too hard for the cloud
uh and we'll go firewall i just want
firewall rules well that's app engine so
we'll go here
because i imagine this must be in a vpc
so
what we'll do is go here and create
ourselves a new rule
and i will say uh my postgres rule
and we'll go down we'll let ingress
allow
specified targets we're just going to
do all instances in the networks with a
particular ip range so
um i'm just going to get my ip i
pediatrics like i did last time so my ip
address
right
then we'll grab it there
we'll drop it in four slash 32 we'll say
tcp 5432 we'll go ahead and create that
rule
so now now that i have this rule on 5432
which is the port 4 postgres
let's go ahead well i guess we got to
wait we should probably be patient there
is the rule
i'm going to go ahead and hit test see
if it works now
probably it's not going to work if i
have that colon in the name in the
database
we'll try again just connect here
that doesn't work we'll just edit it
again test connection
is the server running 5432 still no good
okay well
i'll give it another try okay give me a
second okay so another thought i had was
i was just poking around and we have
users and databases here on the left
hand side so here we have postgres
and then here we have uh postgres again
so there is no database called
i mean again i haven't tried it but
there is no database
called my postgres database that's just
what
i wrote in because i assumed it's based
on the instance name it's just the name
of the instance
internally for gcp so what would happen
if i was
to type in postgres instead here and
then test this connection
would this work because to me like this
would make a lot more sense right
and if that doesn't work i would say
that we have the database right and the
username is right
but maybe there's something wrong with
the host or the ip address or the
connection so we go over to users
that looks fine we go to the databases
this one's called postgres so that is
fine we go to connections
um and it's
public ip to authorize a network or use
cloud sql so we said public ip address
is fine
you do not have an authorized any
external networks to connect to your
cloud sql external applications can
still connect
through cloud proxy so if we don't have
a network maybe that's our problem
so whoops what if i go and grab my ip
address here maybe that's our problem
forward slash 32 my home address
we'll hit done uh we'll hit save
scroll on down below here uh here it
says you can manage
if you're encrypted public ip address
only allow unsecured connections are
allowed to connect
and that's fine we just want to be able
to use it so what we'll do is go back
here
try this again we'll hit test
and this thing is super buggy but notice
that it's editing our postgres so i'll
see you back here in a moment okay
okay so we waited a short amount of time
and what i'm going to do is go edit and
notice my connections postgres postgres
the database password i
put in the host name and if i go ahead
and hit connect
it now connects so i don't think that
firewall rule mattered at all that's for
vm instances
uh so i probably go back and just delete
it out just to make sure
you know that is the case um so we just
type in firewall here
okay and i'm going to go ahead
and delete this rule
all right and
now just to do a sanity check
it's not uncommon for cloud service
providers to have you know
that stuff messes separately like in aws
you have
uh security groups that are like db
security groups that are specialized so
to me that's not a surprise that was
like that
we'll get go ahead and hit edit hit
connect can we still connect
yes okay so that's how we had to grant
us access
now this is postgres this is the default
table you really wouldn't be uh
making uh or or database you wouldn't be
making stuff inside of that
what you'd probably want to do is go
ahead and create a new database so what
we can do
go back to our instance here
close some tabs out so we don't get
confused and probably what we'd have to
do is create a new database in here so
we go here and i'd say
um uh you know my database
okay we'll hit create
and we'll give that a moment to create
probably the postgres user is a super
user so we can do whatever we want there
but if we go and edit our connection
we're going to leave out the database it
should allow us to connect to all
of the databases here so it should show
us postgres and the other one
we might have to select our database so
ctrl k or
oops that's not it control k okay so
there we go so we can see we have cloud
sql admin
uh my database and postgres so i'll go
ahead and click into postgres here
all right and there are no tables but i
can go
and maybe i can make a new table here
yep so there we go so we say id
and i will add a new column it will say
name
we'll make that a var char who let me
just drop down change it to varchar
or text i just prefer text okay
and we'll go ahead and save that create
untitled table oh we gotta name the
table so we'd say users here
and now it does not like here
zero length identifier create table
undefined table well i just named it up
here
the primary id would be id up here
can i save it now maybe it doesn't like
this one hold on here
i'm doing control s by the way to save
it
i never create tables this way i always
go through and make a manual connection
but i'm giving it a go here today for
the first time so zero length eliminated
identified at or near double quotations
is want to be named over here maybe
i mean it's named right i don't know it
doesn't doesn't want it
um you know that doesn't work that's
totally fine the other way we could do
this
is um i'm just thinking here
because if we like i don't have um
postgres client installed on my local
machine i don't think i do
so i don't think i can use that i can
try let's see here
no i don't think i do so uh the only way
i'd have to do this probably through
cloud shell and through cloud shell we
would have to allow the ip address
i don't know how much of a pain that is
my point is is that you know like
it's not necessary for the exam to know
how to set up a table but the idea is to
establish a connection i just wanted to
show you
how to do that and so i kind of feel
like we've kind of satisfied it there
and solved all the stuff that we wanted
to do
but what we'll do is we'll just go ahead
and destroy this and we're all good to
go okay
and what we'll do is just check box that
off or
click into there go ahead and hit delete
and we will put in the instance name
there we go
it's deleting i'm pretty confident that
we'll delete and
that's it there so we're done with that
we'll move on to the next
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
in this follow along i want to show you
google's app engine which allows you to
easily deploy
uh web applications so in the top left
corner we'll go all the way up here to
the navigation menu
and we'll scroll on down looking for app
engine which appears under serverless
so we'll go there go ahead and create
ourselves a new application
and the first thing we're going to see
is a bunch of regions we can choose from
i like to always use from canada so what
i'll do is try to find my region if it
is available it might not be which is
totally fine
um and i don't think i'm going to get
canada today
so i'll just go with u.s east one so
let's me zoom in on this map here
oh no there's canada there we go north
america northeast one great so we'll go
next
and we'll give it a moment to load it's
just thinking really hard there
thinking really hard
and i cannot tell if it's frozen so what
i'm going to do is just give it a hard
refresh here
see if that helps at all
all right so i just had to give it a
hard refresh there uh
in order for this to actually show up
but what i want you to do is
go down and we'll choose our runtime to
be a ruby because that's what i know and
love uh and we have the option between
standard and flexible
for the exam you definitely want to know
the difference uh for this follow along
not a big deal we're gonna stick with
standard here today
um and the great thing is they do have
some samples here on github so what i'm
gonna do
is right click here and just take a look
here what they have
they got a bunch of different stuff here
uh and so
what i'm thinking is we can open up our
cloud shell so i'm gonna open up cloud
shell here at the top and it actually
has an editor mode i haven't really
given this a go so let's try it
out i know what it looks like it's like
vs code um but i'm just saying i haven't
uh done a big workload in here yet so
i'm kind of curious
and we'll let that load up and oh yeah
there's me doing some big query stuff
from
earlier but what i'm going to do yeah
see i was just doing a
quick test there but what i'm going to
do here is bring in a new repo
so here um source control
i don't really use vs code but usually
you can go here and
press this button here
um and that's not really helping so
that's fine we'll open up the terminal
it's not a big deal
and i'm just going to do ls pwd to see
where i am so i'm in my home directory
and here it's going to ask me to do a
git clone so i should be able to clone
this
and we'll hit enter and so now we have
all those samples
so the question is and here down below
it says app engine four slash app engine
whatever
what i noticed is that there is no
folder called app engine so which one
will be run
well intuitively i would pick something
like rails or maybe sinatra so maybe
they have a very simple example
they also have static files so they have
sinatra and rails
but um they have a hello world example
here and if we click into it it is
sinatra so i feel that this will
probably be the easiest way to deploy
um and then we have our app yaml file
that's actually how we configure
most like like whether it's app engine
elastic bean stock or app uh azure app
services
they always have like this accompanying
configuration file that you can use with
it
i'm noticing that this is set to flex
so maybe we might want to use flex
mode and to me it doesn't really matter
whether it's standard flexible so we'll
just switch it over to flexible here
and what i'll do
is it says initialize deploy so what
i'll do is i'll just see
into that hello world directory here
oh we got a first cd into our ruby docs
and then into our hello world directory
oh look at that now there is a uh
there's an app engine right here maybe
we're already in that folder okay that's
why
so we'll do app engine and then we'll do
hello world
okay and so
we'll probably have to do a bundle
install so we'll just do a bundle
install
um gym thought cannot be required you
have etc
it could be just because this machine
doesn't have a
ruby installed so maybe we'll do um
gem install bundler actually i didn't
even check if it says ruby does this
have ruby installed
yeah it does okay and actually it's a
very recent version so we'll do
gem install bundler it's really not even
necessary to do this but it's just out
of habit i like to make sure that it
uh it bundles before deploying bundler
is just like
requirements.txt or mpm it's just ruby's
package manager
or composer if you're used to using php
and so then i can just do a bundle
install after install the packages
uh did i not just install bundler jam
install bundler yep it's installed
bundle install um
i'm i'm not really that worried about
getting it running locally i just want
to deploy it and so
in order to deploy it we will have to
run the
g cloud app deploy command we'll just
double check and make sure that's the
case here i'm pretty sure that's what it
says down below
yeah it's just as simple as this so
hopefully this works no problem
and we'll authorize it with g cloud if
you're installing this locally you
probably use g
cloud init to authenticate it's giving
us some details here it's really hard to
read this on
white on black or black on white there
but uh let's see what it's doing so
we have a description it's going to tell
us the source it's going to show us the
target url where it's going to deploy
app engine default service account
sounds good to me so we'll hit y for
yes and we'll let it go ahead and
provision
probably the most simple out of uh all
the providers in terms of like a
platform as a service i would say gcp is
out of all the three
great and so if you just take a look
there you can tell it's actually
building out a containerized image so
it gives you the idea that this is
running off of containers
also noticing that it's setting up cloud
sql
and cloud cloud sql proxy so i would
suppose if
it needed to be backed by a database um
this should be shouldn't require a
database we'll just take a look here
maybe the configuration it has that in
there nope just says environments
flex runtime ruby resources
memory to size etc so i'm not i'm not
sure why it's spinning up
a relational database there but
and this doesn't even have one but maybe
that's just part of what it does
okay so we'll just have to wait here a
little bit a while and
i'll see you back here in a moment okay
all right and so after a little while
there we can see there's a cloud
build fail um it doesn't say as to why
hold on here um you have out of gem
etc i know ruby pretty well so for me
it's not hard to figure out as to why
but looks like we're going to have to go
check the logs so
i'm not sure where the logs are so just
give me a moment i'll go figure that out
okay
all right so what i did here is i went
down below and i opened up this link
which brings us to our build details and
if we scroll all the way down the bottom
notice how many steps it's out of 11 out
of 14 so this is actually building the
container image
and when it went and uh and did a bundle
install
uh it ran into some trouble here so
you're trying to install in deployment
mode after changing your gem file
run bundle install elsewhere and add the
updated gem block
gemfile.lock to the version control
so um i think maybe we just have to get
that bundle installed to work
so what i'll do is go back here to my
editor i really wish i could figure out
how to change the theme here
is a way we can change the theme so i
can
see what i'm looking at
i'm not sure maybe settings uh
color theme and we will go
abyss oh there we go that's a little bit
better so we'll work with that i suppose
um so maybe we just need to make sure
that the bundle install works
uh which is something i try to just get
around but there's no gem lock file
that's what it's probably going to be
complaining about so if i just expand
this here
yeah notice there's no gem gem
gemfile.lock or gem lock file
so we'll do bundle install and this time
we'll just be a bit more
thorough about its read so could not
find bundler required by your home
directory to update the latest
version installed in your system do
bundle update bundler so we'll do bundle
update bundler
let's see if that works i would have
thought that we were up to the latest
version because we ran it
the lock file has been updated to
bundler 2 after which you will be unable
to return to bundler 1.
totally fine with that nobody uses
bundler 1 anymore
but if we take a look here on the left
hand side i don't see
bundler a gem lock file there so i'll do
bundle install and so now i should have
one
we have to hit refresh here i'm still
don't see one here let's do a clear and
i'll do a ls hyphen la
yeah it's right there so
oh you know why it's because i'm not
looking in the subfolder here so we're
supposed to
app engine hello world and so there's
that gem lock file so now let's go ahead
and try that deploy again
i don't know what happens when you have
a failed deploy like that so we'll just
hit enter
uh and i wonder if anything has changed
here with app engine
probably not probably a successful
deploy while that's going let's go take
a look here what was going on
through our build history so
nothing exciting here but i wanted to
see what services was so it was doing it
through
cloud build so cloud build um i imagine
it's just like um
uh aws code build which is just a build
server so it's a server that is designed
to
build things um and so that could be uh
preparing uh artifacts for code or in
this case it could be building out a
image which i think that's what it was
doing was building out an image so
that's interesting how they uh
they linked that up so we'll go ahead
and hit capital y here
and we'll let it go and deploy again and
i will see you here at the end of it and
hopefully it works or you know we'll
encounter a new era okay
all right so after waiting several
minutes here it looks like it is done
uh and it has a sense command here
called gcloud app browse i don't know if
it's going to work within the
um google cloud shell here but let's
give it a go
and see what happens
okay so it didn't detect a browser
because we're not running it on our
local machine
we're running it within uh the google
shell but that's fine we can just copy
that link
and paste it up on here and so we can
see the application is working so let's
go give it a peek
in the actual service let's see what we
can see okay
because usually usually uh we will see
some additional stuff here so i'll go
give this a hard refresh here
still showing us that we'll go ahead and
click the dashboard here and so
our app should be here
uh looks like it must be running here um
i'm just trying to distinguish okay up
in the top right corner that's where we
can see it we can see our versioning
here
we've got services okay that makes sense
if we wanted to upload different
versions or we deployed new versions i
guess it would be version management
so yeah pretty straightforward so i'd
say we're all done here
and now we just need to go ahead and
tear this down
um good question so i i mean i see this
running here so i imagine we can just go
ahead and delete it oops
i have no idea how we should delete this
so just give me a second
and i'll figure this out okay all right
so it looks like we don't
delete app engines we just disable them
so let's go ahead here and click on
disable
and we will enter this key in here
okay and so that should disable it so
why they don't let you delete them i do
not know why um
but i mean that's totally fine as long
as we're not getting build so here it
says
your app has been currently disabled
okay um so yeah there we go
so we'll just make our way back here and
move on to the next
service
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and let's go take a look
at some storage options for gcp in
specific um cloud storage so what we'll
do is scroll on down here
so we got our compute and we have our
storage and here is cloud storage
okay and you will notice
our screen's a bit messed up here just
give it a oops give it a hard refresh
here to get that
weird navigation out of the way but you
can see
that because we set up our app engine we
already have some storage
here but let's go ahead and create
ourselves a new bucket
and we'll just say uh my new bucket
okay these are globally unique names so
it's just like domain names so you might
have to put in some random
numbers there hit continue now we have
an option of multi-region dual region or
just region with the lowest latency with
a single region
i'm just going to stick with
multi-region for
this i'm going to see if i can choose
canada i actually only have three
options u.s
european union or asia if i choose
different ones what are my options do i
get north america there we go
actually i want toronto because that's
the closest place that i am here
uh clearly a multi-region would give you
the highest availability
but if you want the lowest latency and
you just want a single region more
options you probably might just want to
choose region there
okay go ahead and hit continue i like on
the right hand side it's estimating our
cost here
now we have our different storage
options this will absolutely show up on
the exam so you need to know the
difference
so standard best for short term storage
and frequently accessed data near line
best for backup and data access less
than a month
cold line best for disaster recovery and
data access less than once a quarter
archive best for long-term digital
preservation of data access less than
once a year so we're going to stick with
standard
uh and then here it says prevent public
access one of the most
common vulnerabilities for cloud service
providers is through
cloud storage when they're made public
especially on aws
i'm sure it's no different for gcp so
it's probably good to have
public access prevention turned on on
the bucket and then you have access
controls under it you have uniform and
fine grade
we're not sharing this with anybody else
so we don't have to worry about that
we'll go ahead and hit continue
you'll notice that we can set encryption
to be the google manage encryption key
or a customer manage encryption key
we'll just stick with google's
manage key there because that's very
easy you can set up a retention policy
if we check boxes we get more
information
so we could say how long we want to
retain uh stuff for
leave that off for now apply labels as
per usual we'll go ahead and create our
bucket
and so now that we have our bucket let's
go ahead and i'm gonna create a new
folder
i'm gonna call it star trek okay
and what i'll do is i'll just go grab
some images to upload just a couple
images i'll be back here in a second
okay all right so let's go ahead and
upload some files so i'm going to click
into the star trek folder we're going to
hit upload files
i'm going to go into my star trek folder
and i have a couple of graphics
from my one of my previous courses here
we'll hit upload and you'll see the
files upload
and there they are if you want to go
ahead and download them there's a
download button on the right hand side
uh we have some other options uh here
nothing super important i'm going to go
ahead and
delete these files okay
and give that a moment
not that this would cost us anything to
keep these two teeny tiny files around
but it's probably a good habit to
learn how to delete stuff at this level
here
and i'll go ahead and delete my new
bucket
and we will type in delete to permit and
delete it
okay and there you go that is google
cloud storage
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look here at
bigquery so what i want you to do is go
to the top and type in bigquery
and this is one of google's flagship
products because
it does something that other cloud
service providers does not do and it's
the fact that it's a
serverless data warehouse so other
providers like redshift or um
i'm kind of forgetting the one azure
synapse
uh things like that they are not
serverless that means that they have an
idle cost that you pay for and they're
generally really expensive
uh but big query is very cost effective
because
it can scale to zero and you're paying
for consumption
okay so uh for me it's actually a
service i definitely use
on a regular basis and i really really
like it so
just to kind of give you an idea of how
this works now if you
have not attached your credit card yet
and you're using the sandbox it is
totally safe to do this
but if you do have your credit card
attached i probably suggest not querying
if you're trying to be cost effective
here
but they have a bunch of data sets here
and so here is one for covid
and a lot of these are public data sets
or i mean this one is
at least that means that google has made
it available to you
and for this one in particular for new
users you can store up to 10 gigabytes
of data up to uh and query up to one
terabyte each month for free
so you can really play around with
bigquery in that sense once you attach a
credit card it's no longer free
actually i'm not really sure if if it's
if it's still extended to be free
outside of sandbox mode
uh but i can't be certain okay so if we
go back here we don't have to
do anything the data sets already there
we just have to reference it so
uh it was a bit hard to find any
available queries but i did find one on
this blog
post so thank you whoever did this and
let's go ahead and grab this here
and see if we can run ourselves a
successful query
notice it's going to suggest how much
data it's going to process this is
important because it's our consumption
and we'll go ahead and hit run okay
and we will see we get back and so there
we there we go we got some
data back you go ahead and explore the
data so export in data studio
or geoviz so if you have some other
things there you could see that data
create some live dashboards and things
like that but that's pretty much it
that's all i really wanted to show you
and that is bigquery
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and in this video we're just going to
take a peek into vertex
a i um i just like doing this because
at some point you know maybe your
company or you or you might be
considering
to do a little bit of ml okay and the
thing is a lot of people are scared of
it and they're really worried about it
being extremely expensive and so
this is kind of my way of just kind of
getting your toes toes uh
into the pool um so you're not too
afraid to do it so we'll go ahead here
and type in vertex ai
that is gcp's offering and we'll go
ahead and just enable it
and i wonder if i can do it in canada i
always like to pick canada if i can
montreal
be nice if it was toronto they just
don't have data i mean they have data
centers there but
there's never data centers for the main
providers there
and so we chose our region okay
and i just want to do anything like
opening a notebook that's usually what
we would want to do
but what i really want to show you is
about compute because that is the
the hidden cost uh to any type whether
it's sagemaker
um azure ml studio or
data studio ml i can't remember off the
top i had what's called vertex ai
it's just that you have to remember to
turn off the servers if you remember
that
it's very not scary to use
these services so if we want to have a
notebook so migrate your notebook i
don't have any right now but i just want
to run anything
so we'll go ahead and create ourselves a
new instance
and so here uh just like all the other
ones you'd have to choose your
environment
cuda or gpus you do not want to touch
because those are super super expensive
so we will just choose python 3. notice
it comes with scikit-learn pandas and
more
that's usually the safest one uh here if
you look here it'll tell us what it's
spinning up so four
c v cpus 15 gigabytes of ram 100
gigabytes standard so it's pretty darn
large but
that's pretty standard for what you'd
want to use
um so what we'll do is go ahead and hit
create
actually let's go take a look at
advanced options i've never clicked that
before
um no nothing exciting there so we'll go
ahead and hit create
notice this is a hundred and two dollars
a month so you if you're afraid to run
this don't do it
but i mean we're gonna turn it on and
turn it off so it's like not gonna cost
us much right
um so i'll go ahead and spin that up
there
okay and i'm not sure how fast this is
going to
start up on aws they have like ones that
will start up within one or two minutes
but i don't think that's something that
is offered on gcp or
or azure so
the green usually means it's running
setting up the proxy to jupiter lab so
this is what we really want to do is we
want to open up jupiter lab
so we'll just have to wait a little
while until that's ready okay so i'll
see you back here in a moment
all right so after waiting a very short
while there now we can see we have this
open jupiter lab so we'll go ahead and
click that
and that will give us our jupiter lab
environment this is just an ide
specialized for data scientists
or people working in the data field
notice that it comes pre-loaded with
tutorials which is pretty nice
so we have some bigquery cloud ml engine
fairing storage
if we go in here this would show us how
to work with bigquery pragmatically
and the idea here is you go ahead and
use just hit play on these
okay uh and the idea is you if you hit
play
i'm not too afraid of doing this if you
want to just watch that's totally fine
as well
but here it says locations are required
etc etc so that ran
um and so here this would just query
some public data set
so that's something we did when we did
bigquery we just ran a query there but
if we hit
run it should output the results notice
there's a asterisk it just means that
it's running
so give it a bit of time and so there is
its data so this is pretty um
you know this is pretty uh uh you know
pretty straightforward
and very similar experience to the other
providers there so once you learn one
you kind of learn them all
but yeah the real thing that you got to
be a bit fearful of is the fact that
uh you know depending on the machine
type you choose they get really
expensive so
what you can do i'm just going to check
if they have them on the left-hand side
here sometimes
the providers will have like a category
just for compute
but when you're actually in jupiter labs
you can go over here um
oh it shows the kernel session if you're
on um
aws they would actually show you the
compute here that you can shut it down
but what we can do is if we're really
concerned about it we just go here and
stop
stop the instance okay
but the thing is is that you could also
be paying for storage so that could be
kind of expensive so i'll actually just
go ahead and delete it
but we have to stop i think the instance
before we can go ahead and delete it so
we'll give this a refresh here okay
and while that's going i just want to
show you something else actually i
really like this channel called bicloud
because
they cover a lot of different kind of ai
techniques but the reason i'm bringing
it here is not to promote this channel
but more so because they'd like to link
in these google collab
files and so google collab is kind of a
way of
um utilizing it's kind of it's like a
notebook it's a like a jupiter notebook
uh or it may be a jupiter notebook it
just doesn't look one-to-one with the
jupiter labs notebook
but um it allows you to run ml models
uh but also to utilize gpus and gpus
like your graphics cards
are really really expensive in the cloud
and so this is an opportunity where you
can use it for free and you're just
sharing it with other people
and it's one of google's initiatives to
allow you to learn in a cost-free way
with google and i think it's really cool
but you could just click through this
stuff and kind of get a result so i'd go
here and hit
run and i'll just say run anyway that's
totally fine with that
okay and i can just say run all
like that and this is not going to cost
me anything like i do not have to worry
about it so that's something that's
really nice that google lets you do i
assume it's you
uh using underutilized machines or
machines that aren't being in use
so if you are learning you can just you
know use google collab
uh but if you uh if you need to use you
need to build a real model to deploy
then you're going to be doing that with
jupiter labs and vertex ai okay
so i'm going to see if that is finished
shutting down yet
is it done no
it's pending i'm going to shut that down
maybe that was causing the issue there
okay so i'll wait till it gets out of
the pending state here
and this is just running i don't know
this is even going to do
execute a 3d uh photo in painting it's
going to do something cool something
relating
relating to something to change poses
for people
okay but anyway i'll see you back here
in a moment when this is out of pending
okay
all right so just as i stopped the video
it it uh
it also stopped the instance so now i
can go ahead and delete it
we'll just say say delete
okay and that should take care of uh any
lingering costs just in case you're
following along and you do not want to
get billed
a hundred dollars by the end of the
month there probably was instances that
were a bit cheaper that we could have
chose
uh like you don't have to do this i'm
just kind of taking a look here so there
probably was
yeah so we could have we could have
chose something like this
notice that was 29 that would have been
a lot safer to do
um because when i think of like sage
maker and and azure's
uh ml studio or studio this is usually
the cost that i run my notebooks at so
probably just had a very expensive
default and we just had to change it
down below to this okay
i figured that was probably the case but
i should have showed you that as we're
doing it
so you're not super scared so really the
real cost would be thirty
and you can do a lot with that but again
you can use google cloud for free
but there you go that's it hey this is
andrew brown from exam pro and i'm going
to show you how to book a
google certification exam so in this
particular one i'm booking for the cloud
digital leader
and so the idea here is we're going to
go ahead and
register for this exam and then we would
need to choose our preferred language
and you're going to notice that up here
this is powered by criterion so
criterion
is a global testing solution similar to
psi
or pearson vue but for whatever reason
this is the one that
google's partnered with so you might
need to
log in but if you don't have one you'll
have to go ahead and create yourself a
new account
and so just looking at the details here
login password etc
address there's a lot of information to
go on here so
just notice for the asterisk i'm going
to go ahead and fill all this out
so i'll see you back here in a moment
all right so i filled in all my
information we'll go ahead and hit save
great and we've created our account so
let's go ahead and log in
so i'll just put in my username i chose
i was lucky to actually get my own name
i was really surprised
but i'll go grab my password here
great and so now we can go ahead and
register for our exam
so here we can see all the exam
exam possibilities here and so what i
want to do is go ahead
and find the one i'm looking for which
is the
digital team leader cloud digital leader
there it is
let's go ahead and hit the plus we have
two options
um on-site or proctored at this time i'm
going to do
a remote proctored exam
and so i have some options to choose
here um
so i think i would like today is
the 27th oh i got to choose my time zone
so we'll go up here in the top
i'm in the toronto time zone
and actually that's the date i want so
it's the only date on the calendar but
that's perfect for me
and i need to choose my appropriate time
and that is going to be
8 p.m
and so then we just have the usual
instructions here so no shows
cancellations reschedule
retake policy online test center
exam terms and conditions so you'll want
to go through that
and read this very very thoroughly okay
and once you're happy with it you're
gonna go ahead and hit select
i do not have a coupon but if you did
you could enter it in there
if you are happy with the time and to
make sure it's the correct exam of the
correct language go ahead and check out
and so now this is where i'm going to go
ahead and enter in my credit card
details
all right great so that's all filled in
there so let's go ahead and hit submit
and so it's just saying here that for
our registration to be complete we have
to receive a confirmation email
so i'm going to wait here a little bit
and just wait until i see that okay
so i just want to show you here i've
received it just was instantaneously
which was great since it's like zero
seconds
and so it's just a refresher of our exam
details there so
it's going to really help you find that
stuff quicker so that's all good there
and if i go ahead and hit done
there's nothing else to do there so
there you go